GOOD MORNING EVERYONE.
I COULD ASK A THE MEETING TO
COME TO ORDER -- WE OBVIOUSLY
ARE LACKING A QUORUM RIGHT NOW --
SO WE WILL PASS OVER THE VOTE
ONLY CALENDAR AND AND RETURN TO
WHEN WE WHEN WE ARE STEP OF THE
ABLE TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
AND WILL MOVE TO ITEMS TO BE
HEARD.
OUR FIRST -- ISSUE.
IS -- THE CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN AND FOR THAT WE
ARE GOING TO HAVE A PRESENTATION --
BY -- I THINK MISTER BROWN --
THE A FOR ON BEHALF OF THE ALEJO.
AND IT -- A DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
I THINK IT'S GET AWAY AS WELL SO
WELCOME.
PLEASE PROCEED WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ROSS
BROWN WITH THE LA -- I'M GONNA
GIVE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
GOVERNOR'S CAP AND TRADE --
EXPENDITURE PLAN PROPOSAL AND
PROVIDE SOME OF OUR COMMENTS I'M
GONNA BREAK IT INTO KIND OF TWO
DIFFERENT SECTIONS I THINK ALL
START OFF PROBABLY WHICH IS TO A
GENERAL OVERVIEW OF THE
CONDITION OF THE G. G. R. OUT.
SOME COMMENTS AROUND KIND OF
WHAT THE REVENUE ASSUMPTIONS ARE
AND WHAT OUR ESTIMATES ARE AND
HOW THEY COMPARE THE
MINISTRATIONS.
WHAT THAT MEANS FOR KIND OF
OVERALL RESOURCES AVAILABLE FOR
SPENDING -- AND THEN GET INTO
SOME OF THE MORE DETAILS AND OF
THE ACTUAL PROPOSALS FOR
SPENDING AND OUR COMMENTS AROUND
THOSE PROPOSALS -- SO FIRST OUT
MAYBE CALL YOUR ATTENTION TO THE
TABLE ON PAGE FOURTEEN OF YOUR
AGENDA.
WHICH GIVES A KIND OF SUMMARY OF
THE REVENUES AND EXPENDITURES
AND FUNDBALANCE -- UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S ASSUMPTIONS AROUND
REVENUE AND THEN SOME OF OUR
ESTIMATES AROUND WHAT REVENUE
WILL BE -- JUST TO GO OVER SOME
OF THE HIGH LEVEL MEMBERS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION ASSUMES TWO POINT
SIX BILLION DOLLARS IN REVENUE
IN THE CURRENT YEAR.
AND TWO POINT ONE BILLION AND
THE BUDGET YEAR -- THERE ARE
PROPOSING FOR THE BUDGET YEAR A
TWO POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
SPENDING PLAN THAT INCLUDES -- A
LITTLE OVER A HUNDRED MILLION
AND KIND OF EXPENDITURES THAT
COME OFF THE TOP TO CERTAIN --
COMMITMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
IN THE PAST AS WELL AS ABOUT ONE
POINT TWO BILLION IN CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATIONS BASED ON THE
REVENUE ESTIMATES.
AND OVER ONE BILLION IN
DISCRETIONARY SPENDING ALL GOOD
AND TO THAT PROPOSAL IN MORE
DETAIL IN JUST A MINUTE -- AND
UNDER THOSE REVENUE ASSUMPTIONS
THAT WOULD WOULD BE LESS THAN
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR FUND
BALANCE -- WE'RE PROJECTING THAT
REVENUE OVER THE CURRENT YEAR IN
THE BUDGET YEAR WOULD BE ABOUT
EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
MORE THAN WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ASSUMING IN
THEIR PROPOSAL -- ONCE YOU KIND
OF TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATIONS THAT
AUTOMATICALLY GET ALLOCATED TO
VARIOUS PROGRAMS -- WE'RE
PROJECTING THAT UNDER THOSE READ
OUR REVENUE ASSUMPTIONS -- THERE
WOULD BE ABOUT A FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR FUND
BALANCE.
AND SO THERE'S STILL QUITE A BIT
OF UNCERTAINTY AROUND REVENUE
BUT WE DO THINK THAT THERE WILL
BE MORE RACES OF RESOURCES
AVAILABLE AND WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ASSUMING -- WE
STILL THINK IT'S DEFINITELY
PRUDENT TO MAINTAIN A HEALTHY
FUND BALANCE BUT UNDER OUR
PROJECTIONS WE DO THINK IT WOULD
BE -- IT COULD BE REASONABLE TO
ALLOCATE SOME ADDITIONAL MONEY
SO FOR EXAMPLE THE LEGISLATURE
ALLOCATED A COUPLE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS MORE.
IT WOULD STILL BE OVER TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR BALANCE
IN THE FUND IN WHICH WE THINK
THAT'S A THAT'S A REASONABLE
PLACE TO BE.
SO IF I COULD INTERJECT A
QUESTION EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION
IS FAIRLY SIGNIFICANT.
IS THERE A DIFFERENCE IN
ASSUMPTIONS -- THAT THE LA YOU
LA ALWAYS USING OVER PART IN THE
FINANCE OR IS IT JUST AN
EXPECTATION.
YEAH SO WHAT WE SETTLED SOME
BACK AND FORTH WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THAT I I THINK
THE KEY DIFFERENCES IN
ASSUMPTIONS ARE ROUNDS.
ASSUMPTIONS AROUND HOW MANY
ALLOWANCES WILL BE OFFERED AND
SOLD.
OVER THE NEXT YEAR PLUS.
I THINK WE BOTH ASSUME THAT
ALLOWANCE PRICES WILL STAY AT OR
CLOSE TO THE FLOOR AS THEY HAVE
BEEN IN RECENT YEARS -- WE JUST
HAVE DIFFERENT ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT
HOW MANY ALLOWANCES OR ARE BEING
OFFERED -- WE WE ASSUME THAT YOU
ALL OF THE ALLOWANCES SO IT
CLOSE TO THE FOR PRICE WHICH HAS
BEEN CONSISTENT -- ALMOST ALL
THE ALLOWANCES SO CLOSE TO THE
FOR PLACE WHICH HAS BEEN
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT WE HAD IN
THE IN THE LAST YEAR
[inaudible]
TO THANK -- THE SECOND POINT.
I WANT TO NOTICE JUST LOOKING AT
KIND OF A MULTI YEAR OUTLOOK --
WE DO THINK AGAIN UNDER KIND OF
THOSE SIMILAR TYPES OF
CONDITIONS OF ALLOWANCE PRICES
UP THE FLOOR AND ALL OF ALMOST
ALL THE ALLOWANCES SELLING.
REVENUE OVER THE NEXT COUPLE
YEARS WOULD BE CLOSE TO TWO
POINT FOUR BILLION AND SO --
WHEN YOU LOOK AT AGAIN KIND OF
ALLOCATING THIS 60% A CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATIONS AND SOME OF THE
OTHER EXPENDITURES THAT WOULD
LEAVE ABOUT NINE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE NEXT COUPLE
YEARS FOR DISCRETIONARY SPENDING
SO WE THINK?
YOU KNOW IT'S IMPORTANT TO KEEP
IN MIND WHEN THINKING ABOUT
MAKING ONGOING AND MULTI YEAR
COMMITMENTS THAT YOU KNOW ABOUT
NINE HUNDRED MILLION.
UNDER THAT SCENARIO WOULD BE
AVAILABLE FOR THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS AND FEET AND THE NEXT
COUPLE OF YEARS -- AND THEN
LASTLY A MORE OF A TECHNICAL
ISSUE THERE IS SOME BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
REVENUE UNCERTAINTY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WOULD HAVE
SOME.
AUTHORITY TO REDUCE ALLOCATIONS
TO CERTAIN PROGRAMS -- IF
REVENUE COMES IN LOWER THAN
EXPECTED -- WE THINK THAT
GENERAL PROVISIONS REASONABLE WE
JUST WANNA KINDA HIGHLIGHT MAKE
SURE THAT.
YOU KNOW THE AUTHORITY THEY HAVE
TO REDUCE -- CERTAIN PROGRAMS IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE
LEGISLATURE'S PRIOR HOW IT LOOKS
LIKE -- PRIORITIZES DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS.
I'M NOT A NEXT OLD JUMP INTO
SOME OF THE DETAILS OF THE
SPENDING PLAN ITSELF SO ON PAGE
FIFTEEN OF YOUR AGENDA.
IT HAS A LIST OF THE
EXPENDITURES THAT WOULD BE UNDER
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL.
I'M NOT GOING TO GO THROUGH ALL
OF THEM -- AT A HIGH LEVEL.
A LOT OF THE EXPENDITURES ARE
FOR PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
RECEIVED FUNDING IN THE PAST I
THINK ONE KEY EXCEPTION AS
THERE'S A NEW WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROPOSAL THAT'S AND
UNDER OTHER DISCRETIONARY
SPENDING TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS -- YOUR AGENDA SINCE THE
NOTE THAT THAT THAT PROPOSAL TO
BE HEARD IN A DIFFERENT
SUBCOMMITTEE SO I WON'T TALK
ABOUT THAT IN IN DETAIL -- I DO
WANNA HIGHLIGHT FOR THE SECOND
TWO CATEGORIES ON THE ON THE
TABLE THE DISCRETIONARY SPENDING
WE'VE GOT A BROKEN IT UP INTO.
TWO DIFFERENT CATEGORIES ONE IS
EXISTING DISCRETIONARY SPENDING
SO.
THOSE ARE PROGRAMS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ALREADY TAKEN AN
ACTION OR GIVEN SOME INDICATION
THAT WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR THESE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS IN.
PREVIOUS YEARS SO FOR EXAMPLE
THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION FOR
FOREST RELATED ACTIVITIES AND SB
NINE A ONE THAT WAS PASSED LAST
YEAR -- SOME -- MULTI YOUR
COMMITMENT FOR THE CLEAN VEHICLE
REBATE PROJECT THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS.
AND THEN THE SECOND CATEGORY THE
OTHER DISCRETIONARY SPENDING
WHICH IS -- IN THE BUDGET YEAR
FIVE HUNDRED NINETY THREE
MILLION THOSE ARE -- KIND OF
MORE WANT NEW KIND OF ONE TIME
EXPENDITURES A LOT OF THEM ARE
CONTINUING EXPENDITURES FOR
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN FUNDED
IN THE PAST BUT THE LEGISLATURE
HASN'T.
GIVEN KIND OF A MULTI YEAR
COMMITMENT FOR THOSE TYPES OF
EXPENDITURES.
SO -- JUST A COUPLE OF COMMENTS
ON THE PROPOSAL AS A WHOLE --
MANY OF THE FUNDING PROPOSALS
DON'T HAVE.
A LOT OF INFORMATION ON KIND OF
WHAT THE EXPECTED OUTCOMES ARE
FOR THOSE EXPENDITURE PROPOSALS
SOME CASES JUST BASIC
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW MANY
PROJECTS -- THE ADMINISTRATION
EXPECTS TO FUND -- AND AND A LOT
OF CASES ESTIMATES AROUND WHAT
THE EXPECTED EMISSION REDUCTIONS
ARE SO SEE WHAT THOSE PROGRAMS
AND SO WE ENCOURAGE AND
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
DIRECTING MINISTRATION TO REPORT
ON WHAT X. EXPECTS. FOR THOSE
PROGRAMS BOTH TO GET A SENSE OF
HOW TO PRIORITIZE YOUR FUNDING
DECISIONS AS WELL AS A WHOLE THE
ADMINISTRATION ACCOUNTABLE IN
FUTURE YEARS FOR WHAT -- WHAT
ACTUALLY?
HAPPENS IN SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMS -- THE SECOND POINT IS --
FOR SOME OF THE PROGRAMS THERE
WILL LIKELY BE NEED TO BE SOME
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE PROGRAMS
UNDER THE PROPOSED FUNDING
AMOUNT SO FOR EXAMPLE -- CARBS
CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE PROJECT OF
THE BUDGET INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THAT PROGRAM
WHICH IS CONSISTENT WITH AN
ACTION THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS
TAKEN -- FOR THAT PROGRAM --
THERE HAD BEEN SOME RECENT
PROJECTIONS AND WHAT THE DEMAND
FOR THAT PROGRAM WILL BE AND IT
HAS SEEN IT.
I THINK CARP RIGHT NOW IS
PROJECTED THAT IT WILL FAR
EXCEED THE TO ON DEMAND UNDER
KIND OF THE CURRENT STRUCTURE OF
THE PROGRAM WILL FAR EXCEED THE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND
SO -- CAN YOU GIVE US AN IDEA
WHAT THAT MEANS YES SO SO -- I
BELIEVE UNDER THEIR CURRENT
PROJECTIONS -- IN THE BUDGET
YEAR UNDER THE PROGRAM AS IT
CURRENTLY STANDS THERE WERE --
DEMAND WOULD BE ROUGHLY FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
SOVIET DOUBLE WHAT THE PROPOSED
AMOUNT IS AND SO THAT MEANS --
YET AND THERE WOULDN'T IN ORDER
TO STAY WITHIN A BUDGET THEY
WERE LIKE WE NEED TO BE SOME
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES TO THE
STRUCTURE OF THE PROGRAM WHETHER
THAT BE -- YOU KNOW WHICH
VEHICLES QUALIFY FOR REBATES THE
AMOUNT OF THE REBATES -- INCOME
LIMITS THOSE TYPES OF THINGS AND
SO -- WE RECOMMEND YOU MIGHT
WANT TO ASK THE ADMINISTRATION
TO KIND OF REPORT ON WHAT
THEY'RE THINKING IS AROUND KIND
OF WHAT THOSE TO TRUST THE
JUDGMENTS ARE.
AND WHETHER THOSE TYPES
ADJUSTMENTS ARE CONSISTENT WITH
WITH WHAT YOUR PRIORITIES ARE
ABOUT THIS THE STRUCTURE OF THE
PROGRAM -- AND THEN FINALLY JUST.
MORE GENERALLY AS ALWAYS -- I
THINK YOU KNOW THE G. JARA
PACKAGE AS A MATTER OF HOW THE
LEGISLATURE PRIORITIZES
DIFFERENT GOALS AND DIFFERENT.
ACTIVITIES -- WHETHER THAT BE
GREENHOUSE GASES -- REDUCTIONS
AND LOCAL AIR POLLUTANTS FIND AN
ADAPTATION ACTIVITIES ALL THESE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS YOU HAVE A A
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT FOCUS IN
THOSE AREAS AND SO A LOT OF
THESE DECISIONS AROUND AROUND
YOUR PRIORITIES.
I DO WANT TO NOTE -- ON THE
GREENHOUSE GAS SIDE -- I'LL JUST
KIND OF RE EMPHASIZE SOME OF OUR
EARLIER COMMENTS AROUND YOU KNOW
IT'S REALLY AND WE THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO THINK ABOUT.
HOW THE SPENDING FITS AND TO
KIND OF THE OVERALL CLIMATE
STRATEGY THAT THE STATE HAS HOW
IT FITS IN WITH THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM AND THINKING ABOUT
HOW HOW THINGS INTERACTION?
AND WHERE SPENDING CAN KIND OF
DO ADDITIONAL YOUR CONCURRED
ADDITIONAL EMISSION REDUCTIONS
WERE OTHER POLICIES AREN'T
ENCOURAGING THOUGH SO THINGS
LIKE SPENDING ON THINGS OUTSIDE
OF THE THE CAP SECTOR IN THE CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM -- ENCOURAGING
ME OF TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATION
THOSE TYPES OF THINGS.
AND ONE LAST THING I'LL
EMPHASIZE.
AS WELL IS -- YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT.
AGAIN CALIFORNIA'S PLACE AND
GLOBAL GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
AND CALIFORNIA'S ROUGHLY 1% OF
GLOBAL GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS --
TRYING TO THINK STRATEGICALLY.
AROUND.
HOW THE STATE CAN DO THE MOST TO
ENCOURAGE A MEASURE OF OPTIONS
HERE AS WELL AS REDUCTIONS IN
OTHER JURISDICTIONS AND SO WHAT
TYPES OF POLICIES ARE MOST
LIKELY TO DO THAT WHETHER THAT'S?
YOU KNOW -- DEMONSTRATING THE
POLICY CAN BE ADOPTED HERE AYE
AYE AS WELL AS AND AND AND KIND
OF ENCOURAGE OTHER JURISDICTIONS
TO ADOPT A SIMILAR TYPE OF
POLICY OR WHETHER THAT'S
ENCOURAGING.
TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATION TO
PROMOTE TECHNOLOGIES THAT CAN
THEN BE ADOPTED IN OTHER
JURISDICTIONS.
THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
CONSIDERATIONS NOW LOOK AT IN
THIS FUNDING BUT WE THINK THAT'S
ONE IMPORTANT THING TO KEEP IN
MIND PARTICULARLY FROM A
GREENHOUSE GAS PERSPECTIVE SO.
WELL IN MY COMMENTS AND THANK
YOU.
BARBARA PLANTS WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE JULIANA MORE IZUMI.
AND THE GOVERNOR'S.
BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR THE CAP AND
TRADE THE NEXT TWENTY NINETEEN
CAP AND TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN --
THE LA DID THE LA -- DID A GOOD
JOB OF OF GIVING AN OVERALL --
IT IS CONSISTENT WITH NOT JUST
AB FOR THIRTY TWO BUT ALSO
EIGHTY THREE NINETY EIGHT AND
THE INTENTIONS BEHIND THAT.
THE THE PLAN DOES.
CONTINUE TO FUND CORE PROGRAMS.
AND WE WILL BE AS FAR AS
REVENUES GOES WE WILL BE GOING
BACK THROUGH THE MAY PROCESS.
I THINK TYPICALLY WE'VE DONE
THIS IS WE GO BACK AND
REEVALUATE THE REVENUE
PROJECTIONS.
AND GIVEN THAT THE FEBRUARY
AUCTION CAME IN MUCH HIGHER THAN.
THAN ORIGINAL -- ESTIMATES WE
WILL BE RE WORKING ALL OF THAT
SO.
MORE TO COME -- THE PLAN DOES.
DOES CENTER ON PROVIDING THE
THIS DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AMOUNTS PER.
AB FIFTEEN FIFTY HAND SB.
FIVE THIRTY FIVE AND THEN AS FAR
AS OUTCOMES AND HOW THINGS ARE
ARE ALLOCATED THE ADMINISTRATION
ALLOCATES BASED ON A MULTIPLE --
VIEW POINT IF YOU WILL.
SO GLOBAL.
GLOBALLY WITHIN CALIFORNIA THE
THE TOP -- THE TOP.
I CAN'T REMEMBER THE WORD -- BUT
THE INVESTMENT THE BEST BANG FOR
BOX ON AND WE ARE FUNDING A LOT
OF THOSE PROGRAMS FOR EXAMPLE IN
THE LOW CARBON -- TRANSPORTATION
FIELD THOSE WERE GETTING QUITE A
BIT OF GHG REDUCTIONS.
THROUGH SOME OF THOSE ACTIVITIES --
ONE THING AS FAR AS
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OUTCOME BUT
THIS WAS JUST RELEASED LAST.
WEEK SO IT'S THE ANNUAL REPORT --
THAT.
BASICALLY IT ELIMINATES WHAT'S
BEEN DONE IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND
IT ALSO RECAPS WHAT'S BEEN DONE.
OVER.
THROUGH THE LIFE OF IT UP TO
THIS UP TO DATE [inaudible]
SO.
THE CAP I'M SORRY.
THIS REPORT.
WHICH IS -- PURSUANT TO AB.
FIFTEEN THIRTY TWO PROVIDES THE
FRAMEWORK OF TRANSPARENCY.
AND PROVIDES IT'S A REPORT ON
THE AUCTION PROCEEDS AND THE
PROJECTS AT ITS FUNDING.
JUST TO GIVE YOU A HIGH LEVEL.
AS OF NOVEMBER THIRTIETH.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE'S APPROPRIATED NINE
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING FOR PROJECTS THAT
FACILITATE GHG EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS.
AND SUPPORTS A VARIETY OF OTHER
STATE PRIORITIES INCLUDING LOW
CARBON TRANSPORTATION WILDFIRE
PREVENTION.
JOBS COMMUNITY YEAR PROTECTION
AND CLIMATE RESILIENCY.
OF THE NINE POINT THREE BILLION
ADMINISTERING AGENCIES HAVE
IMPLEMENTED THREE POINT FOUR
BILLION.
IN PROJECTS TO CARRY OUT AN
ESTIMATED THIRTY SIX POINT FIVE
MILLION TONS OF GHG EMISSION
REDUCTIONS.
THESE INVESTMENTS ARE HELPING
PRIORITY POPULATIONS WHICH
INCLUDE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. TO DATE 57% OF THE
IMPLEMENTED FUNDING HAS
BENEFITED PRIORITY POPULATIONS
WITH 36% OF IMPLEMENTED FUNDING
LOCATED IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
THE REPORT ALSO DESCRIBES HOW
THE INVESTMENTS HAVE MET AND
EXCEEDED THE INVESTMENT MINIMUM
SET FORTH IN AB FIFTEEN FIFTY AN
SB.
FIVE THIRTY FIVE JUST TO GIVE
YOU A FEW STATISTICS ON SOME OF
THE INVESTMENTS. FOR EXAMPLE.
A HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN MILLION
APPROPRIATED FOR AGRICULTURAL
REPLACEMENTS.
OF THAT SIXTY SIX POINT THREE
MILLION HAS BEEN AWARDED
THIRTEEN POINT TWO MILLION HAS
BEEN IMPLEMENTED.
AND THE EXPECTED BENEFITS ARE
ALMOST TEN THOUSAND METRIC TONS
OF GHG EMISSIONS ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION POUNDS OF KNOX
REDUCTIONS OVER NINETY NINE
THOUSAND POUNDS OF DIRECT DIESEL
PM TWO POINT FIVE REDUCTIONS.
AND ALMOST A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SEVEN THOUSAND GALLONS OF FUEL
REDUCTIONS. 73% OF THE FUNDS
WERE IN DISADVANTAGED IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
HOUSEHOLDS.
IN THE AB SIX SEVENTEEN
COMMUNITY AIR PROTECTION PROGRAM
OF THE FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
MILLION ALLOCATED. ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRTEEN POINT FOUR MILLION
HAS BEEN IMPLEMENTED IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN FROM THAT SIXTY
FOUR THOUSAND METRIC TONS OF GHG
EMISSIONS HAVE RESULTED TWELVE
POINT THREE MILLION GALLONS IN
FUEL REDUCTIONS.
AND AN EXPECTED NINE POINT SEVEN
MILLION POUNDS OF KNOX
REDUCTIONS.
AND FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND POUNDS OF DIESEL IN
PARTICULAR MATTER REDUCTIONS.
SO AS FAR AS OUTCOMES WE CAN SEE
FROM SOME OF THE STATISTICS.
WHAT PROGRAMS ARE VERY
SUCCESSFUL AT REDUCING GHG AND
THEN WE GET SOME OF THE CO
BENEFITS OF THE REDUCE
PARTICULATE MATTERS?
SO THE THE ANNUAL REPORT ALSO
INCLUDES SOME STATISTICS ON THE
CO BENEFITS THAT WE'RE GETTING
FROM THE G. H. T. -- FROM THE
WHOLE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM NOT
JUST GHG REDUCTIONS BUT BUT
ADDRESSING A LOT OF THE AIR
POLLUTION.
AND CLIMATE RESILIENCY ISSUES --
THE PLAN DOES INCLUDE TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION.
FOR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
TO DO A PRE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM AND THAT'LL GO WILL
DOUBLE INTO THAT MORE IN SUB.
FOR BUT THAT THAT -- PIECE OF
THIS PLAN IS JUST CONSISTENT
WITH EIGHTY THREE NINETY EIGHT
WHICH WE KNOW THAT WE'RE GOING
TO NEED.
A QUALIFIED.
EXCUSE ME AND SKILLED WORKFORCE.
IN ABLE TO TO IN ORDER -- TO
CONTINUE ON THE PATH TOWARDS A
NEW LOW LOW CARBON ECONOMY.
AND WITH THAT.
ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SO -- WELL PUT TO THAT
AND THAT OUR ASK A COUPLE
QUESTIONS FIRST -- EIGHT ONE CAN
HARDLY -- LOOK AT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S SICK A PROPOSED
EXPENDITURE PLAN AND MISS THE
FACT THAT AT THE BOTTOM OF THE
LIST -- THERE ARE I DON'T KNOW --
TEN TWELVE CATEGORIES THAT ARE
NOT FUNDED -- TO NOT NOT
PROPOSED FOR FUNDING THAT WERE
FUNDED AND THE LAST CYCLE -- AND
I'M WONDERING WHY THAT IS. FOR
SOME OF THEM.
THEY HAVE ALTERNATE FUNDING
SOURCES SO SOME OF THEM ARE
FUNDED WITH -- PROP SIXTY EIGHT
MONEY FOR EXAMPLE A LOT OF THE
NATURAL RESOURCES.
AGENCIES FUNDING WILL BE BACK
FILLED USING THE PROP SIXTY
EIGHT MONEY SO IS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S POSITION THAT
PROP SIXTY EIGHT WAS -- OF THAT
THE VOTERS VOTED ON PROP SIXTY
EIGHT TO SUPPLANT -- WHAT WE
WERE ALREADY DOING NOT
WHATSOEVER VETERANS -- EVER WE
ALSO HAVE QUITE A BIT OF KERRY
OVER IN SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS.
SO THEY'VE GOT PREVIOUS YEARS
THAT THEY'RE STILL TRYING TO GET
OUT THE DOOR.
WELL THAT'S THAT'S DIFFERENT --
AND I WOULD APPRECIATE SEEING AN
ANALYSIS OF THAT -- BUT I'D I
THINK YOU KNOW FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE IT'S PRETTY CLEAR
THAT VOTERS EXPECTED TO
SUPPLEMENT WHAT WE ARE ALREADY
DOING THEY WANTED MORE OF THE
SAME.
NOT -- JUST -- SHIFT OVER THE
WAIVER ACCOUNTING CUTS FOR
EXISTING EXPENDITURES OTHERWISE
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE MOTIVATION
FOR VOTING -- AFTER THE MEASURE
WOULD HAVE BEEN -- SO I I
FRANKLY THINK WE NEED TO REALLY --
RETHINK THAT PART OF THE
PROPOSAL HERE THERE'S SOME AREAS
HERE THAT ARE -- A VERY
EFFECTIVE PROGRAMS -- LIKE URBAN
GREENING URBAN FORESTRY THE
WETLAND RESTORATION -- AND THEN
AT THE VERY BOTTOM OF THE LIST --
THERE'S TWO MILLION DOLLARS FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES -- AND
IT YOU MENTIONED I THINK RIGHTLY --
A LOT OF THE PROGRAMS THAT WE'RE
FOCUSING ON DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES BUT WITHOUT THAT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN
COMMUNITIES THAT CAN'T AFFORD --
TO HAVE THE FOLKS ON BOARD WHO
DO THAT.
TO A TECHNICAL WORK ON STAFF
THIS IS A CRITICAL MONEY WHAT'S
THE ADMINISTRATION'S.
THINKING ON ELIMINATION OF THAT
FUNDING.
WE'VE GOT.
A LOT OF PARTS THAT THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL IS
PULLING FROM THEY'VE GOT -- THE
TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES AND THEY CAN USE A
PORTION OF THAT.
AS WELL FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
FOR THE LOCALS.
WE ALSO HAVE A LOT OF LOCAL
ASSISTANCE JUST JUST. TO WRAP IT
ALL IN TOGETHER THERE ARE A LOT
OF DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THAT ARE
GOING ON TO HELP THE LOCALS. FOR
EXAMPLE THE AB.
SIX SEVENTEEN IS REALLY FOCUSING
ON LOCAL AND REGIONAL NEEDS.
AND WORKING WITH AND DEVELOPING
THOSE RELATIONSHIPS SPECIFICALLY
WITH IN THESE.
REGIONS TO GIVE THE LOCALS AND
WE KNOW THAT THOSE.
THE THE AB SIX SEVENTEEN HAS
TARGETED.
THE THE HIGHEST RISK AND WE KNOW
THAT THOSE ARE THE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WERE TARGETING THOSE
WELL SO IF THERE ARE IS
SUFFICIENT FUNDING FROM OTHER
SOURCES -- I THINK WOULD BE
IMPORTANT TO HAVE FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO SEE AN ANALYSIS
THAT SHOWS WHERE THAT MONEY'S
COMING FROM OF WHAT THE DEMAND
IS AND HOW THAT DEMAND IS -- IS
ADEQUATELY OF BEING BEING THAT I
WAS QUITE SURPRISED TO SEE THIS --
A COMPLETELY THIS ITEM
COMPLETELY DE FUNDED -- WHY
DON'T WE TAKE ROLE SO THAT WITH
STATUS QUORUM JUST IN CASE
SOMEBODY NEEDS?
TO TAKE OFF AND THEN WILL --
CONTINUE WITH QUESTIONS OF THE
LOOKS LIKE OTHER MEMBERS HAVE
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
HELLO.
HERE FONG GARCIA MULLIN
PATTERSON [inaudible]
PRESS.
THAT WE HERE.
TO REVERSE.
ALL RIGHT SO WERE -- WERE
COMPLETE HOME -- FOR QUESTIONS --
MS RADIUS MISTER PATTERSON IS
REVERSE.
I I WANTED TO JOIN WITH THE
CHAIRS IN HIS CONCERN.
SPECIFICALLY ON THE TAKING AWAY
OF URBAN GREENING FUNDING.
AND VERY SPECIFICALLY TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THE CHAIR IS
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT.
OFTENTIMES WHEN WE SAY WE HAVE
THIS AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
COME TAKE ADVANTAGE WE HAVE LOTS
OF COMMUNITIES TO HAVE GREAT
EXPERIENCE AND THEY'VE INVESTED.
IN GETTING THE RIGHT PEOPLE TO
HELP THEM WITH THEIR PROPOSALS
WITH PUTTING TOGETHER A WINNING
GRANTS.
BUT SOME OF THE MOST TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES DON'T
HAVE THOSE RESOURCES AS THE
CHAIR HAS INDICATED.
AND THAT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
IN ORDER MY COMMUNITY AYE AYE
I'M VERY BLESSED AND VERY HAPPY
THAT WE ARE ONE OF THE
RECEPTIONS RECIPIENTS OF THE AB.
SIX SEVENTEEN WE ARE THAT
DISADVANTAGED.
AND I KNOW WE'RE GOING TO
BENEFIT FROM THAT.
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AYE AYE
AYE AYE TO LOOK FORWARD.
TO GETTING SOME FURTHER
CLARIFICATION AS TO WHERE.
THE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
ARE GOING TO GET THAT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE -- IF IT'S NOT GOING
TO BE HERE FROM -- FROM
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL.
THANK YOU MISTER PATTERSON
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A COUPLE OF A COUPLE OF AREAS.
SO IF WE'RE SERIOUS ABOUT
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS.
I'M REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT A
COUPLE OF SIGNIFICANT BUDGET CUT
AREAS AND VERY VERY SIGNIFICANT
PROGRAMS.
THAT ARE DOING A TERRIFIC JOB
THE DERRY METHANE REDUCTION
PROGRAM -- BY THE
ADMINISTRATION'S OWN ANALYSIS.
SAYS IT IS PROVING THE GREATEST
GHG REDUCTION OF ALL FUNDED
PROGRAMS.
AND THAT IS THE SECOND MOST COST
EFFECTIVE AT EIGHT TO NINE
DOLLARS PER TON [inaudible]
A REDUCTION.
WHY THEN IS THIS PROGRAM GOING
TO SEE THESE MASSIVE CUTS?
SO AGAIN THE ADMINISTRATION HAD
GONE THROUGH ALL OF THE CORE
PROGRAMS.
THERE'S STILL RE APPROPRIATED
FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR THE
METHANE FROM PRIOR YEARS THAT
HASN'T GONE OUT YET.
SO. TO JUST KEEP PUTTING IN.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
DOESN'T REALLY MAKE SENSE IF
IT'S NOT GONNA GET OUT THE DOOR
RIGHT AWAY.
SO THIS IS JUST A REGENERATING.
OF SOME OF WHAT.
PROGRAMS ARE CONTINUING TO GET
OUT THE DOOR AND WE CAN ALWAYS
REVISIT.
IN ANOTHER PLAN SO IF.
YOU'RE WILLING.
TO IF THE FUNDS ARE NOT FULLY
SUBSCRIBE.
TO AND THEY GET FULLY SUBSCRIBED
IN SIX MONTHS NINE MONTHS INTO A
BUDGET YEAR.
ARE YOU TELLING US THAT.
WE CAN GO BACK AND AND WE VISIT.
THESE HUGE CUTS IN A FUTURE YEAR
NOT IN NOT IN THE CURRENT YEAR.
BUT THAT'S NOT SATISFACTORY TO
ME AND TO THE PEOPLE I REPRESENT
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA.
SIMILARLY THE FARMER PROGRAMS
FUNDED MORE THAN SIX HUNDRED
PROJECTS TO REDUCE GHG AND
IMPROVE AIR QUALITY.
ESPECIALLY IN DISADVANTAGED AND
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES.
CARP HAS IDENTIFIED TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IS THE
NECESSARY AMOUNT TO CONTINUE
SUPPORTING THIS PROGRAM.
AGAIN IF YOU CARE ABOUT CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA.
AND IF YOU REALLY CARE ABOUT
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AS MUCH AS THE
MINISTRATION SAYS IT DOES.
WHY IS THE FORMER BUDGET BEING
CUT TO JUST TWENTY FIVE MILLION?
THERE ARE OTHER FUNDING SOURCES
FOR THE AGRICULTURAL
REPLACEMENTS AND THE HEAVY DUTY.
WE'VE GOT OTHER INVESTMENTS THE
FARMER PROGRAM IS NOT JUST
SUPPORTED BY -- THE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUND.
BUT I BELIEVE THAT SOME OF THE
CARL MOYER LSO CAN GO TOWARDS
THIS.
THIS IS A HUGE CUT FROM LAST
YEAR [inaudible]
WHAT'S CHANGED.
IN BOTH OF THESE INSTANCES
[inaudible]
WHAT'S CHANGED.
WHY THE SLASH WELL?
THIS IS ALWAYS A ONE TIME
ALLOCATION EACH YEAR
[inaudible]
WITH THE THE VINTAGE ALLOWANCES.
PRETTY MUCH BEING SOLD OUT NOW
SO WE'VE SOLD ALL OF THE VINTAGE.
UP TO THIS POINT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING.
AND THAT'S WHY OUR REVENUE
PROJECTIONS ARE ALSO.
VERY DIFFERENT BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
PROJECTING ADDITIONAL VINTAGE
ALLOWANCES SO AS HE ALLOWED INTO
THE LOANS.
IT'S FROM PREVIOUS YEARS THAT
WERE THAT WENT UNSOLD.
YOU TALK ABOUT THAT DID THE DID
THE IN THE OUTRAGE THE CAP AND
ROCKS RIGHT IN THE AUCTIONS SO
THE THE THE AUCTION PROCEEDS.
WILL BE NOT NEARLY AS HIGH AS
WHAT WE SAW IN SAY.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN OR TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THOSE WERE THOSE WERE
HUGE AMOUNTS AND WE HAVE LARGE
BALANCES AND WE DON'T ANTICIPATE
THAT MOVING FORWARD -- THE L. A.
O. IS NOT HERE.
HELLO I'M SORRY.
THE ADVISABLE MISTER BROWN I
THOUGHT YOU NORMALLY I THINK IS
THAT RIGHT.
THAT'S THE LA OC.
ARE WE DOES NOT THE LA --
PREDICT GREATER.
CAP AND CAP AND TRADE MONEY.
THAN WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING.
YES SO OUR PROJECTIONS ARE OVER
THE CURRENT YEAR AND OVER THE
BUDGET YEAR THAT REVENUE WILL BE
ROUGHLY EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS HIGHER THAN WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WAS PROJECTING
NOW SOME OF THAT MONEY IS
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED TO
CERTAIN YES A TO CERTAIN
PROGRAMS.
BUT YOU KNOW ONCE THAT MONEY IT
IS KIND OF ALLOCATED TO THOSE
PROGRAMS AND THERE WOULD BE NO
ROUGHLY AN ADDITIONAL THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
AVAILABLE TO BE SPENT SOME OF
THAT YOU MIGHT NEED TO BE LEFT
IN RESERVE TO BUDGET FRONT
CERTAINTY BUT ONE EXAMPLE WE
LAID OUT.
IS YOU KNOW WITH UNDER OUR
REVENUE PROJECTIONS IF THE
LEGISLATURE ALLOCATED A COUPLE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS MORE
THERE WOULD STILL BE OVER TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS LEFT IN
THE FUND AT THE END OF THE YEAR
AND WE THINK THAT'S A THAT'S A
REASONABLE FUND BALANCE. FOR THE
PREDICATE ON YOUR CUTS.
IS THAT YOU'RE NOT EXPECTING --
SUBSTANTIAL.
STABILITY I GUESS YOU WOULD SAY
IN THE AUCTIONS.
AND YET WE NOW THAT WE HAVE THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
SAYING THAT.
WE WE CAN TEST THAT.
THAT POINT OF VIEW.
MY ONLY POINT IS.
THESE ARE HUGE DRAMATIC CUTS.
AND IF IT'S PREDICATED ON
CAUTION.
I CAN UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT WE HAVE A DIFFERENT POINT OF
VIEW HERE WITH RESPECT TO THE
LEDGE OFFICE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION.
I JUST WANT TO GO ON RECORD THAT
THAT THE WI YOU'RE CUTTING THE
VERY PROGRAMS.
IN CENTRAL CALIFORNIA.
DISADVANTAGED AREAS IN THESE TWO
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE A HUGE
PERFORMANCE HISTORY IN DOING
PRECISELY WHAT.
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SAYS WE WANT
TO DO AND I FIND THAT VERY
DIFFICULT TO SWALLOW.
NOTED I IT I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
POINT OUT THAT TOO WITH SOME OF
THE DISCRETIONARY FUNDING.
THE WE'VE ALREADY THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION OF ALREADY.
COMMITTED SOME OF IT TO ONGOING
FUNDING. FOR EXAMPLE THE CVR P.
THE THE VEHICLE REBATE PROGRAM
AND THE SP NINE A ONE FOR THE
FIRE PREVENTION PROGRAMS.
SO THAT'S AS WE START DOING
THOSE ON GOING YEAR AFTER YEAR
COMMITMENTS IT'S GOING TO
SQUEEZE OUT SOME OF THE OTHER --
DISCRETIONARY FUNDING
[inaudible]
AND AS I HAD MENTIONED EARLIER
AND I'M NOT SURE THAT YOU WERE
IN THE ROOM WHEN WHEN WE FIRST
STARTED.
BUT THAT.
WE ALWAYS GO BACK THE
ADMINISTRATION ALWAYS REVIEWS
REVENUES AGAIN AT MAY REVISE.
AND YES WE HAVE DEFERRED AND AND
WITH THE LA -- THE LA -- AND THE
ADMINISTRATION WE'VE BEEN WE'VE
BEEN IN DISCUSSIONS AND WE KNOW
WHERE THE DIFFERENCES ARE.
AND MOST OF OUR ASSUMPTIONS ARE
CORRECT THE ONLY REAL BIG
DIFFERENCE IS THE NUMBER OF
ALLOWANCES THAT WILL BE OPTION.
SO ARE YOU SUGGESTING THAT I'VE.
I SHOULD BE LOOKING TO A MAY
REVISE FOR RECALCULATION IN
CONSIDERATION ON THESE TWO
PROGRAMS.
WE WILL BE COMING BACK OUT WITH
A NAY REVISED PROPOSAL.
AND WILK WOULD IT BE INCLUSIVE
OF THE TWO PROGRAMS I'VE JUST
SUGGESTED.
IT'S STILL UNDER DISCUSSION.
WELL AGAIN I JUST WANT.
TO POINT OUT THESE ARE TWO
EXCEEDINGLY SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS
AND THEY ARE UNDERGOING HUGE
CUTSI FIND IT DIFFICULT -- TO
JUSTIFY THAT THANK YOU.
MS RIVER S. FOLDER MISTER FONG.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF I'D
LIKE TO TALK I MEAN I SURE
CONCERNS SIMILAR TO THE ONES
THAT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE BROUGHT
UP OF THE PROGRAMS.
ON THEIR NOT BEING FUNDED -- ONE
SPECIFICALLY URBAN GREEN AND
THEN DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES --
YOU MENTION THAT IRVING GREEN
YOU KNOW LAST YEAR WAS FUNDED AT
TWENTY MILLION.
AND YOU MENTIONED THAT THAT'S
MOVING OVER TO PROP -- SIXTY
EIGHT DO YOU KNOW IF IT'S BEING
FUNDED AT THE SAME LEVEL WITHIN
THE PROP [inaudible]
SIX EIGHT A LOCATION.
I WOULD I WOULD HAVE TO GET BACK
TO ON THOSE NUMBERS OKAY THANK
YOU -- YOU KNOW.
AND THEN AS FAR AS PRIORITIZING
SPENDING YOU KNOW TO REACH
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES YOU
KNOW I REMEMBER THAT REPRESENTS
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY -- AND
YOU KNOW AS A CONCERNS -- I HAVE
CONCERNS HOW GGF FUNDING IS
BEING SPENT TO REACH THOSE
COMMUNITIES.
OF YOU KNOW OF THESE COMMITTEES
HAVE THE LEAST EFFICIENT
BUILDINGS AND HIGHEST EMITTING
VEHICLES WHICH MAKES THEM THE
MOST COST EFFICIENT TARGETS FOR
CLIMATE INVESTMENT -- AND I'M
NOT ENTIRELY CONFIDENT THAT WERE
FOOD FULLY UTILIZING COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE AT THE
GROUND LEVEL -- TO IDENTIFY --
THOSE INVESTMENTS AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE A CONVERSATION ON ON
HOW WE CAN BETTER REACH THOSE.
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE WORKING
IN THESE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES [inaudible]
MR FUNG.
WELL I APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE --
I GUESS MY MY QUESTIONS ARE KIND
OF MORE HOLISTIC AND IF WE COULD
JUST STEP BACK A LITTLE BIT.
CAN YOU AT FROM AT LEAST CAN A
MINISTRATION I GUESS OUTLINE.
THE FRAMEWORK OUR CRITERIA THAT
THEY'RE USING TO MAKE THESE
DECISIONS -- HELP ME UNDERSTAND
HOW YOU HOW YOU DECIDE THE
AMOUNTS AND WHAT GOES INTO THESE
DECISIONS.
AGAIN SOME OF IT WAS IS LOOKING
AT IT AGAIN HOLISTICALLY AND I
APPRECIATE THAT.
BUT UTILIZING SOME OF THE
PROGRAMS AGAIN THAT ADDRESS THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
MEET THE GOALS THAT WE WANT THAT
THE STATUTE HAS LAID FORTH.
IN GETTING 35% OUT TO THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THE
LOW INCOME -- COMMUNITIES AND
HOUSEHOLDS SO THAT'S ONE LANDS.
AND WE ALSO LOOK AT THE PROGRAMS
THAT [inaudible]
THAT SUPPORT.
MOVING FORWARD AND BUILDING OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE.
SUCH AS OUR TRANSPORTATION IS A
HUGE.
PORTION OF THIS.
AND THEN HOUSING IS ALSO THAT'S
PART OF THE CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATED.
AS WELL AS A TRANSFORMATIVE
CLIMATE COMMUNITIES.
SO THE THESE ARE ALL THE
DIFFERENT THESE ARE ALL THE
DIFFERENT PIECES AND LENSES THAT
WE LOOK AT WHEN.
TRYING TO CRAFT A PLAN.
SO I GUESS AS A FOLLOW UP MY MY
MY VIEW OR MAYBE THIS IS
SUGGESTION IS OR MAYBE THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU CAN GIVE ME
SOME INPUT ON BUT IF THERE ARE
THESE CRITERIA OR CERTAIN GOALS
AT THAT.
YOU'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS IS
THERE A LIST.
OF GOALS AND ITEMS THAT.
YOU COULD PROVIDE IN A IN A
SIMPLE SIMPLE WAY WHERE WE CAN
UNDERSTAND THE CRITERIA FULLY
TRANSPARENT ALLOWS THE PUBLIC TO
SEE THIS IS WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE THESE ARE THE STATUTE
THAT WE HAVE TO DO.
SO THAT WE WE ARE HAGGLING -- WE
WILL WE'RE ALWAYS GONNA HAGGLE I
GUESS FOR THE OVER THE AMOUNTS
BUT I GUESS THAT WE UNDERSTAND
WHY THESE CUTS OR AUGMENTATIONS
ARE HAPPENING.
I THINK RIGHT NOW IT'S THE THE
VIEW THAT I SEE IS THAT -- THESE
DECISIONS ARE VERY SPORADIC WE
DON'T I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
WE'RE CUTTING -- UP OF ONE
PROGRAM SIGNIFICANTLY THAT IS
VERY VERY COST EFFECTIVE AND
THAT WE MAY BE FUNDING -- A
PROGRAM THAT IS NOT SO COST
EFFECTIVE AND AS IF COST
EFFECTIVENESS IS ONE OF THE
CRITERIA WHICH I BELIEVE IT
SHOULD BE IN TERMS OF THE THE
MOST COST EFFECTIVE WAY OF
REDUCING GHGS.
THAT SHOULD PROBABLY BE THE NO
ONE PRIORITY AND IF WE'RE NOT.
ABIDING BY THAT CRITERIA THAT
EVERYONE AGREES SHOULD BE THE
CRITERIA THEN MAYBE WE THROUGH
VALUE WAY.
OUR OUR SPENDING.
THAT MAKES SENSE.
SO IS THAT POSSIBLE IS IT WITH
THE LA I'LL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THAT LIST OF OR WITH THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE BE ABLE.
TO PROVIDE THAT IN ADDITION TO
THE MAY REVISE A HERE'S OUR
EXPENDITURE PLAN AND HERE'S A
CRITERIA THAT WE USE TO
DETERMINE THE EXPECTED PLAN.
WE CAN PROBABLY WE WE CAN
PROBABLY CRAFT SOMETHING THAT
THAT WOULD.
WOULD ELIMINATE SOME OF OUR
REASONING BEHIND THIS.
BUT AGAIN THERE IS THERE IS THAT
ONE COMPONENT THAT IF WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE WITH THE ON
GOING COMMITMENTS THAT WE'VE
ALREADY MADE.
THAT THAT I'M AWARE OF WE DIDN'T
OTHER THAN THE WORK FORCE --
DEVELOPMENT.
TRAINING AND THE EIGHTEEN
MILLION ADDITIONAL FOR THE
HEALTHY SOILS.
I DON'T THINK ANY OF THEM
INCREASED OVER CURRENT YEAR.
AND TO MY LAST QUESTION MISTER
MISTER CHAIR I APPRECIATE THE
THE TIME IS IT.
IS THERE UNDERSTANDING THAT.
THE THAT THESE PROGRAMS -- ARE
ALWAYS ARE SUBJECT TO CHANGE
EVERY YEAR AND IT.
IS IS THAT YOUR UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE NUMBERS CAN CUT BECAUSE
OF MIKE MY FEAR IS THAT YOU
YOU'RE.
YOU'RE NOT PROVIDING ANY
CERTAINTY TO THOSE WHO ARE
TRYING TO REDUCE AN AND ABIDE BY
THE THE STATUES SO YOU'RE ASKING.
FOR EXAMPLE THE AGRICULTURE
INDUSTRY TO ACHIEVE THESE OALS
AND THEN YOU OUTLINED THESE
THESE FUNDING LEVELS AND THEY'RE
PLANNING LONG TERM. TO TO TRY TO
MEET THE GOALS SET FORTH BY THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THEN IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE PROCESS YOU SAY I
CHANGED MY MIND WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GIVE YOU THE FUNDING LEVELS
THAT YOU'RE EXPECTING.
AND THEN YOU'RE EXPECTING THE TO
SAY THAT MY EXAMPLE THAT
CULTURAL COMMUNITY TO STILL HIT
THE GOALS.
HI IT'S IT'S LIKE LUCY PULLING
THE FOOTBALL AWAY AND SO.
HOW DO YOU EXPECT?
ANY INDUSTRY TO BE ABLE TO LONG
TERM PLAN. TO ACHIEVE THE GOALS
THAT THE MINISTRATION AND
PROBABLY THIS BODY WANTS TO
ACHIEVE WITHOUT PROVIDING THEM
WITH SOME CERTAINTY.
ACKNOWLEDGING THE THE CHALLENGES
WITH ONE TIME FUNDING.
BUT THAT'S WHY WE THAT'S WHY THE
ADMINISTRATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE CRAFTED SOME OF THE
ON GOING COMMITMENTS WAS TO
CARRY THAT THROUGH.
NOW IF THE LEGISLATURE WANTS TO
PROPOSE.
ON GOING IT JUST SQUEEZES OUT
SOME OF THE OTHER ONE TIME SO IT
IS A MATTER OF OF TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT IS THE RIGHT.
MIX AND PRIORITY SURE BECAUSE
WE'VE GOT ALL OF THE STATUTORY
THAT 60% SO WE'RE LEFT WITH40%
AND THEN ONCE WE'VE.
OBLIGATED A PORTION OF THAT.
AS AN ONGOING RESOURCE.
THEN THERE'S THERE'S ONLY SO
MUCH THAT CAN GO AROUND SO I
UNDERSTAND HOW.
THE THE CHALLENGES WITH WITH.
THE GOALS THAT THE STATE HAS
OVERALL IN ACHIEVING CLIMATE
RESILIENCY GHG REDUCTIONS.
AND HELPING THE DISADVANTAGED
AND LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES.
AND THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE DISCUSSION ON
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE AS ONE OF
THE DAILY OF RESPONSE IS THERE A
WAY THAT YOU CAN PROVIDE A LIST
OF CRITERIA THAT SHOULD OR
SHOULD NOT BE.
USED I I SEE THAT YOU'RE A RABBI
REVIEW TO REPORT BUT AND IS IT
IS IT IS THAT HELPFUL FROM A
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE AND IN
TERMS OF EDUCATING THE PUBLIC
AND EDUCATE AND LEGISLATURE IN
TERMS OF HOW THESE DECISIONS
SHOULD OR SHOULD NOT BE MADE.
YEAH I MEAN I THINK SOMETHING
LIKE THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL AND I
THINK PART OF THE CHALLENGES
TRYING TO TO KIND OF ESTIMATE
WHAT THE BENEFITS ARE ASSOCIATED
WITH EACH PARTICULAR PROGRAM AND
I THINK.
ANY OF THE YOUR POINT IS THAT A
GOOD ONE THAT SORT OF YOU KNOW
WE WANT TO TRY AND GET
INFORMATION ON KIND OF WHAT EACH
ONE OF THESE PROGRAMS.
IS ACHIEVING AND THEN SORT OF
HAVE A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
HOW HOW THAN WERE SORT OF
ALLOCATING FUNDS AND
PRIORITIZING AMONGST THOSE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS -- ANY WE
DON'T HAVE A YOU KNOW WE DON'T
HAVE THE ANSWER TO KIND OF WHY
THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PRIORITIZING THINGS IN IN A
PARTICULAR WAY BASED ON KIND OF
INFORMATION WE HAVE RIGHT NOW.
BUT CERTAINLY KIND OF TRYING TO
OUTLINE FOR EACH PROGRAM WHAT
TYPES OF BENEFITS ARE ARE YOU
EXPECTING TO ACHIEVE AND THEN
THE LEGISLATURE CAN THEN USE
THAT.
TO KIND OF YOU KNOW -- YOU
PRIORITIZE AMONG THOSE DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS BASED ON HOW IT
PRIORITIZE IS DIFFERENT THINGS
WHETHER THAT BE LOCAL AIR
POLLUTION REDUCTIONS GREENHOUSE
GASES CLIMATE ADAPTATION SO.
DOES LA WILL HAVE A FREE MARKET
THAT.
CAN WORK OR DO YOU HAVE DO YOU
HAVE THE DATA.
WOULD YOU BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THAT INFORMATION -- I'M RIGHT
ANALYSIS.
I MEAN I I THINK PART OF THE
CHALLENGES WE DON'T HAVE.
OF A LOT OF INFORMATION ON KIND
OF PROJECTED OUTCOMES FOR EACH
ONE OF THESE POTS OF MONEY WE DO
HAVE SOME INFORMATION ABOUT KIND
OF HOW THE MONEY HAS BEEN SPENT
SO FAR AND SO WE CAN TRY TO KIND
OF PULL INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE
AVAILABLE ON KIND OF HOW.
THE MONEY HAS BEEN SPENT SO FAR
AND WHAT IT HAS ACHIEVED BUT AS
FAR AS KIND OF A PROJECTIONS
GOING FORWARD FOR EACH PROGRAM I
THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE BE KIND
OF GAPS THAT WE HIGHLIGHTED ON
IN THE KIND OF CURRENT PROPOSALS
THAT INFORMATION.
ISN'T AVAILABLE BUT WE'RE WE'RE
HAPPY TO KIND OF YOU WORK WITH
YOU AND OUR STAFF TO TRY TO PULL
WHATEVER WE CAN'T AVAILABLE
THANK YOU OFFICIAL TEMAS GERMAN
THAT'S SOMETHING I THINK THAT
MAYBE WE HELPFUL FOR ALL OF US.
MS RESTED YOU HAVE AN ADDITIONAL
QUESTION.
ARE COMMON I DID TO CHAIR OF MY
INITIAL COMMENTS WERE IN
REACTION TO WHICH WOULD SEVEN
HOW PORTENT THAT WAS --
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCES LETTER COULD CONTINUING
WITH FUNDING -- THE CLEAN
VEHICLE REBATE PROJECT
CONTINUOUSLY.
IS A PRIORITY TO THE
ADMINISTRATION WHEN IT COMES TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEAVY DUTY --
VEHICLES IN OFF ROAD EQUIPMENT.
IT NOT ONLY ISN'T SEEN AS A LONG
TERM INVESTMENT BUT IS ACTUALLY
PROPOSED TO BE DECREASED.
UNLIKE THE REST PATTERSON TALKED
ABOUT THE WHAT IS THE RATIONALE
FOR THIS DISPARITY -- MY MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THAT PROGRAM
SUCH AS HYBRIDS AND ZERO
EMISSION TRUCK AND BUS VOUCHER
PROGRAM. TO THIS POINT HAS BEEN
EXTREMELY SUCCESSFUL.
WELL AGAIN THE WE'VE GOT WE'VE
GOT THE TWO HUNDRED THAT'S THE
ONGOING COMMITMENT AND THAT IS
IN THE BUDGET FOR THIS FOR THE
VOUCHER PROGRAM. FOR THE CLEAN
VEHICLE VOUCHER PROGRAM.
AND THE HEAVY DUTY AGAIN IT WAS
IT WAS A MATTER OF CRAFTING IT.
SO IT SOME OF IT WAS
PROPORTIONATE.
IN WHAT WE HAD REMAINING.
AS FAR AS AFTER WE'VE TAKEN OUT
THE CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED
AFTER WE'VE TAKEN OUT OFF THE
TOP AND THE ON GOING COMMITMENTS.
I WANT IT I'M SORRY I AM SORRY
GO HEAD NO NO PLEASE
[inaudible]
STE.
SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE OVERALL.
ON THE ONES THAT WERE FUNDED FOR
HEAVY DUTY [inaudible]
AND THE AND THE OTHER
TRANSPORTATION WITH THAT IS THE
HIGHEST AMOUNT OF THE G. H. G.
AND THE AIR POLLUTANTS.
CONTRIBUTING TO TO HIGH AIR
POLLUTANTS IS IN THE
TRANSPORTATION FIELD.
SO IN ORDER TO GET THOSE NUMBERS
DOWN IT ONLY MAKES SENSE TO DO
SOME INVESTMENT SENATE.
BUT IF WE WERE TO SAY INCREASE
THE HEAVY DUTY BACK UP.
TO THE ONE EIGHTY THAT IN
CURRENT YEAR THEN WE WOULD NEED
TO FIND SOMEWHERE ELSE TO CUT
ANOTHER FIFTY MILLION.
BUT YOU KNOW THERE'S I'M SORRY
THERE IS THAT THAT BALANCE BUT
IF THE LAR LET LA WAS CORRECT IN
THAT THE THE ADJUSTMENTS DO HAVE
TO BE MADE AND ANOTHER HUNDRED
MILLION COULD BE SPENT.
AS WAS ANNOUNCED EARLIER.
ONCE THE BUDGET IS DONE IS DONE --
WE CAN SPEND MORE BECAUSE THE
THE THE MORE ACCURATE --
ESTIMATES OF THE REVENUE OR WITH
THE LA -- HAS SENT.
THEN WE DO HAVE THAT MONEY TO
OUT HERE OR DO WE NOT.
THEY'RE THEY'RE ALL ESTIMATED
PROJECTIONS WE ARE COMING BACK
IN IN THE MAY REVISE WITH
UPDATED REVENUE PROJECTIONS.
AND THAT WILL HAVE THE BENEFIT
OF THE OF THE ESTIMATED REVENUE
THAT HAS BEEN PROVIDED BY THE LA
L. NO THAT WOULD BE BASED ON ON
THE EXPERIENCE THAT WE HAD WITH
THE THE LATEST FEBRUARY AUCTION
IN THAT CAME IN MUCH HIGHER THAN
ANTICIPATED FOR CURRENT YEAR.
SO WE KNOW WERE WERE PROJECTING
ADDITIONAL IN CURRENT YEAR.
AND THEN THAT WILL AFFECT WHAT'S
IN BUDGET YEAR.
WONDERFUL.
MISTER CHAIR IF I MAY.
AB -- FIFTY FIFTY A 25%.
INVESTMENT WAS WAS --
RECOMMENDED I KNOW YOU'VE TALKED
ABOUT THIS.
WHICH OF THE IT WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE ENTIRE PORTFOLIO.
WHICH OF THE PROGRAMS ARE
FULFILLING THAT 25% WHICH OF THE
MOST SUCCESSFUL.
I CAN GET I CAN GET A CHART TO
YOUR P. WHEN YOU'RE SAYING.
THANK YOU -- AND THEN FINALLY IF
I MAY MISTER CHAIR -- THIS YEAR
I I AUTHORED.
AB FOURTEEN ELEVEN WHICH SETS A
GOAL TO DEPLOY TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY --
VEHICLES -- AND ALSO INCLUDING
THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT
THEM.
AT THE BILL HIGHLIGHTS NEED FOR
COMMUNITIES ACROSS ESPECIALLY
THE FREIGHT CORRIDORS. TO INVEST
IN TECHNOLOGY THAT WILL CLEAN
AIR QUALITY IN SOME OF THE MOST
BURDENS COMMUNITIES.
OF IT SEEMS THAT WOULDN'T
WOULDN'T WE'RE TRYING TO
DETERMINE THE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION FUND'S ALLOCATION
THERE SEEMS TO BE THIS BACK AND
FORTH ON THE GOALS OF THE
PROGRAM.
AND I THINK THERE WAS A COMMENT
ABOUT THIS -- LOOKING TO
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE.
GREENHOUSE GASES BUT ALSO
PROTECTING THOSE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES -- ENSURING CLIMATE
EQUITY. FOR COMMUNITIES JUSTICE
OF MIGHT MY COLLEAGUES TALKED
ABOUT.
THE COMMITTEES ARE MOST AFFECTED
ARE THE POOREST AND THEY DO HAVE
THE WORST AIR.
AND THAT IS WHY THAT 25% IS SO
IMPORTANT. TO US.
I I THINK THAT WE CAN DO BOTH
AND FOR ME IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
THAT WE SEE HOW WE FIND THAT
THAT BALANCE SO THAT THE POOREST
AND THE MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES.
ARE ALWAYS TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION.
AND PROVIDED THE FUNDING THAT'S
NEEDED -- WE KNOW THAT.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS COMING
ESPECIALLY.
IT COMES TO ALL COMMUNITIES BUT
THE POOREST ARE THE ONES THAT
SUFFER THE MOST -- AND WE ARE
WITHOUT A DOUBT
DISPROPORTIONATELY MORE POLLUTED.
BECAUSE AND THEN AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER DIFFERENT COURT CORRIDOR.
I I AM JUST ASKING THAT AS WE
LOOK AT THESE NUMBERS AS WE
EVALUATE.
THOSE THAT DO BENEFIT THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
NOT TO BE THE ONES THAT ARE ON
THE CHOPPING BLOCK FIRST.
AN ABSOLUTELY AND THAT WAS ONE
OF THE FACTORS IN HOW THE PLAN
WAS CRAFTED.
SO WE'VE ALWAYS WANTED TO TARGET
THOSE PROGRAMS THAT ADDRESS THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
THE LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AS
THE REPORT.
THAT I HAD I HAD MENTIONED --
THAT'S OUT.
IT WE HAVE MET THOSE GOALS WHICH
I'M VERY PROUD OF THE STATE FOR
DOING AND AND IT'S BECAUSE OF
THE ALLOCATIONS [inaudible]
THAT WERE.
MORE PROJECTED AND I THINK THAT
SOME OF THESE WILL CONTINUE THAT.
I WOULD AND I KNOW IT'LL BE --
WE'LL DISCUSS IT LATER BUT
MAKING SURE THAT AS WE TALK
ABOUT THE ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
THE WE ALSO HAVE INFRASTRUCTURE --
WE DON'T WANT STRANDED ASSETS I
RECOGNIZE THAT BUT WE ALSO HAVE
TO PUT THE INFRASTRUCTURE IN IF
WE WANT TO THE PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY TO THEN INVEST.
IN THAT THE ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES AND FOR THE TRUCKS
COMING THROUGH THE THE THE
FREIGHT CORRIDOR IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE DO HAVE THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE SO THAT AS THEY
TRANSITION.
AND THEY KNOW THAT THEY CAN GET
THROUGH THE FREIGHT CORRIDOR
WITHOUT LEAVING ALL OF THEIR
DIESEL IN OUR COMMUNITIES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR ALL OF
YOUR QUESTIONS -- MR TO SORRY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR JUST A
COUPLE AND QUITE WELCOME. TO SUB
THREE THIS MAKE YOU THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE YOUR DAY.
I JUST WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON
MISTER ON PATTERSON AND MISTER
FONG COMMENTS CAN YOU TALK ABOUT
HOW MUCH.
YOU YOU MENTIONED THAT THERE WAS --
QUITE A BALANCE IN EACH OF THOSE --
COMMITMENTS THAT WAS LEFT ON
SPENT HOW MUCH WAS LEFT ON SPENT%
I WOULD HAVE TO GO BACK IN AND
VERIFY BECAUSE MOST OF THE TIME.
WHAT WE DO WE DO THE STATE WIDE
COORDINATION WE DON'T GET INTO
THE NITTY GRITTY?
BUT I DO HAVE A LIST OF ALL OF
THE DIFFERENT RE APPROPRIATIONS
AND WHAT HAVE TO ACTUALLY PULL A
REPORT FROM THE SYSTEM TO SEE
HOW MUCH.
HOW MANY DOLLARS ARE ACTUALLY
THERE AND I CAN GET THAT BACK?
GREAT AND AS AS AS A FOLLOW UP
ALSO IN THOSE TWO SECTORS OF
YOUR TALK ABOUT THE AGRICULTURAL
SECTOR IN AB.
SIX SEVENTEEN GIVE A SPECIFIC
CAN YOU SHARE SOME EXAMPLES OF
TYPES OF PROJECTS YOU FUND.
I WOULD HAVE TO DEFER TO ARB FOR
SPECIFIC PROJECTS.
GOOD MORNING JACKIE TESKE
CALIFORNIA RESOURCES BOARD --
WITH REGARD -- TO EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
FIRST YEAR DESIGN THAT PROGRAM
TO BE VERY MUCH -- CARL MOYER
LIKE SO A LOT OF THE PROJECTS
THAT WE SAW IN THE FIRST YEAR --
ARE ORIENTED A LITTLE MORE --
CARL MOYER -- BACKUP PROJECTS SO
YOU SAW A TRUCK TO TRUCK
REPLACEMENT PROJECTS YOU SAW
SOME -- FARMER -- A GROUP --
TRACTOR REPLACEMENTS -- YOU SAW
SCHOOL BUSES THE OVER THE LAST
YEAR THEY'VE -- GUIDED A LOT
MORE TOWARDS THAT COMMUNITY
DEVELOPING GETTING THAT
COMMUNITY INPUT SO YOU'RE
STARTING TO SEE A LITTLE MORE
ZERO EMISSION SOME BUSES --
DELIVERY VEHICLES THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS -- BUT A BROAD SPECTRUM
DEPENDING ON THE DISTRICT AND
AND THE OTHER PROGRAM WAS.
JUST THE THE DOOR TALKING BY ADD
PROGRAMS WHEN I WALKED AND SO
SOME OF THE BUT IN THE END WITH
REGARD TO THE AG PROGRAM THE
FARMER PROGRAM THAT YOU'VE SET
UP AGAIN STARTED VERY MUCH CARL
MOYER LIKE.
BUT WE'VE EXPANDED THE PROGRAM
BEYOND THAT SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
HAS THE PREPONDERANCE OF THAT
AND THEY HAVE GOTTEN -- EXPANDED
INTO MORROW WHEN YOU SAY CALL
MORE LIKELY YOU'RE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT I'M SORRY -- THE CARL
MOYER PROGRAM IS -- INCENTIVE
PROGRAM THAT WAS THE BASIS --
IT'S IT'S BEEN AROUND FOR TWENTY
YEARS AND IT'S BEEN THE WITH THE
START OF THE FOUNDATION FOR A
NUMBER OF THESE OTHER INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS.
SO WHEN -- THE LEGISLATURE --
ALLOCATED THAT MONEY THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS THAT ALLOCATED
AND SORT OF UNDER THAT FORMAT
AND AND SO THE DISTRICTS HAVE
BEEN USED TO THAT AND THAT'S HOW
THEY THE PROCESS AND PROCEDURES
THEY USED TO GET THAT FUNDING
OUT.
BUT IN THE FORMER PROGRAM THE AG
WERE PROGRAM WE SEE A LOT OF
TRACTOR REPLACEMENT WE'RE
STARTING TO SEE SOME -- ZERO
MISSION -- AG U. T. V.'S -- AND
SOME -- YOU KNOW AG PUMPS A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT --
EQUIPMENT LIKE THAT TRUCK TO
TRUCK REPLACEMENTS IN THE AG
SECTOR BUT THE VAST MAJORITY IS
AG TRACTOR REPLACEMENTS RIGHT.
IN IN IN PART OF ANY INCENTIVE
PROGRAM OF THIS IS TO TRY TO GET
TO A TIPPING POINT WHERE THE
INDUSTRY WHAT JUST NATURALLY
MOVE THAT WAY HOW HOW FAR AWAY
OR HOW CLOSE DO YOU THINK WE ARE
TO THE WELL THAT DEPENDS ON THE
THE CATEGORY WHEN WE'RE TALKING --
THE THE TRACTOR REPLACEMENT
THAT'S A VERY CHALLENGING AREA
TO BE I MEAN FUNDAMENTALLY -- AG
INDUSTRY WILL RUN THESE VEHICLES
UNTIL THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NO LIFE
IN THEM AND THEN RUN THEM SOME
MORE RIGHT.
AND AND SO REALLY THE INCENTIVE
PROGRAM IS THE WAY TO TO JUST
DRIVE THAT REPLACEMENT WHAT
WE'RE DOING AND OTHER PROGRAMS
LIKE -- IN THE CLEAN TRUCK
PROGRAM WHERE WE'RE ACTUALLY
BUILDING A MARKET FOR ZERO
MISSION AND THOSE VEHICLES HAVE
A LOWER COST OF DOING BUSINESS
OVER THEIR LIFE WE'RE STARTING
TO SEE -- THE BUSINESSES -- YOU
PS FRITO LAY OTHERS GO AND SAY I
I CAN ACTUALLY MAKE A BUSINESS
CASE FOR THIS AND SO WE DO SEE --
PATHWAY THERE FOR THOSE OF
TAKING OFF ON THEIR OWN.
IT IN IT'S IT'S IT'S BEEN A LOT
OF DISCUSSION REGARDING FREIGHT
AND AND PASSENGER VEHICLES WE WE
KNOW THAT -- TRANSPORTATION.
COVERS ABOUT 40% OF GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS WHAT'S THE
BREAKDOWN WITHIN THAT. 40% OF
PASSENGER VEHICLES VERSUS RIGHT --
I DON'T HAVE THAT IN FRONT OF ME
AS PRIMARILY -- THOUGH -- IT'S
DRIVEN MORE BY LIGHT DUTY BUT I
WE CAN GET YOU THAT INFORMATION.
DID YOU HAVE ANY BROUGHT.
GAS.
I'D I DON'T OKAY.
MY MY MY LATEST -- START
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING.
I THINK OF WHEN WE LOOKED AT THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN NUMBERS ON
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS -- THAT --
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES REPRESENTED
ABOUT 22% OVERALL TRANSPORTATION
EMISSIONS AND 9% OF OVERALL
EMISSIONS GOT AS HE IS EVEN IF
YOU'RE IN.
A DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY WHICH
IS PRIMARILY DISADVANTAGE
BECAUSE THEY'RE PROBABLY NEXT TO
A FREEWAY -- ON AVERAGE -- USE
GOING TO BE EVEN EVEN THE
LEGISLATURE NEXT TO THE PORT OF
LA OR THE OAKLAND PORT.
CHANCES ARE YOU GONNA BE ROUGHLY --
SHARING THE SAME SIZE THE SAME
KIND OF PERCENTAGE IS THAT IS
THAT FAIR OR NOT FAIR.
I I MEAN I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE DISTRICTS LOCALLY HOW
THEY BREAK THAT DOWN WHEN THEY
WELL I I THINK WHAT YOU'LL WHAT
WE'VE FOUND -- VERY CLEARLY IF
AND SO -- PARTICULATE MATTER
FROM THE TRUCKS IS A HUGE
CONSIDERATION FOR THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES -- SO
WE DO HAVE -- DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES REGIONALLY WE CARE A
LOT ABOUT THE KNOX EMISSIONS ARE
TO LEAD TO OZONE -- SO WE DO
LOOK AT ALL OF THESE WHEN WE'RE
DESIGNING OUR PROGRAMS.
THIS IS SO YOU WOULD YOU WOULD
LOOK AT SPECIFIC COMMUNITIES.
AND BASED ON THE POLLUTANTS YOU
WOULD.
DESIGN PROGRAMS DIFFERENTLY I'M
SOLUTIONS ARE JUST TELL ME ARE
AND WE WE CERTAINLY MIGHT WE
MIGHT TARGET FOR EXAMPLE -- A AT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY OR ONE
THAT'S VERY -- A COMMUNITY THAT
HAS A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
ROADWAY TRAFFIC TO CARE MORE
ABOUT -- DRIVING THAT TO ZERO
MISSION WE MIGHT DESIGN A
MOBILITY PROGRAM VERY
DIFFERENTLY WHICH HASDIFFERENT
ATTRIBUTES A CAR SHARE PROGRAM
MIGHT.
MIGHT BE VERY -- DESIGN FOR A
DIFFERENT TYPE OF COMMUNITY.
THAT THE FOR SAY LIKE FREIGHT IN
PARTICULAR YOU HAVE THE FREIGHT
MAY IT MAY START AT A PARTICULAR
PLACE BUT IT'S DRIVING ALL LET'S
SAY ALL THROUGHOUT THE STATE HOW
DO YOU KNOW WHERE.
WHERE THEY'RE GOING AND WHERE
THEY'RE POLLUTING AND WE HAVE A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT PROGRAMS SO
WHEN WE HAVE OUR -- OUR REBATE
PROGRAM IT IS A FIRST COME FIRST
SERVE AND AND THAT WILL SERVE
WHOEVER COMES IN THE DORM
PROVIDED MISSION BENEFITS AS YOU
SAY EVERYWHERE WHEN WE HAVE
CERTAIN PILOT PROGRAMS WE MAY
TARGET THOSE TO CERTAIN REGIONS
LIKE THE PORTS OR OTHERS WHERE
WE WANT.
TO FOCUS -- AND AND GET
ADDITIONAL EMISSION REDUCTIONS
IN CERTAIN REGIONS -- BUT
REGARDING THE THE BREAKDOWN FOR
FUNDING FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES GIVE A SENSE OF
REGIONALLY HOW IT BREAKS DOWN.
WHETHER IT'S BETWEEN NORTH SOUTH
INLAND.
I THINK IT'S A BROADER QUESTION
THERE BE.
YEAH AND I I BELIEVE THAT THE
THAT ON THE WEBSITE. FOR THE
ANNUAL REPORT THERE ARE SOME
MAPS AND IT'S ACTUALLY PRETTY
COOL BECAUSE YOU CAN.
YOU CAN SORT THE MAP BY REGION
YOU CAN SORT OF BY DIFFERENT --
DIFFERENT CRITERIA.
AS FAR AS WHAT PROGRAMS WERE
LOCATED IN IN WHAT.
WHAT AREAS OF THE STATE SO SO
WHAT ONE OF OUR ONGOING CONCERNS
FROM THE FROM THE BAY AREA IS
THAT ARE DISADVANTAGED MUSE HAVE
BEEN PENALIZED?
BY THE CALLIN VIRUS SCREEN AND
AND THE CONCERN IS THAT --
BECAUSE FRANKLY THERE THE REGION
HAS BEEN A LEADER IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL AREA HAS DONE A
LOT OF WORK IN THIS THAT.
MUCH OF THE WORK THAT OUR OUR
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES HAVE DONE IN
PURSUIT AND FRANKLY OUR COMPANY
TO PURSUE WOULD HAVE BEEN
PENALIZED.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT THAT WERE AT
RISK OF NOT GETTING -- ONGOING
FUNDING OR NOT GETTING OUR FAIR
SHARE MOVING FORWARD.
YOU'RE LOOKING AT ME KIND OF
PUZZLED LIKE FORTUNATELY FOR
THIS NO I'M NOT SURE
[inaudible]
BECAUSE ONCE.
AT THE STATE LEVEL WE PROVIDE
THE FUNDING IN BULK AND THEN WE
DON'T GET DOWN INTO THE GRANULAR
AS FAR AS WHICH ONES AND I WOULD
HAVE TO DO AGAIN 242- THEIR
BOARD AS FAR AS WELL THIS IS
THIS IS BUDGET COMMITTEE SO WE
DO ASK INTO GRANULAR THINGS.
WHAT?
SO -- PERHAPS YOU COULD --
FOLLOW UP AND WE COULD HAVE A
RIGHT SEPARATE.
DISCUSSION SO I WOULD REALLY
URGE YOU -- WHEN YOU COME NEXT
TIME TO BE?
PREPARED.
TO OUST ANSWER SOME OF THESE
QUESTIONS IT'S IT'S DOUBTS
CONCERNING THAT THE TO COME TO
COMMITTEE IN A BILL TO ANSWER
SOME OF THE BASIC FINANCIAL
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU MISTER TING AT THE
ACTUALLYPERFECT SEGUE -- TO A
COMMENT I WANTED TO MAKE AND
THAT IS THAT -- YOU'VE HEARD --
TO FROM -- ALMOST EVERY MEMBER I
THINK IT ALMOST EVERY MEMBER ON
THE ON THE COMMITTEE ABOUT A
VARIETY OF ISSUES -- AND THIS IS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO GET
THOSE ON THE TABLE -- AND
RECEIVE INFORMATION BACK -- RICK
REGARDING ALL THE MY FOR MYSELF
AND PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN
THIS ISSUE OF OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S INTERPRETATION
OF UP PROP.
SIXTY EIGHT AND I'M GONNA ASK
STAFF TO ACTUALLY SET THAT AS AN
AGENDA ITEM IN AN UPCOMING
HEARING -- SO THAT WE CAN --
HAVE A FULL EXPLORATION AND
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S POSITION AS ON
THAT I THINK IT'S OF A BUT MOST
IMPORTANT TO CALIFORNIA VOTERS --
THAT THEY KNOW WHEN THEY'RE
VOTING ON A FOR A A REVENUE
PRODUCING MEASURE THAT -- OF THE
MONEY'S GOING TO BE USED IN A
WAY THAT -- THEY EXPECTED -- TO
SO I LOOK FOR TO HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION AT A AT A FUTURE
MEETING.
A WE DO WANT TO TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THIS ITEM
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS IS A
HOLD OPEN RECOMMENDATION ON
WHILE PEOPLE ARE STEPPING
FORWARD -- AND WE HAVE ALMOST A
FULL HOUSE HERE I THINK -- WILL
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT -- ASK
YOU TO REMAIN STANDING FOR A
MOMENT WILL TAKE A FEW QUICK
VOTES WE ACTUALLY HAVE TEN VOTES
THAT WE NEED TO TAKE ON THE VOTE
ONLY.
CALENDAR SO -- IF I COULD --
HERE A MOTION -- TO APPROVED
ISSUES 246-910-1317 EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AND TWENTY ON THE VOTE
ONLY CALENDAR THAT WOULD BE
GREAT [inaudible]
THEIR SECOND.
LET'S TAKE A VOTE BLOOM I FONG
[inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
MULLIN -- ST.
FRANCIS [inaudible]
THIS.
AND WE'VE HAD A REQUEST TO HEAR
EACH OF THESE -- ITEMS THAT'LL
IDENTIFY -- SEPARATELY SO WE'RE
GOING TO THESE WANTED AT TIMES A
LITTLE BIT TEDIOUS BUT IS THERE
A MOTION ON ISSUES.
THREE I'M SORRY -- STRIKE THAT --
IS OUR MOTION ISSUE.
ONE BLOOM HI FONG GARCIA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
REYES.
RE THIS [inaudible]
ISSUE [inaudible]
THREE SIR MOTION [inaudible]
GOVERNOR [inaudible]
YEAH.
BLOOM HI FONG.
GARCIA RIGHT MULLIN [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
RAMOS [inaudible]
THIS. TO HEAR MOTION FIVE ISSUE
[inaudible]
FIVE SECOND.
BLOOM I FONG.
GARCIA.
MULLIN PATTERSON.
BRASS REVERSE [inaudible]
ISSUE.
SEVEN THE MOTION TO APPROVE.
BLOOM HI.
FONG GARCIA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON RAY YES.
PREVIOUS.
THE MOTION TO APPROVE ISSUE.
EIGHT BLOOM HI FONG GARCIA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON [inaudible]
RAMOS.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION TO APPROVE
ISSUE.
ELEVEN BLOOM BY FONG GARCIA.
RIGHT MULLIN -- ST.
FRANCIS.
REAVIS.
IN THE NEXT -- WOULD BE A MUST
APPROVE A PHOTO ONLY ISSUE.
TWELVE BLOOM HI FONG
[inaudible]
GARCIA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
BRASS.
REVERSE.
ALMOST THERE THREE MORE ODD WE
HAVE A MOTION ON ISSUE FOURTEEN
TO APPROVE.
BLOOM I FONG.
GARCIA [inaudible]
SORRY MULLIN [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
RAY S..
REAVIS.
ISSUE FIFTEEN IS NEXT MOST
APPROVED.
BLOOM HI FONG.
GARCIA [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
RAY S. FIVE REAVIS.
AND FINALLY -- LAST AND I DON'T
KNOW IF IT'S LEAST ISSUE.
SIXTEEN BLOOM I FONG.
GARCIA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
REAVIS.
THANK YOU LIKE I SAID A LITTLE
BIT TEDIOUS -- AND THANK YOU FOR
BEING PATIENT WE HAVE QUITE A
FEW PEOPLE WHO WANT TO SPEAK ON
THIS ITEM I'M GOING TO ASK THAT
YOU -- TO KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO
THIRTY SECONDS OR LESS I KNOW
YOU CAN DO IT.
WILL DO -- GOOD MORNING I
STRUGGLING THERE'S THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS RYAN CANYON WITH
CLEAN ENERGY AND WE APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEES OF FOCUS ON THE
LA A REPORT WE BELIEVE THE
FINDINGS ARE REAL AND SERIOUS.
I DON'T BELIEVE ANY OF THE A
POLICY COMMITTEES ARE
CONSIDERING THE FINDINGS WE BOTH
BELIEVE THAT.
THE THAT THE BUDGET COMMITTEE IS
ON THE WAY -- TO CONSIDER --
WORK WERE -- THE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE OTHER
REPORT I WE DO WE JUST WANNA
MAKE A QUICK NOTE THAT -- WE
BELIEVE SHORT TERM AND LONG TERM
STRATEGIES ARE NEEDED AND RIGHT
NOW THE FOCUS WE BELIEVE ON THE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
KNOCKS PROGRAMS ARE FOCUSED ON
LONG TERM.
MOSTLY PUT A LOT OF MONEY INTO
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES THE ONLY
WERE LA OR REPORTED REFER DID
FIND THAT -- SEVEN CENTERS OF
THE MOST COSTLY AND LEAST
EFFECTIVE I'LL GIVE YOU A QUICK
EXAMPLE THE H. FIT PROGRAM BACK
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WAS ALLOCATED BY AIR BE
EIGHTEEN MILLION DOLLARS.
INITIATIVE AT A FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR VOUCHER AMOUNT -- FUNDED
A FORTUNE FIFTY LOW KNOCKS
VEHICLES THE VOUCHER AMOUNT WAS
SO LOW AT FORTY THOUSAND THE
ONLY SIXTY NINE VEHICLES WERE
FUNDED SO WE DO YOU BELIEVE THE
DEVIL'S IN THE DETAILS LOW
KNOCKS ARE IS A SHORT TERM --
SOLUTION TO REDUCING GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS AND KNOCKS WE
BELIEVE THE COMMITTEE WOULD BE
WELL SERVED -- TO CONTINUED
EXPLORING OTHER DETAILS OF THE
PROJECTS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE ON FEDERAL ON THOUGH
HERE ON BEHALF OF MY MOM DEFENSE
FUND I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT TWO
THINGS ONE IS -- THE CONTINUE
PUSH -- FROM MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE A BICAMERAL LETTER --
ASKING FOR AN ADDITIONAL FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION FOR INVESTMENTS
IN NATURAL LOOKING LANDS WHICH
COULD ACROSS MANY DIFFERENT
SECTORS INCLUDING WETLANDS
INVESTMENTS -- FOREST HEALTH
INVESTMENTS URBAN FORESTRY
NORMAN GREENING -- HEALTHY SOILS
ISSUES AND AND A NUMBER OF OTHER
CATEGORIES -- AND SECOND ONE OF
THE ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE BY
THE CHAIR ABOUT.
THE INTENT AROUND PROP SIXTY
EIGHT NOT SUPPLANTING --
INVESTMENTS IN IN THESE AREAS IS
IS VERY CLEAR TO US AS FOLKS
THAT WORKED ON CRAFTING.
THE THE THE BOND LANGUAGE AS
WELL AS FOLKS THAT HELPED TO
ADVOCATE FOR ITS PASSIONS WITH
WITH THE ELECTORATE -- IT'S VERY
CLEAR THAT THE ELECTORATE MEANT
FOR THIS TO BE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR THESE THESE TYPES OF
TYPES OF INVESTMENTS AND WE
DON'T WANT TO SEE -- SUPPLANTING
ARGUMENT THAT THAT'S OAK WE'VE
ALREADY HEARD BEING MADE FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION -- WITH
REGARDS TO HOW THE BUDGET IS
GONNA BE ALLOCATING ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS -- ALSO WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT -- MISTER BROWN
WITH HELIO HAS BEEN DOING A
GREAT JOB OF ALWAYS ARTICULATING
HOW MUCH REVENUE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WHEN IT COMES A YEAR AFTER.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
VERY CLEAR AND CONCISE I'M IN
PROVIDING THOSE THOSE DETAILS
THAT OFTEN I GET LEFT OUT --
WHEN WE SEE IT -- REPORTED
OTHERWISE THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JULIE JOURNAL WITH
THE LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY -- I
WANT TO THANK THE MEMBERS FOR
THEIR COMMENTS ON THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS URBAN
GREETING PROGRAM -- WHICH ARE
VERY IN FRONT OF THE COMMUNITIES
WE WORK WITH WHICH ARE LOW
INCOME DISPENSED COMMUNITIES IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY SAN JOAQUIN
IN EASTERN PATELLA IN PARTICULAR --
AND ALSO ON EXPRESSED SUPPORT
FOR THE TRANSFORM OF CLIMBING
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM WHICH WE
BELIEVE SHOULD BE FUNDED A
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION -- AND IN
PARTICULAR WITH -- PERCENTAGE
SET ASIDE FOR DISMANTLING
CORPORATE COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE
BEEN HISTORICALLY UNDER INVESTED
IN WHEN IT COMES -- TO BASIC
INFRASTRUCTURE -- SERVICE NEEDS
AND THE LIKE -- IN PARTICULAR
THAT YOU SEE IN THE EASTERN TO
TELL OF ALLEY WE'RE SEEING
AMAZING PLANNING GRANTS
HAPPENING THERE BUT THEY'RE NOT
EVEN ABLE TO CURRENTLY IMPLEMENT --
DUE TO LOOK ELIGIBILITY
CONSTRAINTS -- WE WERE LOOKING
TO SEE THOSE CHANGED AS WELL AS
PERCENTAGE -- DIRECTED
SPECIFICALLY TO THOSE AREAS --
IN ADDITION I WANT HELLO THE DAY
OR DAY JUSTER PROGRAM -- THIS
PROGRAM MAY CLAIM BENFITS TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES BUT
REALLY THOSE BENEFITS ARE NOT
VERIFIED -- WE'RE NOT SEEING
THAT CLEARLY WHAT WE ARE SEEING --
ARE NEGATIVE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS OF HOLD THEIR SYSTEMS --
INCLUDING ENTERICA MISSIONS
WATER CONTAMINATION AIR QUALITY
AND OTHER ISSUES -- AND SO WE
NEED TO CONTINUE QUESTIONING
WHETHER OR THE INVESTMENTS THAT
WE'RE MAKING INTO THAT PROGRAM
ARE ACTUALLY ENCOURAGING -- GAS
INFRASTRUCTURE AN UNSUSTAINABLE
FARMING PRACTICES AT A LARGE
SCALE -- RATHER THAN ACTUALLY
INVESTING AND SHIFTING TOWARDS
TRULY CLEAN ENERGY AND
ECOLOGICAL WAYS OF DOING ANIMAL
AGRICULTURE -- SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT
ANY.
CONTINUED CHOOSE YOUR OF MONEY
SHOULD BE TARGETED TOWARDS THE
DIRT I JUST A PROGRAM -- WHEN WE
ASKED LEGISLATORS NO LONGER
ALLOCATE FUNDS TO THIS PROGRAM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH?
MR TURN MEMBERS SO ELEVEN SALAS
WITH THE NATURE CONSERVANCY WE
WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS
WITH AND PUT A LOT OF THEM
THOUGH AS WELL AS THE CHAIR --
ASSEMBLY WOMEN RACING REVISE IN
REGARDS TO THE ONGOING CONCERN
ABOUT A LACK OF FUNDING FOR
NATURAL RESOURCE AS WELL AS
NATURAL WORKING LANDS PROGRAM.
AND ALSO JUST HIGHLIGHT A LETTER
THAT HAS BEEN CIRCULATED TO THIS
COMMITTEE -- THAT HAS
SIGNATORIES MOST OF WHICH ARE
BEHIND ME THAT DOES CALL FOR AN
ADDITIONAL FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT YOU KNOW IT'S
OFTEN SAID THAT THE BUDGET IS A
STATEMENT OF OUR VALUES IN.
ORDER EVOLVING FOR NOT FUNDING
THESE CRITICAL PROGRAMS AS WE
LOOK FOR TO ENGAGEMENT AND NOT
FRONT AND ONE THING THAT HASN'T
BEEN MENTION IS CLOSE A LOT OF
TATIAN THAT WAS A BIG -- TOPIC
OF CONCERN IN THE LAST YEAR IN
THE LA -- DID REFERENCE SOME
REALLY -- STRONG STATISTICS AS
TO POTENTIAL REAL ESTATE THAT IS
AT RISK -- AND ITS EQUIPMENT TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS BY
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED WHICH IS SIX
POINT 5% OF THE STATE'S GDP --
AND FROM A FINANCE PERSPECTIVE
WE THINK THOSE ARE REALLY LARGE
NUMBERS AND ISSUES OF CONCERN.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING THEN THE COMMISSION
WITH A CALIFORNIA BICYCLE
COALITION HERE ON BEHALF OF
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES FOR ALL
WE'RE A COALITION ITS MULTI
MULTI SECTOR.
AND LOOKING AT HOW WE CAN I'M IN
HERE I'M JOINED BY MY COLLEAGUES
AND WE'RE HERE TO SEE HOW WE CAN
INVEST IN ADVOCATE FOR INVESTING
IN VIBRANT COMMUNITIES AND AND
HOW WE CAN LOOK THESE FUNDS ADD
TO REALLY ACHIEVE OUR GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTIONS BUT ALSO CREATE.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
TRANSPORTATION CHOICES FOR OUR
LOWER LOWER INCOME -- OF
FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS ACROSS
THE STATE.
OUR EFFORTS HAVE HELPED TO
CREATE THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
PROGRAM AND ALSO THE TRANSIT
OPERATIONS PROGRAMS THAT ARE.
AWARDED IN THESE FUNDS BUT ALSO
AND WE LOOK TO OTHER WAYS AND
OTHER PROGRAMS TO COMPLEMENT
THOSE -- THOSE PROGRAMS WHICH WE
TODAY ARE LOOKING AT URBAN FOR
STREAM GREENING -- RESIDENTIAL
WEATHER'S STATION AND ALSO
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS SO --
YOU KNOW WHY WE DO THIS IS
BECAUSE WE SEE A BENEFIT TO
REDUCING THE HOUSEHOLD COSTS FOR
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE --
WHEN THERE'S MORE TO
TRANSPORTATION CHOICES AND A
HOUSING CHOICES ALSO THE ENERGY
REDUCTIONS?
AND THAT AND THEN ALSO THE JOB
CREATIONS THAT COME OUT OF THESE
PROGRAMS AND SERVE.
AS I'LL BE SPEAKING TO HOW WE'RE
INTERESTED TO SEE THE C. B. R.
P. ALTHOUGH THERE'S BEEN
CONVERSATION TODAY AND HOW
THAT'S AN OVERSUBSCRIBED PROGRAM.
WE SEE AN OPPORTUNITY TO ADD
ELECTRIC BIKES PEDAL ASSIST
BIKES TO THIS PROGRAM AS A
VIABLE OPTION FOR FOR FOLKS TO
BE ABLE TO GET A REBATE AND
REPLACE THE CAR IN THEIR FAMILY.
OR IN THEIR INDIVIDUAL AND A
CHOICE IS TO BE ABLE TO AT
REPLACE THEIR CAR TRIPS A LOT OF
ALMOST HALF OF CAR TRIPS ARE
ACTUALLY TWO THREE MILES OR LESS --
TO PLACES WHERE PEOPLE ARE
TRAVELING AND THAT CAN BE
ACCOMPLISHED THROUGH -- ELECTRIC
BICYCLE RIDE -- STILL A BARRIER
TO ACCESS -- TO PURCHASING CARD
PURCHASING HE BIKES -- TO
REPLACE CARS IN HOUSEHOLDS AND
SO THIS WOULD BE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO EXPAND THE OPTION -- TO THOSE
FAMILIES WERE ASKING FOR A FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR ADDITION TO THE
C. B. R. P. FOR THAT OR TO
EXPAND THE PROGRAM FOR AT ADDING
THAT OPTION.
THANK YOU.
LOOK AT MORNING MANY OF SEVEN
OLIVER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP IS AND A
MEMBER OF THE SUITABLE
COMMUNITIES FOR ALL ALLIANCE
COALITION.
AND SO IN PARTICULAR I WANT.
TO APPLAUD THE COMMITTEES --
CONCERNED ABOUT EQUITY AND AN
INVESTMENTS AND JUST
COMPRESSIBILITY COMMUNITIES AND
SO WHEN IT COMES THE LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM -- WHICH
IS WHAT I AM ADVOCATING FOR A
PROGRAM THAT UNIQUELY ADVANCES
EQUITY ENVIRONMENTAL -- A
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS I
MISSION REDUCTIONS AS WELL AS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING GOALS.
WE ASK FOR AN INCREASE
STABILIZED -- INVESTMENT OF
SIXTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THAT
WOULD ACTUALLY.
BE NECESSARY TO FOR THE PRO
PROGRAM TO PHIL'S POTENTIAL --
AND ALSO THE PROGRAM HAS
BENEFITED OVER ALMOST SIX
THOUSAND LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS --
HOPE HOPEFULLY SIR MANY MANY
MORE ON THE A IT WHEN IN
ADDITION -- TO ADVANCING CLIMB
IN EQUITY GOALS THE PROGRAM ALSO --
YET WHEN IT COMES AFFORDABLE
HOUSING TO HIS DIRECT CO
BENEFITS AS WELL AS THE I STAY
OF WITH THE DECOMPOSITION
PARTICULAR SO WHILE WHEN IT.
BESIDES TRANSPORTATION --
BUILDINGS ARE THE SECOND LEADING
SOURCE OF GREAT GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS SO -- WE HEAR TO
STRESS.
THE IMPORTANCE OF BUILDING THE
CONVERSATION AS WELL WHEN IT
COMES TO GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
REDUCTIONS THANK YOU.
HI EVERYONE MY DEALER ACHO WITH.
CALIFORNIA RELIEF ARE ALSO PART
OF SYSTEM COMMUNITIES FOR ALL.
THE URBAN GREEN AND OR URBAN FOR
SHIPPERS ARE CRITICAL -- TO
IMPROVING THE HEALTH AND LIVE
ABILITY IN METROPOLITAN AREAS
WITH THE MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS LIVE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM YOU ASKED
ABOUT DEMAND SO FOR THE NATURAL
RESOURCES A RING GREEN PROGRAM
THERE OR SUBSCRIBE ON AVERAGE
5100%.
AND BOTH PLAYED A CENTRAL ROLE
IN URBAN AREAS TO MEETING THE
GREEN HOUSE REDUCTION TARGETS
SET BY SB -- THIRTY TWO THESE
PROGRAMS NOT ONLY ARE NOT ONLY
THE PARMI CARBON SEQUESTRATION
MECHANISM FOR THEY ALSO PROVIDE
MULTIPLE CALL BENEFITS SUCH AS
REDUCING.
URBAN HEAT ISLAND EFFECT --
BEING MANAGE STORM WATER --
IMPROVING AIR WATER QUALITY AND
REDUCING -- ENERGY CONSUMPTION --
FOR THE REASONS THAT MY
COLLEAGUES AND I HAVE A LINE WE
URGE YOU TO INVEST IN.
THESE PROGRAMS WHICH HELP CREATE
SYSTEMIC COMMUNITIES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS FROM THE DíAS ABOUT.
THE SUBSTITUTION OF PROP.
SIXTY EIGHT FOR AN EXPLANATION
FOR AS HEARING OUT THESE --
PROGRAMS THIS HAPPENED LAST YEAR.
IT'S HAPPENED THIS YEAR AND
EVERY SINGLE TIME THAT WE AS AN
ADVOCATE FOR THESE PROGRAMS WE
GO TO THE ADMINISTRATION FOR AN
EXPLANATION IT'S ALWAYS BEEN
PROP SIXTY EIGHT AND THAT WAS
EVEN BEFORE THE VOTERS PASSED
PROP.
SIXTY EIGHT SO -- I WANT TO
VERIFY THAT THAT'S WHAT FROM MY
AND THAT IS WHAT'S HAPPENING ANDI ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU BOTH.
FOR HIGHLIGHTING THE URBAN
GREENING PROGRAM -- THE
ADMINISTRATION SAYS THAT THEY
CRAFTED THIS FOR DA SEASON I BUT
I BELIEVE THAT I CAN SEE WHAT
THE HOUSING AND IMPROVEMENTS
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENTS.
BUT THEY'RE NOT DESIGNING IT TO
IMPROVE THEIR TREE CANOPY OR
GREENING SPACE WHICH IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL THIS IS
WHERE MOST OF THE PEOPLE LIVE WE
NOW HEAT IS COMING HE DOES THE
NUMBER ONE WEATHER RELATED.
MORTALITY -- IMPACT AND IF YOU
LIVE IN LAND IN PACOIMA OR YOUR
DISTRICT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AS WERE IN A LOT
OF TROUBLE AND WE DON'T HAVE
THOSE MATCHING SACRAMENTO
WITHOUT TREES THAT'S WHAT.
A LOT OF THEIR DISTRICT IS LIKE.
SO -- I JUST WANNA SAY
APPRECIATE EVERYTHING I
APPRECIATE CHAMPION THESE OF
PROGRAMS IT'S SUPER IMPORTANT
AND THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS HANNIBAL SMITH AND
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION THANK
YOU.
ASSEMBLY I COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
THE IMPORTANT DISCUSSION TODAY
AS WAS DISCUSSED IN IS EVIDENT
BY THE REPORT ON THE CABIN TRADE
PROCEEDS AND THEIR BENEFITS OF
THE LOW CARBON TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS ARE HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL.
IN REDUCING EMISSIONS BOTH AIR
QUALITY AND CLIMATE POLLUTANTS
AND ALSO PROVIDE SOME OF THE
HIGHEST BENEFITS FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
WHERE VERY THANKFUL FOR THE
INITIAL PROPOSAL FOR THESE
PROGRAMS THAT'S AND THE
GOVERNOR'S FIRST -- BUDGET.
BUT IN ORDER TO REACH OUR AIR
QUALITY CLIMB IT PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SOCIETAL TARGETS WE THINK
THAT THESE PROGRAMS -- NEED TO
SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONAL FUNDING
AS HAS BEEN OUTLINED BY THEIR
RESOURCES BOARD -- AS WELL AS IN
OUR LETTER THAT IS MAKING THE
ROUNDS IN THE LEGISLATURE RIGHT
NOW SO -- WE URGE YOU IF THERE
IS ADDITIONAL FUNDING AVAILABLE
FROM CAP AND TRADE REVENUE TO
ALLOCATE IT TO THE LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS THANK
YOU. ONE OF THE MEAT ON A WITH
AUTUMN ON CALIFORNIA WE ARE --
WE WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN OURSELVES
WITH PREVIOUS COMMENTS RELATED
TO NATURAL RESOURCES THAT SECTOR --
WERE INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL FOR THE
CHAIRS -- INDULGENCE THE AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE A
SPECIFIC HEARING ON PROP SIXTY
EIGHT AND AND HOW DID YOUR DID
YOUR HALF WE THINK THAT IS.
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE -- INVESTMENTS
IN NATURAL RESOURCES IN ADDITION
TO MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
MEETING OUR CLIMATE GOALS
THROUGH CARBON SEQUESTRATION --
WITH THESE IMPORTANT AREAS IN --
WETLANDS ARE IRVINE GREENING
THINGS LIKE THAT IF WE ARE
REALLY TRULY SERIOUS ABOUT
MEETING OUR CLIMATE GOALS IN THE
FUTURE WE NEED TO START
INVESTING NOW.
WE THINK THAT THAT CONVERSATION
NEEDS TO HAPPEN THANK YOU.
HI GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE MATTEO CHROME
TO HAVE THE MOUNDS RECREATION
CONSERVATION AUTHORITY IN THE
SANTA CLARA VALLEY OPEN SPACE OF
FORTY I'M ON A HIGHLIGHT TWO
THINGS.
FIRST OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
INVESTING IN NATURAL WORKING
LANDS -- TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES OTHERS IN
NOT ONLY A COST EFFECTIVE METHOD
OF REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS.
ARMED ALSO INCLUDE SIGNIFICANT
ADAPTATION OF RESILIENCY
BENEFITS -- AS WE'VE SEEN FROM
THE FIRE DISASTERS OTHER NATURAL
DISASTERS THE PAST FEW YEARS ON
THIS IS VERY MUCH A PRIORITY.
I ALSO MISSING MY APPRECIATION
TO YOU -- SIR CHAIR AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE -- FOR
HIGHLIGHTING THIS DYNAMIC
BETWEEN PROP SIXTY EIGHT AND
YOUR OF SPENDING -- THE VOTERS
DEFINITELY DID NOT INTEND PROP
SIXTY TO SUPPLANT ARM OTHER
FUNDING FOR NATURAL RESOURCES
AND REPRESENTATIVE OF CALIFORNIA
RELIEF MENTIONED THE OVER
SUBSCRIPTION ON URBAN GREENING.
OF THAT'S NOT UNIQUE TO THIS
PROGRAM MANY OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES PROP SIXTY FUNDED
PROGRAMS ARE OVERSUBSCRIBED BY.
UP TO A 1000% AND SO THERE IS
ALREADY A HUGE DEMAND -- AND
THIS IS AN AREA WORKING SEE A
LOT OF PROGRESS SO WE HOPE THE
COMMITTEE -- SPORTY'S NATURI
SOURCE INVESTMENTS THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING A ROBIN UNIONS
WITH CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE --
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF INCREASED
FUNDING FOR COVER CYCLE AND
HEALTHY SOILS -- FIRST OF ALL
I'D LIKE TO START BY THINKING
THIS COMMITTEE FOR ITS SUPPORT
FOR QATAR CYCLE PROGRAMS --
PROGRAMS MANAGED BY COLOR CYCLE
HAVE BEEN AMONGST THE THE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE IN TERMS OF
GREENHOUSE REDUCE PER DOLLAR
SPENT -- THE PROGRAMS RIGHT
SIGNIFICAN VESTMENT FOR OUR
CITIES AND COUNTIES.
THERE NEED TO CHEAP FOOD
RECOVERING ORGANICS VERSION
GOALS THROUGHOUT THE STATE -- WE
ASK THAT YOU CONTINUE SUPPORT
THESE PROGRAMS I DO BELIEVE THAT
THEY ARE GOING TO BE -- THEY'RE
GOING TO BECOME INCREASINGLY
IMPORTANT AS CALIFORNIA
SPONSORED CHANGING GLOBAL AND
REGIONAL LANDSCAPES THINKING.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MICHAEL
HIMSELF THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION I WANT TO LINE MY
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF HANDLED
SMITH THAT CALLIE DC.
IN ORDER TO CONTINUE INVESTMENT
IN LOW CARBON TRANSPORTATION IN
PARTICULAR WERE INTERESTED IN --
CONTINUED INVESTMENTS IN ZERO
MISSION -- TRUCKS AND BUSES --
AND I DO WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
WHEN IT COMES TO LECTURE
VACATION OF HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT FLEET OWNERS
IT'S IMPORTANT HAVE SOME
CONSISTENCY IN STATE FUNDING --
SO YOU CAN DO SOME PLANNING FOR
YOUR PROCUREMENTS AND REALLY --
GET TO A POINT WHERE YOUR
THINKING ABOUT HOW YOU ELECTRIFY
FULLY -- YOUR FLEET I AND AND
AND AND AND UNFORTUNATELY -- ONE
YOUR INVESTMENT THAT DON'T
PROVIDE THAT CERTAINTY -- CAN
HAVE A CHILLING EFFECT ON FLEET
OWNERS AS IN MAKING THIS
TRANSITION SO ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONSIDER -- LOOKING AT EITHER A
MULTI YEAR ON GOING
APPROPRIATION I TO SUPPORT LOW
CARBON TRANSPORTATION THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JENNIFER FEARING HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CENTER FOR FOOD SAFETY
AND WANTED TO START BY SAYING
HOW GRATEFUL WE ARE TO LA -- AND
TO YOUR STAFF FOR THE THOUGHTFUL
QUESTIONS POSED ABOUT WHAT
VALUES RESULTS AND OUTCOMES ARE
ADVANCING ACHIEVED WITH THE KIND
OF INVESTMENTS THAT WE MAKE IN.
THE CENTER FOR FOOD SAFETY
THINKS THAT ONGOING INVESTMENTS
IN DERRY DIE JESTERS MERIT
PARTICULAR SCRUTINY ALONG THOSE
LINES.
AT THE STATE'S OBJECTIVES ARE
NOT TO INCREASE DAIRY HERD SIZES
AND PROMOTE BUSINESS AS USUAL AT
LARGE SCALE FACTORY FARMS IN THE
VALLEY.
ESPECIALLY THE SIGNIFICANT AIR
AND WATER POLLUTION THEY POSE
FOR IMPACTED COMMUNITIES AND
PAUSING ON ANY ADDITIONAL THE
JESTER INVESTMENTS MAKE
TREMENDOUS SENSE TO US -- JUST
ADD ALSO ON BEHALF OF DEFENDERS
OF WILDLIFE WE WANT TO FLAG ARE
DEEP CONCERNS ABOUT THE PROPOSED
HEARING OUT OF THE WETLANDS
FUNDING IN THE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL --
WITH THE STATE WATER BOARD
ADOPTING YESTERDAY A LONG
OVERDUE WETLANDS POLICY -- IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO PUT ZERO
DOLLARS TOWARDS THIS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT WE HAVE 10% OF OUR
STATE'S WETLANDS -- REMAIN
INTACT AND THEY CAN CONTRIBUTE A
LOT TO ECOLOGICAL SERVICES AND
CLIMATE RESILIENCY THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING DISAPPEAR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BRING
RC ON BEHALF OF SEE ON OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL SERVICES AND
WEEPING WASTE WE WANNA LANA
COMMENTS WITH CALIFORNIA'S
GAINES WASTE -- FOR CHARIS I GOT
UP A HUNDRED MILLION MORE
DOLLARS FOR ORGANIC WASTE
DIVERSION FACILITIES.
IF WE ARE TO MEET OUR ORGANIC
WASTE DIVERSION GOALS WE NEED TO
HEAVILY INVEST IN THEM.
CALPERS LIKE LOS MATES WE NEED
THERE IS A NET COST OF THE STATE
OF THREE BILLION DOLLARS JUST TO
MEET THOSE GOALS.
IN A FIVE HUNDRED TO ONE HUNDRED
NEW AND EXPANDED FACILITIES IF
YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO MEET OUR
GOALS WANT TO REDUCE EMISSIONS
WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO TRUST AND
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING TO ALL KRAMER'S THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION THIS MORNING BY THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICULARLY
ON THE AG.
PROGRAMS FOR THE AG DIESEL
REPLACEMENT PROGRAM.
I AM IT'S RECEIVED TWO HUNDRED
AND SIXTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE PAST TWO BUDGETS.
HOWEVER IT'S RECEIVED
APPLICATIONS WORTH OVER THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
REPLACING THAT AG EQUIPMENT.
IT IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT FOR
HELPING MEETING THE GOAL OF THE
PM TWO POINT FIVE STEP.
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY I'M.
THAT SIP INCLUDES A GOAL OF
REPLACING TWELVE THOUSAND
TRACTORS BY TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
AT AN ESTIMATED COST OF ONE
BILLION DOLLARS WHICH IS WHY
WE'RE ASKING. FOR TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE AG DIESEL
REPLACEMENT -- PORTION.
WE ALSO WOULD LIKE TO SEE ON AND
SUPPORT AN INCREASE IN FUNDING
FOR THAT AT TERRY NOTHING
PROJECTS THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS BRENDAN TO
IT ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION THAT'S EXECUTIVE
OFFICER SMALL THIRTY FIVE LOCAL
AIR DISTRICTS -- WE HAVE A AT
PRIMARY ROLE CENTRAL ROLE IN
IMPLEMENTING AB SIX SEVENTEEN
WHICH IS A IMPORTANT -- BUT ALSO
AMBITIOUS PROGRAM TO IMPROVE
PUBLIC HEALTH IN OVER BURDEN
COMMUNITIES -- I WANTED TO TALK
TODAY JUST ABOUT -- FUNDING THAT
UNDER THE PROGRAM WE'RE REQUIRED
TO PURCHASE A MAINTAIN
MONITORING EQUIPMENT -- ENGAGE
WITH THE COMMUNITY AND ALSO --
DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT EMISSION
REDUCTION PLANS I JUST TO NAME A
FEW.
AND TO DO ALL THAT ALSO REQUIRES
STAFF AND AND AND AND RESOURCES --
LAST YEAR -- WE WERE PROVIDED
FOR IMPLEMENTATION FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET -- WHICH
WE DO APPRECIATE AND THEN
THERE'S ANOTHER FIFTY MILLION
PROPOSED IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
WHICH AGAIN WE APPRECIATE -- BUT
IT IS LESS THAN THE SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION THAT WE ASKED IN LAST
YEAR'S FOR LAST YEAR'S BUDGET.
AND OUR EXPERIENCE OVER THE LAST
NINETEEN MONTHS IS SHOWING --
THAT IMPLEMENTATION COSTS ARE
EVEN HIGHER THAN THE SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION THAT WE ASK -- FOR
IT'S MAKING IT.
VERY DIFFICULT -- TO IMPLEMENT
THE PROGRAM WITH THE WITHOUT
BEING ABLE TO PLAN FOR STAFF AND
AND HAVE THE PROPER RESOURCES IN
PLACE -- THAT'S WHY WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE LA US
RECOMMENDATION TO DEVELOP A LONG
TERM FUNDING PLAN WHICH WE THINK
WILL GO A LONG WAY TO ADDRESSING
THOSE ISSUES.
ADDITIONALLY -- WE ASK FOR FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION AB SIX SEVENTEEN
INCENTIVE FUNDING -- WE FIND
THAT THAT INCENTIVE FUNDING IS
THE MOST EXPEDITIOUS AND COST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO GET EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS IN OVER BURDEN
COMMUNITIES.
WE'RE ALSO ASKING FOR TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION FOR THE
FOR FOR AGRICULTURAL DIESEL
ENGINE REPLACEMENT.
AND LASTLY -- WANTED TO REQUEST
TWENTY MILLION FOR WOOD STOVE --
REDUCTION FUNDING -- LAST YEAR
THE SENATE PROPOSED TWENTY
MILLION IN THEIR BUDGET
ULTIMATELY THERE WAS THREE
MILLION IN THE BUDGET SO WE'RE
WE ARE ASKING FOR THAT TWENTY
MILLION WE THINK IT'S A COST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO GET REDUCTIONS.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S ALAN AB SOME
OF THE BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT I'D LIKE TO
LINE MY COMMENTS -- FIRST OF ALL
WITH THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM CAP
COLOR -- FURTHER NOTED THE BAY
AREA A Q. M. D. HAS -- TO
COMMUNITIES IN THE FIRST YEAR
MAYBE SIX SEVENTEEN AND AND NOTE
THAT THE OUR EXPENSES HAVE
EXCEEDED.
OUR REGIONAL -- BUDGET
ALLOCATION FOR THOSE PROGRAMS I
ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT -- AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING US LINE OF
QUESTIONING -- GOT TO I'D --
INCENTIVE FUNDING TO THE BAY
AREA A Q. M. D. -- IT HAS --
SEVERAL PURPOSES ONE IT REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GASES ONE IT REDUCES
KNOCKS EMISSIONS AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY FOR THE SIX
SEVENTEEN PROGRAM IT REDUCES --
DIESEL PARTICULATE MATTER IN OUR
MOST -- OVERBURDENED COMMUNITIES
SPECIFICALLY WEST OAKLAND AND
THAT -- EASTERN -- BAY CORRIDOR
AND SO -- WE WOULD -- LOOK TO OF
WITH KEPCO IT -- THE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN IMPLEMENTATION GOING
FORWARD AS WELL AS THE FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
INCENTIVE FUNNY GOING FOR THANK
YOU.
TURN MEMBERS ROSS BUCKLEY ON
BEHALF OF SOUTH COAST AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
ALECTO LINE MY COMMENTS WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM CAP COLA.
KLAY THE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
FOR IMPLEMENTATION IN THE FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
INCENTIVES.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS JAMIE GO ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA RELIEF JUST WANTED
ALIGN OURSELVES WITH A COUPLE
COMMENTS MADE PREVIOUSLY.
BY EDF TNC AND A COUPLE
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS ON
THE NEED FOR ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS FOR NATURAL
RESOURCES ON TOP OF PROPOSITION
SIXTY EIGHT AND ALSO WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
LETTER.
THAT REQUEST FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION FOR THESE PURPOSES THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBER
STEPHANIE MORAL HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION.
THE CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION IS IN SUPPORT OF A
MULTI YEAR ALLOCATION OF G. R.
FOREVER NEW TO THE CLEAN TRUCK
BUS AND OFF ROAD EQUIPMENT
PROGRAM.
WE BELIEVE STABLE INCENTIVE
FUNDING IS VITAL TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF ZERO AND YEARS
ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS AND WE HOPE
TO CONTINUE OUR STRONG
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE FOR
CLEANER FREE TECHNOLOGY THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ROCKY
RUSSIAN WITH COALITION FOR CLEAN
AIR AND FIRST I WANNA SAY WE
APPRECIATE -- ELLIE OWES
COMMENTS AS WELL AS STAFF
COMMENTS REGARDING THE NEED FOR
FOCUS ON HOW.
DID YOU ARRIVE -- SPENDING IS --
IN LINE WITH THE OVERALL
STRATEGY AND HOW THESE DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS INTERACT TO ACHIEVE OUR
CLIMATE GOALS AND ARE AT THE
CORE BENEFITS -- WE WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FIRST AB YOUR SCRUTINY
IN THE ADMINISTRATION'S YOU'RE
ROLLING IT OUT IMPORTANT AND
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS -- LIKE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON OTHERS --
CLOSE CLEAN AIR IS CONCERNED
ABOUT THE REDUCTION SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTION AND SPENDING AG
SPENDING FOR THE DIESEL ENGINE
REPLACEMENT PROGRAM AND WE DON'T
THINK THAT.
HARDLY ADEQUATE TO ACHIEVE WHAT
NEEDS TO BE ACHIEVED IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY -- LIKE TO THINK
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS -- AND WE WOULD
NEED AT FOR HER COMMENTS
REGARDING THE NEED.
FOR AT HEAVY DUTY FUNDING AND WE
SUPPORT MULTI YEAR FUNDING LIKE
THE CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION.
FOR THE OPERATOR QUIT THE
PROGRAMS.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING A. B. FORTY ELEVEN AS
WELL AS SB.
FORTY FOUR AND LASTLY WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE CLEAN
VEHICLE WROTE -- REPLACEMENT
PROGRAM AND IT'S PROJECTED --
SHORTFALLS AND WE WILL WORK WITH
OUR STATE CALL OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS AND COLLEAGUES TO
IF.
RESTRUCTURING IS NECESSARY WILL
BE WORKING ON THAT AS WELL SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING REBECCA MARK AS
REPRESENTING AMERICAN FARMLAND
TRUST AND THE CARBON CYCLE
INSTITUTE.
BOTH ORGANIZATIONS ARE PLEASED
BY THE GOVERNOR'S PASSION FOR
THE HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM AND
SUPPORT GREATER INVESTMENTS IN
HEALTHY SOILS SOLUTIONS TO
CLIMATE CHANGE THREE PROGRAMS
HEALTHY SOILS POWER CYCLE AND
AND THE ALTERNATIVE MANURE
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM.
ARE INTEGRAL TO ACHIEVING THE
STATE'S MODEST HEALTHY SOILS
GOALS BY INCENTIVIZING PRODUCERS
TO TRANSITION TO CLIMATE SMART
PRACTICES AND BUILDING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WE NEED TO MAKE
COMPOST AFFORDABLE.
AND ACCESSIBLE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WE ARE SUPPORTING THE
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTHY SOILS
BUDGET ASK A FIFTY MILLION FOR
THE HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM A
HUNDRED MILLION FOR OUR CYCLE
AND A FORTY MILLION LINE ITEM
FOR THE ALTERNATIVE MANURE
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM.
AS PART OF THE STATE'S NATURAL
WORKING LANDS IN ORGANIC WASTE
REDUCTION CLIMATE STRATEGIES.
GOOD MORNING DOCTOR REVEREND
MINISTER OF CIVIL RIGHTS AND
HUMAN RIGHTS I'M HERE FOR MOTHER
EARTH KEEP IT CLEAN THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING KIANA ROSS ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF STOCKTON
MAYOR MICHAEL TUBS HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE HUNDRED AND FORTY
MILLION BUT THE TRANSFORMATIONAL
CLIMATE COMMUNITIES PROGRAM.
THIS IS WITH IT IT'S ALREADY A
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM THAT IS
PRODUCED SIGNIFICANT EMISSION
REDUCTIONS AND LEAD TO
ADDITIONAL SOLAR ROOFS AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE THINK IT'S
A STRONG PROGRAMMING SHOULD BE
FULLY FUNDED THANK YOU -- GOOD
MORNING STEVE ALL HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CAL AT THE CENTER FOR
TRANSPORTATION ENVIRONMENTS --
C. D. E. SAID NONPROFIT TELL
HELPS DEVELOP -- TECHNOLOGIES
AND ZERO MISSION -- MEDIUM HEAVY
DUTY TRUCKS WE SUPPORT -- THE
THE INCREASE FUNDING -- FOR
BUDGET TRUCK PROGRAMS IN A LOW
CARBON -- TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM.
AND HAD PARTICULAR MULTI YEAR
ALLOCATION AS WELL YOU WILD --
TRANSIT OPERATORS ARE REQUIRED.
TO TRANSITION IS OUR MISSION
BUSES ARE STILL NEEDS --
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT -- TO
BRING VERTICALLY A FUEL CELL
BUSES UP TO COMMERCIAL KIND OF
COMPETITIVENESS AND SO WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR A UP ALLOCATION.
FOR A FUEL CELL BUS PILOT
PROGRAM THAT'S IDENTIFIED IN
CARBS EXPENDITURE PLANS OF THANK
YOU.
PERSONAL GET US ON BEHALF OF
STOP WAY SINCE FOR THE G. G. R.
F. FUNDING FOR HEALTHY SOILS AND
ALSO FOR STOP WAYS.
SOLID WASTE ASSOCIATION OF NORTH
AMERICA AND NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP
ACTION COUNCIL IN CALIFORNIA
PRODUCTS WHICH A COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT OF FUNDING FOR CALORIE
CYCLE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS SCRIBBLES ON BEHALF OF
CAL STAR -- I'D REALLY LIKE TO A
LINE -- MY COMMENTS WITH MY
COLLEAGUES -- MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION ABOUT
THE NEED -- TO PUT MORE FUNDING
INTO LOW CARBON TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS -- ACROSS THE SUITE OF
PROGRAMS SO THAT C. V. R. P. FOR
CARS AND THEN CLEAN TRUCKS AND
BUSES.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO REINFORCE ALIGN
MYSELF WITH COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES -- BOTH THAT THE
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION AND
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF MORE ROBUST
FUNDING FOR MEDIUM HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES ON A MULTI YEAR BASIS
AND THANK YOU SOME REMEMBER
REYES FOR YOUR FOCUS IN THIS
ISSUE ARIAN RAISING YOUR
QUESTIONS DURING THIS HEARING.
A REALLY IMPORTANT DISTINCTION
ABOUT THIS PROGRAM COMPARED TO
MANY OTHERS IS THAT.
IF WE WANT BUSINESSES OR I
SHOULD SAY BUSINESSES ARE POISED
NOW TO CONTINUE RESEARCHING AND
DEVELOPING NEXT GENERATION CLEAN
VEHICLE TECHNOLOGIES.
BY.
ALLOCATING MONEY MONEY ON A
MULTI YEAR BASIS REINFORCES
THEIR INVESTMENT DECISIONS AND
THEY'RE PLANNING DECISIONS AND
WHEN WE DO THIS KIND OF ANNUAL
PROCESS.
IT UNDERCUTS THEIR ABILITY TO
MORE EFFECTIVELY PLAN SO THAT WE
CAN BRING THESE TECHNOLOGIES TO
MARKET MUCH FASTER THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS TIFFANY
ACHING WITH CALIFORNIAN VINYL
JUST LANCER SE HA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
DISCUSSION TODAY -- I WANT TO BE
HERE TO RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT HUNDRED
FORTY MILLION FOR THE
TRANSFORMER CLIMATE COMMITTEES
PROGRAM.
AS WELL AS FIVE MILLION FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR ALL DID
YOU HAVE PROGRAMS -- AS YOU
PROBABLY KNOW TO SEE IS REALLY
POINT TO FIND AT A MUCH HIGHER
LEVEL BECAUSE ONE OF THE ONLY
PROGRAMS THAT IN THE STATE IF
NOT THE NATION.
THAT CAN REDUCE GHG EMISSIONS
AND ADVANCE APPROVAL COMMITTED
ELEMENT USING A HOLISTIC AND
MULTI PROJECT APPROACH WE ALSO
KNOW THAT IN ORDER TO BE
EFFECTIVE IN REDUCING EMISSIONS.
AND POLLUTION THESE TYPES OF
COMPREHENSIVE INTEGRATED
STRATEGIES.
ARE NECESSARY AND CRUCIAL SO --
YOU KNOW TCC PROVIDES A WIDE
ARRAY OF IMPORTANT NEED A
COMMUNE CALL BENEFITS AS WELL.
SUCH AS AN IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND JOBS AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND IMPROVE TRANSIT SYSTEMS AND
COMMUTER EXPERIENCE SOME OF THE
HIGHEST POLLUTION BURDENS AND
POVERTY AS WELL AS INVESTMENT IN
OUR STATE SO.
YOU KNOW IN ORDER TO ALSO MAKE
SOME OF THE FIFTEEN TO SEE
PLANNING GRANTS A REALITY WE
KNOW THAT WE MUST INCREASE
FUNDING FOR THE PROGRAM AND
ENSURE THAT SOME OF THESE LOW
CAPACITY GROUPS CAN RECEIVE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. TO BE MORE
COMPETITIVE FOR THESE GRANTS SO
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
AND REALLY HOPE THAT WE CAN GET
YOUR SUPPORT FOUR HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION FOR TCC AS WELL AS FIVE
MILLION FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
THANK YOU.
HI STEPHANIE THIGH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
LINES THE HOUSE SO -- WE'VE
SHARED A LETTER WITH YOU ON
MULTIPLE TEACHER OF PRIORITIES
FOR US I WON'T I WON'T GO
THROUGH ALL OF THEM BUT I DO
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW -- FIRST
IS -- EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN YOU
KNOW I THINK BOTTOM LINE IS A
HIGHLIGHT THAT WE YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA HAS EIGHT OF THE TEN
CITIES ACROSS THE UNITED STATES
WITH THE DIRTIEST AIR IN THE
NATION -- THESE COMMUNITIES YOU
KNOW TEY THEY PAY THE PRICE
EVERY DAY WITH THEIR HEALTH AND
WELL BEING.
AND SO AT THE END OF THE DAY YOU
KNOW BEEN WORKING WITH THEIR
DISTRICTS WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH KERR -- WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY NEED MORE RESOURCES AND YOU
KNOW STAFFING TO IMPLEMENT THESE
PROGRAMS ON AND WE ALSO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE REALLY NEED IS
IS TO REDUCE EMISSIONS DIRECTLY
AT THE SOURCE AND IF WE DO THAT
WE REDUCE THE CRITERION TOXIC
GREENHOUSE GASES -- SO IN LINE
WITH THAT AND WE ALSO SUPPORT --
MORE FUNDING FOR CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PARTICULARLY
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY -- WE
REALLY WANT TO PRIORITIZE ZERO
MISSION INVESTMENTS -- THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE MOST
IMPACTED HAVE BEEN FOR CRYSTAL
CLEAR ABOUT ABOUT THIS
PRIORITIZATION -- YOU KNOW WE
DON'T WANT TO SEE CONTINUED
INVESTMENTS IN NATURAL GAS
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH PERPETUATE
OUR DEPENDENCE ON FOSSIL FUELS --
THIRDLY LIE WITH ALL AND I'LL
JUST SAY THAT YOU KNOW A 100% OF
LIGHT WITH PROGRAM FUNDS
ACTUALLY DIRECTLY BENEFIT LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES WHO WOULD NOT
OTHERWISE HAVE ACCESS TO
RENEWABLE ENERGY -- AND ALSO
HELPS REDUCE THEIR ENERGY BURDEN.
ON AND ALSO REALLY YOU KNOW
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION ABOUT
IN THE ANALYSIS ABOUT WHERE THIS
MONEY COMES FROM AND JUST WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT IF WE RAISE THE
PRICE OF CARBON.
YOU KNOW WE CAN GET MUCH MORE
SERIOUS ABOUT REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GASES ENDS THERE WILL
BE MORE MONEY.
THANKS.
GOOD MORNING CARE BLOOM AND
MEMBERS TRICIA GERINGER WITH
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA EVERY REPRESENT OVER
FIFTEEN THOUSAND FARMERS ALL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
A VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF THE
AIR DISTRICTS PREVIOUS REQUEST
THAT WAS JUST MENTIONED OF
BOOSTING THE FARMER PROGRAM.
UP FROM THE EXISTING DOLLAR
AMOUNT FOR THE AG DIESEL ENGINE
REPLACEMENTS UP TO TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION.
OTHER IMPORTANCE AT
DISADVANTAGED KINI BENEFITS AIR
HEALTH BENEFITS THAT RESULT AS A
RESULT OF THAT.
OZONE AND THAT HAVE PARTICULAR.
AND HOPING TO MEET PARTICULATE
MATTER STANDARDS.
ALSO WE SUPPORT AB BOOSTING THE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION LISTED UP TO
NINETY NINE MILLION.
AND VERY MUCH SUPPORT THAT'S
GIVEN THAT THOSE BENEFITS GO
INTO.
IF YOU DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AND THERE ARE MULTIPLE CO
BENEFITS -- IN ADDITION TO
REDUCING THE METHANE ON THE THG
SIDE AT THE CO BENEFITS INCLUDE.
OTHER AIR QUALITY IMPROVEMENTS --
KNOCKS AMMONIA IMPROVEMENTS AND
ALSO WATER QUALITY WITH RESPECT
TO LINING OF THE GOONS AS IT
RELATES TO TERRY DIGEST STARS
AND ALONG WITH THAT VERY MUCH
SUPPORTS THE ALTERNATE BEEN NORA
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM AS WELL
WITHIN.
NINETY NINE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LARA
KNOWING HE JACK ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL
CALIFORNIA CONGENERS AND GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WESTERN ACT
PROCESSORS CALIFORNIA.
INTERAMERICAN STASH YOUR GROWERS
AND VARIOUS OTHER ACT TRADE
ASSOCIATIONS AND COMMISSIONS --
VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF THE AIR
DISTRICTS REQUEST TO INCREASE
THAT FUNDING FOR DIESEL TRACTORS --
TRUCKS AND PUMPS TO TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION AS IT'S BEEN
STATED THESE ARE FANTASTIC
PROGRAMS THAT ARE SHOWN TO BE
WORKING AND IT GETS THOSE
TRACTORS TRUCKS AND ATVS.
THAT ARE OF THE LOWER TIER THAT
CARS TRYING TO GET RID OF
COMPLETELY CRASH THERE NEVER
GOING TO BE USED AGAIN AND WE'RE
INCREASING OUR ON AIR QUALITY OR
MEETING OUR AIR QUALITY GO GOALS
AND GETTING A LOT OF THOSE CO
BENEFITS -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING
I APPRECIATE YOUR QUESTION ON
WITH SOME OF THESE INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS DON'T WE WANT TO GET
THE INDUSTRY TO JUST BE GOING
THERE AN AGGIE HAS BEEN AND
THEY'RE READY TO GO -- ONE OF
THE REASONS THAT THIS PROGRAM IS
SO IMPORTANT IS BECAUSE IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE SUCH HIGH
QUALITY AIR QUALITY STANDARDS
WERE GOING FOR THOSE TEAR FOR
TRACTORS.
IN AUSTRALIA FOR EXAMPLE THEY
THAT WE COMPETE WITH MANY OF OUR
CROPS NIGHTS COTTON FRESH FRUIT --
THEY DON'T HAVE THE SAME ONES SO
FOR INSTANCE A FRONT LOADER.
WHICH IS BASICALLY JUST OF GIANT
TRACTOR WITH A BUCKET THAT FIX
THINGS UP AND LOADED IN
SOMETHING ELSE.
IN AUSTRALIA THAT COST SIXTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA TO GET A TEAR FOR ITS
THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
SO WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT
COMPETING ON A GLOBAL MARKET AND
TRYING TO MEET THOSE AIR QUALITY
GOALS.
ANY INCENTIVE PROGRAMS TO HELP
FARMERS GET THEIR WELL BEING
ABLE TO COMPETE GLOBALLY IS VERY
IMPORTANT -- WERE ALSO VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF INCREASING THE
MANY ARE MANAGEMENT -- ALTERNATE
MANY OR MANAGEMENT IN DERRY DIE
JUSTER PROGRAMS UNDER CAP AND
TRADE TO THE NINETY NINE MILLION --
THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY
SUCCESSFUL IN REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AS WELL
AS THE OTHER CO BENEFITS -- MANY
OF THE JERRY DIE JESTERS ARE
ALSO MAKING RENEWABLE FUEL WHICH
CAN HELP IN OUR TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR.
SO -- THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
PROGRAM AND WE JUST ENCOURAGE
YOU TO CONTINUE IN THAT FUNDING
THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MATTHEW
ALLEN WITH WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WE WOULD JUST
MERRILY LIKE TO TO VOICE OUR
SUPPORT OF THE FUNDING REQUEST
INCREASE FOR THE FARMER PROGRAM
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHEN MEMBERS MY
NAME'S BRANCH OF I'M WITH CAL
CANNED CALIFORNIA CLIMATE
AGRICULTURE NETWORK BURKE
COALITION OF THE STATE'S
SUSTAINABLE AND ORGANIC
AGRICULTURE ORGANIZATIONS -- AND
I WANT TO BRING UP THE AN
AGRICULTURAL PROGRAM THAT HASN'T
BEEN TALKED ABOUT YET WHICH IS
THE SWEEP PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM I INCENTIVIZE IS
FARMS TO CONVERT TO CLEANER MORE
EFFICIENT IRRIGATION SYSTEMS
THAT CONVERT FROM OUTDATED
DIESEL PUMPS TO SOLAR POWERED
PUMPS.
OUT REDUCE GROUNDWATER
CONTAMINATION AND MAKES A
PARTICULARLY SMALL FARMS MORE
RESILIENT TO DROUGHT -- I WANTED
APPRECIATE THE MEMBER'S COMMENTS
ABOUT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE --
RECOGNIZING THE NEED FOR THAT WE
PASSED A BILL LAST YEAR THAT --
AUTOMATICALLY ENTERS THE 5% OF
FUNDS FOR SWEEP HEALTHY SOILS
AND THE ALTERNATE MANURE
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM.
GOES TO TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
25% OF THAT IS REQUIRED TO GO TO
SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED FARMERS
AND RANCHERS -- SO JUST WANTED
TO NOTE THAT -- IMPORTANT CHANGE
TO THOSE PROGRAMS -- AND NOT
SURPRISINGLY THREE THREE
QUARTERS OF THE GRANTS THIS
PROGRAM HAVE GONE TO SMALL AND
MID SCALE FARMS.
ON FOLLOWING THE THEME OF PROP.
SIXTY EIGHT FUNDS --
SUPPLEMENTING NOT SUPPLANT TEEN --
THIS PROGRAM RECEIVED TWENTY
MILLION LAST YEAR FOR PROP SIXTY
EIGHT THAT WILL BE ENTIRELY
SPENT ON BY THE END OF THIS YEAR.
AS IF WE DON'T SEE GINGER A
FUNDS THE PROGRAM WILL
DISCONTINUE.
AND AND THEN LASTLY WE ARE ALSO
SEEKING A SMALL ASK OF TWO
MILLION DOLLARS FOR ADAPTATION
AND RESILIENCY -- PLANNING AND
DECISION SUPPORT TOOLS AND
AGRICULTURE THANK YOU.
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS PAUL MASON
THE PACIFIC FOR US TRUST ALL BE
BRIEF -- WE SHARE ALL THE SAME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE NETWORKING
LAND PROGRAMS BEING ELIMINATED
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET IS A PLANT AND IS BACK
FILLED WITH PROP.
SIXTY EIGHT THE TERRIBLY
INEFFICIENT USE OF BOND FUNDS --
AND WE REALLY FEEL LIKE THOSE
SHOULD BE ADDITIVE -- IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT BE
INVESTING IN THESE NETWORKING
LAND PROGRAMS FOR WETLANDS AND
WATERSHEDS AND URBAN GREENING
INTO THOSE SORTS OF ACTIVITIES
BECAUSE IT HELPS ADVANCE OUR
ADAPTATION GOALS AND WE'RE GONNA
SEE A TERRIBLE AMOUNT OF CLIMATE
CHANGE AND ARE ALSO MARIO'S.
MAKING SURE THAT OUR INVESTMENTS
ARE HELPING US TO PREPARE FOR
THOSE THINGS IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
FINALLY I WOULD KNOW THAT THOSE
INVESTMENTS BECAUSE THEY'RE
OUTSIDE OF THE CAP SECTOR ARE
ALSO GOING TO BE MORE EFFICIENT
AND GETTING US THOSE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTIONS.
THAN BEING INVESTED IN PROGRAMS
ARE OPERATING WITHIN THE CAP
SECTOR.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS DOCTOR
JOEL CAMACHO I'M ORDERED FOR THE
PLAN AND SAVING THE EARTH THANK
YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SYLVIA'S
FELICIA ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT WE HAVE TWENTY
OF THE THIRTY MOST DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE FACE SOME OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT AIR QUALITY
CHALLENGES IN THE COUNTRY FOR
THESE REASONS WE ASK THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR TO
PRIORITIZE THE INCLUSION OF TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION. FOR
THE FARMER PROGRAM TO REPLACE AG
EQUIPMENT IN THE VALLEY AND FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION IN STATE RIGHT
FUNDING FOR THE AB SIX SEVENTEEN
COMMUNITY AIR PROTECTION PROGRAM.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
AS THE BUDGET PROCESS CONTINUES
THANK YOU.
MORNING MEANING FOR ON BEHALF OF
THAT COALITION FOR RENEWABLE
NATURAL GAS.
AND WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
AUGMENTING THE FUNDING AVAILABLE
TO DERRY DIE JESTERS AND JUST
FOR THE RECORD I KNOW THERE'S
BEEN SOME CONFLICTING
INFORMATION SHARED TODAY ABOUT
THE BENEFITS OF DIRT AYE JESTERS.
I'M IN NOVEMBER OF LAST YEAR AS
PART OF THE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE IMPLEMENTATION PREP
PROCESS CARB ACTUALLY CONDUCTED
THEIR OWN ANALYSIS.
AND FOUND SIGNIFICANT REDUCTIONS
IN METHANE CARBON DIOXIDE
NITROUS OXIDE PARTICULATE MATTER
CARBON MONOXIDE SULFUR DIOXIDE
MODEL ORGANIC COMPOUNDS HYDROGEN
SULFIDE OF AN AMMONIA.
INTEREST OXIDE AND IMPROVEMENTS
IN WATER QUALITY I'M HAPPY TO
SHARE THAT INFORMATION AND WITH%
THE COMMITTEE WITH ALL OF YOUR
STAFFS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MICHAEL BROKER ON
BEHALF OF THE AG ENERGY
CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION ALSO HERE
IN SUPPORT OF AN INCREASE IN
FUNDING FOR THE JERRY.
METHANE REDUCTION PROGRAM THAT'S
BOTH THE DIE JESTER AND THE
ALTERNATIVE MANURE MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM.
IT IS A LITTLE FRUSTRATING FOR
US TO HEAR SOME OF THE
MISINFORMATION -- PEOPLE -- I
THINK CAN LOOK TO THE CLIMATE
INVESTMENT REPORT THAT JUST CAME
OUT IT DOCUMENTS ONE CONCLUSION
THAT YOU CAN DRAW.
AND THAT IS THE JERRY DIED JUST
A PROGRAM IN PARTICULAR IS
ARGUABLY THE MOST EFFECTIVE AND
EFFICIENT INVESTMENT THE STATE
IS CURRENTLY MAKING OF ALL SIXTY
INVESTMENTS.
MORE GHG REDUCTION EXPECTED FROM
THAT PROGRAM SECOND MOST COST
EFFECTIVE SUBSTANTIAL
ENVIRONMENTAL CO BENEFITS ALL
THOSE THINGS TELL ME IT'S A
GREAT PROGRAM LET ME GIVE YOU A
CONCRETE EXAMPLE.
EVERY DAY ABOUT A HUNDRED TRUCKS
LEAVE KERN COUNTY ON THE WAY
OVER THE HILL TO ARTESIAN MISS
GARCIA'S DISTRICT WHERE THEY ARE
DELIVERING MILK TO THE
CALIFORNIA JERRY'S INCORPORATED
PLANT.
MOST OF THOSE BERRIES AND KERN
COUNTY -- DEVELOPING NOTHING DIE
JESTERS THAT WILL PRODUCE
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS FOR
TRANSPORTATION FUEL WE'RE GONNA
BE ABLE TO USE THAT TO REPLACE
DIESEL ON THOSE TRUCKS
ULTIMATELY SO THOSE TRUCKS THAT
ARE GOING OVER.
THE TO HATCH APPEASE INTO THE LA
BASIN WILL PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT
AIR QUALITY BENEFITS IN THE
VALLEY AND IN THE LA BASIN SO
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL CO BENEFITS THAT
THESE PROJECTS CAN PROVIDE.
AND LASTED THIS ONE REMIND
EVERYBODY IT'S ALL NOTHING WHICH
MEANS WE'RE GOING TO SEE THE
BENEFITS OF THIS PROGRAM FASTER
THAN OTHER INVESTMENTS THAT ARE
JUST REDUCING CARBON DIOXIDE.
BECAUSE NOTHING TO SHORT LIVED
CLIMATE POLLUTANTS FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO
INCREASE FUNDING.
LAST I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT --
THE PROGRAM IS CLOSING TODAY FOR
APPLICATIONS SO THE MONEY THAT
WAS PROVIDED IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET WILL BE FULLY
APPROPRIATED WE EXPECT AS WE'VE
SEEN THE PAST FOUR YEARS.
BOTH OF THOSE PROGRAMS WILL BE
GREATLY OVERSUBSCRIBED SO THE
NEED WILL BE THERE AS WE MOVE
INTO THIS BUDGET CYCLE FOR NEXT
YEAR TO HAVE SUBSTANTIAL FUNDING
IN THE PROGRAM TWENTY FIVE
MILLION IS NOT ENOUGH.
THANK YOU.
TIFFANY VAN WE HAVE LAND OF
LAKES JUST WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS FROM THE AG INDUSTRY ON
SUPPORTING FUNDING FOR METHANE
REDUCTION.
THANK YOU.
CODY BOILS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED BIOFUELS
ALLIANCE WE LIKE -- TO JUST A
LINE OR COMMENTS WITH A CLEAN
ENERGY IN THE FOR SPEAKER TODAY
THANK YOU.
GENERAL WITH OTHER CALIFORNIA
CLIMB IN AGRICULTURE NETWORK ONE
IS FOR THE EARLIER COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF THE HEALTHY SOILS
PROGRAM. TO GET TO THAT ONE
MILLION ACRES BY TWENTY THIRTY
WE WILL CERTAINLY NEED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
AND ALSO SUPPORT THE CAL RECYCLE
WASTE DIVERSION PROGRAM.
I WANT TO JUST SAY A COUPLE
WORDS ABOUT THE ALTAR IGNORE
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM THIS IS THE
OTHER JERRY METHANE PROGRAM --
ONLY ABOUT 20% OF THE STATE'S --
JERRY FARMS CAN USE A DIE JESTER --
JUST TAKES TOO MUCH MINORITY
CAPITAL FOR MOST AREAS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE DIGESTIVE
PROGRAM BUT THE ALTERMAN OR
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM.
HAS BEEN WORKING FOR A GREATER
DIVERSITY OF OF TERRY'S AND
LIVESTOCK OPERATIONS.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND FOR
THOSE REASONS WE THINK IT
IMPORTANT -- TO EXPAND FUNDING
TO MEET THE DEMANDS -- FARMER
DEMAND FOR THAT PROGRAM HAS FAR
EXCEEDED OUR CURRENT FUNDING
LEVELS.
ARE REACHING -- JERRY'S AND
LIVESTOCK OPERATIONS IN THIRTEEN
COUNTY IS COMPARED TO THE SIX
COUNTIES FOR THE DIGEST OUR
PROGRAM -- SO THAT'S WHY WE ASK --
TO HAVE A LINE ITEM FOR THE
FIRST TIME FOR THE ALTAR OF
MANURE MANAGEMENT PROGRAM A
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR ALL OF YOUR COMMENTS ON THE
ALL BE TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION
AS WE GO THROUGH WHAT IS --
BECOME AN ANNUAL RITUAL IN THE
SAYS SUBCOMMITTEE NO -- CHAIR
TING I KNOW YOU HAD A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS.
I FORGOT TO ASK ONE QUICK
QUESTION SO ON YOU YOU MENTIONED
DIFFERENT AREAS WHERE THERE ARE
WERE INCREASES WHENEVER YOU DID
MENTION WAS THE ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS INCREASE.
CAN YOU GO THROUGH WHY YOU ADDED
ALL OF MILLION DOLLARS
ADMINISTRATIVE COST INCREASE.
THE THEORY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THAT IS TO HELP IMPLEMENT THE
WILDFIRE PREVENTION LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE FOR CAUGHT FIRE OKAY
ENDED SO WHERE AND WHERE IS THAT
THAT'S GOING INTO CAL FIRE
THAT'S CORRECT OKAY.
AND THEN ALSO THERE'S A THERE'S
A B. SIX SEVENTEEN STATE
IMPLEMENTATION COST YOU.
HAD -- FOUR MILLION LAST YEAR
AND FOUR MILLION THIS YEAR WHAT
POINT CAN WE ANTICIPATE TO STOP
PAYING FOR IMPLEMENTATION COSTS.
THE STATE WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
A ROLE IN THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
AB SIX SEVENTEEN SO I'M NOT SURE
THAT I CAN.
ANSWER THAT QUESTION FULLY WE
DON'T ANTICIPATE THAT THE STATE
WILL HAVE TO DISCONTINUE THAT
SUPPORT THE PROGRAM SO THAT JUST
OF FOR ONGOING STAFFING.
TO DO THE PROGRAM THAT IS
CORRECT YEAH.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER BROWN
YOU LOOK LIKE.
YEAH SORRY I THINK I JUST WANTED
TO KIND OF CLARIFY SO THAT FOUR
MILLION IS IS FOR CARP STAFF TO
IMPLEMENT A. B..
SIX SEVENTEEN THAT'S A PORTION
OF THE POSITIONS THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN AUTHORIZED FOR IMPLEMENTING
VARIOUS ACTIVITIES SOME OF THE
POSITIONS ARE IN KIND OF A
ANOTHER CATEGORY IN THE CHART ON
VARIOUS STATE ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS WHICH ARE ARE ON HAVE BEEN
AUTHORIZED AN ON GOING BASIS
THAT FOUR MILLION IS -- ARE ARE
KIND OF A PROPOSAL TO EXTEND
SOME OF THOSE -- LIMITED TERM
POSITIONS FOR A FEW MORE YEARS.
GREAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT -- BRINGS --
ISSUE. ONE TO A CONCLUSION.
BECAUSE A LITTLE LONGER THAN WE
MIGHT HAVE EXPECTED THAT WE DO
HAVE -- ISSUE TO UNDER VARIOUS
DEPARTMENTS -- THE AS OF
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM THIS IS
INFORMATIONAL ONLY.
I SHOULD THE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THE AT THE END OF ONE ALTHOUGH
THE SPEAKERS OF WELCOME TO THE
WHOLE BUNCH OF YOU.
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
WITH -- MISTER -- ACTIVELY FROM
GO BIZ THAT THE PLANT YEAH GREAT
WELCOME COULD SEE WHAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CHAIR BLOOM AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT.
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE THAT
IT START WITH THAT QUICK LOOK IN
THE PROGRESS AND INFRASTRUCTURE --
AS YOU KNOW ARE TARGETED AT FOR
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE IS TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND CHAIR
CHARGERS.
I'M INCLUDING TEN THOUSAND DC
FAST CHARGER IS INTO ENTERED
HYDROGEN STATIONS.
SO IN YOR PACKET YOU SEE THAT
PUBLIC CHARTER NUMBERS IN THE
STAFF REPORT WE HAVE WELL OVER
NINETEEN THOUSAND CHARGE POINTS
IN THE STATE -- AND CLOSE TO
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED OR DIRECT
CURRENT FAST CHARGERS AND I WANT
TO REMIND THE COMMITTEE THAT
THAT TWENTY FIFTY THOUSAND
TARGET.
INCLUDES SHARED PRIVATE CHARTERS
AND SO WHEN YOU ADD WHAT WE KNOW
FOR SURE PRIVATE CHARTERS WERE
CLOSER TO FORTY THOUSAND
CHARGERS IN THE STATE'S IT.
IT SOUNDS AND FEELS A LOT BETTER.
I HAVE TOWARD THAT TARGET THAT
WE'RE GOING.
FOR I'M HYDROGEN WE HAVE THIRTY
THREE STATIONS THIRTY A SORRY
THIRTY NINE STATIONS NOW WITH AS
MANY AS TWELVE MORE OPENING THIS
YEAR.
AND IN THE REALM OF STATION
PROGRESS AND POINT OUT HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS.
TO ENSURE THAT THE STATION AND
SUPPORTING INFRASTRUCTURE GOING
WITH IN WITH AS LITTLE FRICTION
AS POSSIBLE.
THIS YEAR IN THE SPRING WE'RE
GONNA BE REALLY SEEN OUR
APPLICANT LECTURED VEHICLE
CHARGING STATION STREAMLINING
DEVELOPMENT GUIDE BOOK WHICH IS
QUITE A MOUTHFUL SO JUST THE
GUIDE BUCK BUT WE'RE FOCUSING IN
ON THAT REALLY FOUR KEY AREAS
PLANNING.
PERMITTING ACCESSIBILITY AND
INTERCONNECTION.
AND DISTILLING TO HIGHLIGHT WHAT
WE'RE DOING ON THE PERMITTING
SITE IS REALLY TRACKING PROGRESS
TOWARDS THAT COMPLIANCE WITH THE
TWELVE THIRTY SIX WHICH IS THAT
PASSED IN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN I'M WITHIN THE
IDEA IS A GREAT KIND OF A
TRANSPARENT SYSTEM.
OF KNOWLEDGE SHARING AND
INCLUSION SO THAT COMMUNITIES
CAN LEARN FROM ONE OF AND OTHER
AS WE WORK TOGETHER TO HELP
STREAMLINE -- PERMITTING PROCESS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WILL BE SEEN BASED ON EXPERIENCE
THANK SUCCESS AND ESPECIALLY
WITH PERMITTING COMES DOWN TO
EDUCATION AND AWARENESS AND THAT
THE CHALLENGES WE SEE ARE
SOLVABLE BUT THERE IS A LOT OF
WORK TO DO ON THE PERMANENT
FRETS WE GOT A LOT OF FOCUS
THERE.
I WILL ALSO BE UPDATED OUR
TWENTY FIFTEEN HYDROGEN
PERMITTING GUIDE BOOK AS WELL TO
REFLECT THE STATE OF THE ART.
THAT IS THAT'S ALSO JUST TO TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THEM STATE
AGENCY COORDINATION I THINK YOU
DESPITE.
EVIDENCE EVERYBODY UP HERE
THERE'S A LOT OF COORDINATION
THAT GOES ON BUT WHEN HE TALKED
ABOUT A FEW THINGS THAT HAPPEN
UNDER THAT SEVEN ACTION ACTION
PLAN THAT ARE GONNA WORTH
REFLECTING ON ONE OF THEM IS
THIS IN JANUARY TWENTY NINETEEN
THE BUILDING STANDARDS
COMMISSION ADOPTED A NEW MULTI.
FAMILY GUY BUILDING ST MOTHER
FAMILY HOUSING BUILDING
STANDARDS WHICH WILL VASTLY
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF TV
CAPABLE ANY BE READY.
CHARGING SPACES AND NEW MULTI
FAMILY THING THAT'S EXPECTED
THAT WE'VE HAD A LOT OF
CHALLENGE WITH RECENTLY.
THROUGHOUT TIME -- ANOTHER BIG
SUCCESSES IN OUR FLEET
PROCUREMENT TODAY DEPARTMENT
GENERAL SERVICES BEEN DOING.
INCIDENT REALLY GREAT PROGRAMMER
TARGET FOR TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN WAS 15% OF NEW
PURCHASES WOULD BE SABSE AND
THEY ACTUALLY EXCEEDED THAT IT
REACHED 30%.
THAT WAS ENABLE A LOT BY THE
SUPPORTING INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO LEVERAGE OPEN
AND OVER THOUSAND CHARGING
STATIONS.
AND THOSE FLEET VEHICLES ARE
ALSO UTILIZE OUR PUBLIC HYDROGEN
STATIONS.
I IN TERMS OF FINDING THEIR
STRONG COORDINATION ACROSS THE
AGENCIES IN TWO KEY EXAMPLES
HERE'S THE CAL YOU V. I. P.
PROGRAM WHICH TREE WILL TALK
ABOUT THAT'S REALLY DESIGNED TO
FILL GAPS.
IN THE C. P. U. C. IS YOU'RE
ALSO TALKING ABOUT THEIR
UNDERLINED EFFORTS TO YOU YOU
KNOW BILL THE MARKET -- SO
REALLY JUST LOOKING AHEAD I
THINK THE FOCUS IS NOW ON SCALE.
THAT FOR THE ZERO EMISSION
MARKET I THINK THERE'S IS NO
LONGER A QUESTION OF IF IT'S
JUST A QUESTION OF WHEN.
INCIDENT IN STATE LEADERSHIP
REALLY REMAINS CRUCIAL TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT WHEN IT'S AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE I THOUGHT WAS
EXCELLENT.
AND BACK UP JUST FOR A MINUTE --
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SEVEN THE
ENERGY COMMISSION HAS BEEN
MANAGING THE ALTERNATIVE.
AND RENEWABLE FUEL AND VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY PROGRAM.
AND IT'S DESIGNED HELPS A TENER
CLIMATE IN PUBLIC HEALTH GOALS.
WE ARE FOCUSED ON THIS BECAUSE
AS YOU KNOW HALF OF OUR GHGS
COME FROM TRANSPORTATION IN A
VERY SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGE OF
OUR POLLUTANTS THAT HARM
CALIFORNIANS COME FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR SO IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE GET THIS.
THAT WE GET THIS RIGHT.
THE INVESTMENTS THAT WE MAKE
ABOUT ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR ARE GUIDED BY
AN ANNUAL INVESTMENT PLAN THAT
WE PUT TOGETHER WE THAT IT WITH
STAKEHOLDERS WE DO WORKSHOPS WE
HAVE BEEN -- IT ADVISORY
COMMITTEE THAT MEETS AND WEIGHS
IN AND THEN WE ADOPT THAT --
THAT PLAN IN THE SPRING AND
RECENTLY AT LAST YEAR SB ONE
THOUSAND WAS SIGNED INTO LAW.
IN WHAT IT DIRECTS US TO DO IS
TO LOOK AT THE INVESTMENT PLAN
AND ASSESS WHETHER CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE IS BEING
DISPROPORTIONATELY DISTRIBUTED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
SO WE ARE EAGER TO TAKE A LOOK
AT THAT WERE WERE JUST NOW
SCOPING OUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO
DO THAT EXAMINATION AND IT
PARTNERS WELL WITH AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY SEVEN THAT ALL THAT I
MENTIONED BRIEFLY LATER.
WE ALREADY DO A PLAY A NUMBER OF
TOOLS TO TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS CLEAN ENERGY REVOLUTION
TOUCHES ALL CALIFORNIANS AND
DOESN'T JUST BENEFIT -- POCKETS
OF THE STATE -- PLEASE GIVE ME A
FEW NUMBERS TO DATE WE HAVE
INVESTED SUBSTANTIAL FUNDING AND
SEVEN FOR STRUCTURE AND I WANT
TO BREAK IT DOWN IN TERMS OF
HYDROGEN AND LECTER VEHICLES.
IN HYDROGEN WE'VE INVESTED A
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
THAT HAS FUNDED SIXTY FIVE
STATIONS IN THE STATE THAT ARE
PUBLICLY ACCESSIBLE THIRTY NINE
OF THEM ARE ACTUALLY UP AND
RUNNING AND ACCESSIBLE TODAY --
WE EXPECT THE BALANCE TO BE
ACCESSIBLE.
HOPEFULLY SOON MAYBE AS MANY AS
A DOZEN THIS YEAR WILL BE ADDED
TO THAT. TO THAT TOTAL.
AND WANT TO JUST POINT OUT
THERE'S BEEN SOME CONCERN ABOUT --
LIGHTING AND OTHER ISSUES AT
SOME OF THE STATIONS I'M A PROUD
TO REPORT THAT THE CLOVER FIELD
STATION WE HAVE LIGHTING -- NOW
AND THE OTHER STATIONS ARE SAID
TO HAVE LIGHTING AS WELL TO MAKE
IT MORE ACCESSIBLE FOR FOLKS WHO
WANT TO USE THEM.
TERMS OF THE V. IS -- LECTER
VEHICLES WE HAVE -- NINETY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS WE'VE INVESTED
TO DATE IN TWO EVEY
INFRASTRUCTURE WE'VE GOT ABOUT
ANOTHER NINETY MILLION THAT
WE'RE CURRENTLY.
PUTTING INTO SOLICITATIONS TO
PUT OUT ON THE STREET.
THAT -- IS TYSON POINTED OUT HAS.
CONTRIBUTED TO THE FORTY
THOUSAND CHARGERS CHARGING --
HOOK UPS THAT WE HAVE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE THAT NUMBER IS ABOUT
EQUALLY BALANCED BETWEEN --
PUBLIC PUBLIC.
CHARGERS AND THEN SHARED PRIVATE
CHARGERS SO THOSE WOULD BE AT
COMPANIES THAT WANT PROVIDE THE
FOR THE WORK FORCE OR MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING.
AND IN ADDITION -- THERE ARE
MANY THOUSANDS OF CHARGERS IN
PEOPLE'S HOMES THOSE ARE COUNTED
IN THOSE NUMBERS.
YOUR STAFF REPORT WENT THROUGH
SOME OF THE NUMBERS WE USE A
TOOL WE CALL EVEY I PRO THAT WE
PUT TOGETHER WITH THE NATIONAL
RENEWABLE ENERGY LABORATORY THAT.
HELPS US IDENTIFY HOW MANY
CHARGES WE NEED AND WHERE IN THE
STATE TO SUPPORT THE THE ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION TARGET BY.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND THE THE
ANSWER CAME OUT TO BE ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND CHARGERS
WE NEED TO SUPPORT THAT MANY.
SO.
FORTY IS A IS A NICE DOWN
PAYMENT ON THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
BUT WE'VE GOT QUITE A WAYS TO GO --
I CAN DIG INTO THESE DEEPER IS
NOT THE THESE NUMBERS A LITTLE
BIT MORE DEEPLY BUT WANTED TO
JUST -- FLAG THAT FOR THE
COMMITTEE -- AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY SEVEN ADOPTED ALSO LAST
YEAR IT DIRECTS US -- TO LOOK AT
A READ THE QUOTE IT'S WHAT
INFRASTRUCTURE DO WE NEED C<c.cyan></c>
TO SUPPORT THE LEVELS OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLE ADOPTION
REQUIRED FOR THE STATE TO MEET
ITS GOAL OF PUTTING AT LEAST
FIVE MILLION ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES ON CALIFORNIA ROADS BY.
TWENTY THIRTY SO AGAIN WE'RE
JUST SCOPING THIS PARTICULAR --
EFFORT AS WELL AND PLAN TO HAVE
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE GOING TO
SHARE PUBLICLY -- BEFORE LONG
AND GET AND GET -- INPUT ON IT
AS WE LOOK AT THESE NUMBERS HOW
MANY CHARGES DO WE NEED TO
SUPPORT A COMPLETE
TRANSFORMATION OF OUR SECTOR WE
ARE.
LOOKING AT THE VARIOUS THINGS I
DESCRIBE I JUST WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER
THINGS HAPPENING AS WE SPEAK.
TECHNOLOGIES ARE CHANGING
QUICKLY THESE NUMBERS ARE FLUID
AND THERE YOU KNOW WE WE WE LOOK
AT A MARKING TIME WE WE PROJECT
AGAINST THE FUTURE WE TRY TO
ACHIEVE THOSE TARGETS BUT THINGS
LIKE -- AND IT WILL GO THROUGH A
MALL BUT JUST AS AN EXAMPLE
MOBILE CHARGING RIGHT NOW WE
ASSOCIATE ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING WITH.
A PARTICULAR PARKING SPACE IN A
IN A LOT SOMEWHERE AND THERE'S A
YOU KNOW THERE'S A NO PARKING
SIGN UNLESS YOU'RE ANY V. AND
YOU KNOW IT WORKS FINE FOR WHAT
IT DOES BUT WE'RE LOOKING OUT
THESE MOBILE CHARGE THE CAN BE
WE'LL BETWEEN.
VEHICLES WHEREVER THEY ARE IN
THE PARKING LOTS EVEN IF THE
LOCK UP SPACES FOR A PURPOSE OR
HAVE SOMEBODY CHARGE FOR FOUR
HOURS AND THEN LEAVE THE CAR
THERE AND MEANWHILE THE NEXT
PERSON WANTS TO CHARGE CAN'T
BECAUSE THE THE THE YOU KNOW THE
CABLES ARE LONG ENOUGH.
THIS IS ONE OF MANY THINGS THAT
ARE REALLY CHANGING THE
LANDSCAPE IN OUR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY SEVEN EFFORT.
WILL LOOK AT ALL THESE THINGS AS
WELL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
X. WE HAVE UP UC.
A WELL OR IF YOU HAVE A
DIFFERENT ORDER THAT'S OKAY
THAT'S FINE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR BLOOM AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
PEACE CALL AND I MET.
THE DIRECTOR AT THAT THAT CPC'S
ENERGY DIVISION AND WITH ME IS
KERRY SISTER OR LEAD ANALYST ON
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION
ISSUES TO THEM.
THIS MORNING I'LL PROVIDE A
SUMMARY OF THE PC'S EFFORTS TO
DATE TO SUPPORT THE STATE'S OF
GOALS AND MS SISTER WILL BE
RESPONDING TO THE STAFF COMMENTS
THAT WERE PROVIDED IN THE AGENDA.
TO DATE THE CQC IS AUTHORIZE ONE
BILLION DOLLARS IN UTILITY
UTILITY CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
SPENDING THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TO SUPPORT. THIRTEEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED LIGHT DUTY
CHARGING PORTS AT WORKPLACES AND
APARTMENT BUILDINGS -- MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAMS REQUIRED TO ELECTRIFY
APPROXIMATELY FIFTEEN THOUSAND
VEHICLES -- A PUBLIC DC FAST
CHARGING PROGRAM TO PROVIDE UP
TO TWO HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR NEW
FAST CHARGING PORTS -- AS WELL
OTHER SEVERAL ADDITIONAL PILOT
PROGRAMS DESIGNED TO ADDRESS
BARRIERS TO ZAP ADOPTION
VERTICALLY ANAHEIM EMISSION
REDUCTION OPPORTUNITIES.
SUCH AS PORT ELECTRIFICATION
EQUIPMENT AND A REFRIGERATED
TRUCK IDOLING REDUCTION PROGRAM.
THE CPC ALSO OVERSEES THE
HUNDRED AND TWO MILLION DOLLAR
ENERGY SETTLEMENT.
AND SO FAR -- TO DATE TWO
HUNDRED AND TWELVE DC FAST
CHARGING STATIONS -- HAVE BEEN
INSTALLED AS WELL AS
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT SIXTY
FIVE HUNDRED LEVEL TWO CHARGING
PORTS.
ALSO A TWELVE AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS OF THAT SETTLEMENT HAS
BEEN CARVED OUT -- FOR PAUSES
THAT SUPPORT RESIDENTS IN MULTI
UNIT DWELLINGS -- THE ENERGY AND
ESTIMATES THAT THEY WILL DEVELOP --
FOURTEEN TO TWENTY OF THESE
PAUSES WITH THOSE FUNDS AND FOR
INSTALLED THE DAY.
THERE -- ACTIVELY UNDERWAY IN
GETTING A LOT MORE OF THOSE PUT
IN -- PRETTY SOON HERE -- LET'S
SEE THERE ALSO -- SEVERAL PILOTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE ENERGY
SETTLEMENT -- THREE ARE FOCUSED
ON SPECIFIC EVEY TECHNOLOGIES
TOUGH SUCH AS HIGH POWER
CHARGING.
AND MICRO GRADES THEY'RE ALSO TO
PROJECTS THAT ARE FOCUSED ON THE
SOCIAL BENEFITS OF EVEY THAN
UNDERSERVED AREAS.
SUCH AS SHARED ELECTRIC SHUTTLES
AND EVEY SHARING.
THE SET THAT SAID THAT BUDGET.
IS ANTICIPATED BE FULLY SPENT BY
JUNE OF THIS YEAR.
FINALLY THERE IS AN ADDITIONAL
PRACTICALLY BILLION DOLLARS --
IN UTILITY PROPOSALS CURRENTLY
UNDER SI PC REVIEW.
INCLUDING -- A PROGRAM TO
ELECTRIFY BETWEEN THREE THOUSAND
SIX OUT THOUSAND MEDIUM AND
HEAVY HEAVY DUTY ARE HAVE A
DENSITY VEHICLES IN S. T. G. EAT
SERVICE TERRITORY -- EXTENSION
OF EDISON'S LIGHT DUTY PROGRAM
TO PROVIDE ANOTHER APPROXIMATELY
FORTY EIGHT THOUSAND CHARGING
PORTS -- AND PILOT PROGRAMS TO
INSTALL A LIGHT DUTY
INFRASTRUCTURE AT SCHOOLS AND
STATE PARKS AND BEACHES.
FINALLY I WAS ASKED TO SPEAK TO
THAT P. JEANNIE BANKRUPTCY
IMPACT WE ARE NOT EXPECTING.
THE P. GINNY BANKRUPTCY TO
IMPACT ALREADY APPROVED PROGRAM
SINCE HE'S BUDGETS WERE INCLUDED
IN THE IMPEACHING IS BUSINESS
OPERATING COSTS AND WE'RE
AUTHORIZED BY THE BANKRUPTCY
JUDGE -- END OF THAT REMAINING
BILLION DOLLARS IN A WHICH IS --
LITTLE LESS CERTAIN ONLY FIFTEEN
OF MILLION OF THAT IS P. GINNY
FOR OUR OUR ASSOCIATE PGA
PROJECT SO -- LARGELY THE PIGEON
THE PROJECTS AROUND THE TABLE OF
ALREADY BEEN AUTHORIZED AND
APPROVED BY THE BANKRUPTCY JUDGE.
WITH THAT I WILL TURN THIS OVER
THE MIKE OVER -- TO IS SISTER
WHO CAN SPEAK TO SOME OF THE
COMMENTS ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
GOOD MORNING -- MY NAME'S KERRY
SYSTEM AN ANALYST WITH ENERGY
DIVISION AT THE SI PC -- I
WANTED TO TOUCH ON THE DIFFERENT
STAFF COMMENTS THAT WERE RAISED
IN THE AGENDA BRIEFLY -- FIRST
THE GAPS IN UNDERSERVED AREAS
THAT HAVE THE WORST AIR QUALITY
FOR EACH OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAMS THE CPC HAS AUTHORIZED
THE I A USED TO INVEST IN TO
DATE -- WE'VE INCLUDED TARGETS
FOR EACH AYE A YOU TO FOCUS
INVESTMENTS EITHER A PERCENT OF
THE BUDGET OR AND PERCENT OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE INSTALLED.
DEBIAN DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AS DEFINED BY THE CALLING BY
RISKY -- AND I'LL NOTE THAT THE
I A USE HAVE TYPICALLY EXCEEDED
THOSE TARGETS THAT THE CPC
ADOPTS FOR EXAMPLE FOR THE LIGHT
DUTY INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAMS THE
TARGETS HAVE BEEN TYPICALLY
AROUND 10% OF THE BUDGET.
AND THE MAJORITY OF THOSE
PROGRAMS HAVE CLOSER 240250% OF
THE BUDGET BEING FOCUSED ON
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
ON THIS IF YOU SEE IS ALSO
ADOPTED REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
FOR THE MORE RECENTLY ADOPTED --
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAMS SO THAT
WE CAN HELP MEASURE THE IMPACT
OF THESE INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS SPECIFICALLY ON AIR
QUALITY IMPROVEMENTS AND
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS -- IN
TERMS OF THE ADEQUACY OF THE
GRADE AND ALTERNATIVES -- THIS
IS A CRITICAL FOCUS OF THE CPC
ACROSS ALL OF OUR PROCEEDINGS
NOT JUST. ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
AND WE DEFINITELY HAVE BEEN AND
DIRECTING THE UTILITIES TO TRACK
AND MONITOR THE IMPACT OF
INCREMENTAL AB LOAD ON ON THE
GRID SINCE.
TWENTY ELEVEN AND THEY'VE BEEN
FILING AND ANNUAL REPORTS TO
TRACK ANY -- DISTRIBUTION GREAT
UPGRADES NECESSARY -- TO DATE
THEY HAVEN'T FACED ANY
SIGNIFICANT INFRASTRUCTURE
UPGRADES SPECIFICALLY TARGETED.
TO INCREMENTAL EVEY LOAD BUT WE
EXPECT THAT THEY'LL START TO SEE --
AS AS MORE EAGLES ARE ADOPTED
THAT INCREMENTAL ET LOAD WILL
ONLY GROW SO WHERE WE DIRECTED
THEM TO CONTINUE MONITORING THAT
BUT BEYOND THAT DIDN'T THERE'S
NO.
REAL OBVIOUS ACTION NEEDED AT
THIS POINT.
IN TERMS OF THE AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES AND CONGESTION THE
CBC'S WORKING DIRECTLY WITH THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD -- AS IT
DEVELOPS THE GREEN MILE STANDARD
THAT WAS ADOPTED LAST YEAR IN SB.
TEN FOURTEEN AND ALSO WITH THE
CPC TO EVALUATE THE INCREMENTAL
ET INFRASTRUCTURE -- AS WAS JUST
DISCUSSED UNDER AB -- TWENTY ONE
TWENTY SEVEN ONE THING THAT WE
WOULD NOTE IS THAT -- TO AVOID
AGE ON GOING CONGESTION ISSUES
ASSOCIATED WITH -- RIDE HAILING
FLEETS AND AUTONOMOUS LEADS --
THE CPC WOULD LIKE TO SEE.
INCENTIVES THAT ENCOURAGE.
DRIVERS OR AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES
TO AVOID TRAVELING WITH EMPTY
VEHICLES -- SO WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH ACADEMIC PARTNERS
IN THIS DEEP CC TO STUDY THE
CURRENT DRIVING AND CHARGING
PATTERNS OF DIFFERENT RILEY RIDE
HAILING.
PROGRAMS AND DRIVERS TO HELP
INFORM PRIORITY LOCATIONS FOR
ADDITIONAL ET CHARGING STATION
DEPLOYMENTS AND ALSO
INVESTIGATING WAYS THAT TO
DIRECT INSTILLATION OF
INCENTIVES OF INFRASTRUCTURE --
THAT SUPPORTS PICK UP AND DROP
OFF LOCATIONS THAT INCREASE
ACCESS TO TRANSIT HUBS AND MY
CREDIBILITY OPTIONS. FOR
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE --
SPECIFICALLY TARGETING MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY AND VEHICLES AS
PETE MENTIONED WE'VE AUTHORIZED
AS C. E. AND P. JEANNIE TO SPEND.
NEARLY FIVE HUNDRED EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS ON
INFRASTRUCTURE DISAPPEAR SUPPORT
THESE TYPES OF VEHICLES AND ARE
EVALUATING WHETHER TO AUTHORIZE
AS DID YOU NEED TO SPEND FIFTEEN
MILLION ON SIMILAR PROGRAMS --
I'D SAY HERE ONE THING WE'VE
TARGETED IN THESE INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAMS ARE TRANSIT AND SCHOOL
BUSES WE'VE OFFERED ADDITIONAL
INCENTIVE SPECIFICALLY FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE TO ELECTRIFY
THOSE MORE CRITICAL -- PRIORITY
EFFORTS BECAUSE IT INSIDE IN
PART BECAUSE THEY ALIGN WITH
OTHER STATE AGENCY FUNDING --
FOR MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY AND
SCHOOL BUS REPLACEMENT EFFORTS --
AND ALSO BECAUSE OF DIFFERENT
REGULATORY EFFORTS TO TRANSITION
THE TRANSIT SECTOR TWO ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES -- AND THEN
FINALLY THE STATE ROLE IN
ESTABLISHING STANDARDS FOR IS
THAT CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE --
OUR MAIN POINTS WE'D LIKE TO
MAKE HERE IS IF THE LEGISLATURE
INTENDS TO ADOPT FURTHER
REQUIREMENTS -- FOR PUBLIC
CHARGING EQUIPMENT IN TERMS OF
TECHNOLOGICAL OR OPEN ACCESS AT
REQUIREMENTS IT SHOULD CONSIDER
ESTABLISHING GRANDFATHERING.
PROVISIONS THAT ENSURE ALREADY
DEPLOYED CHARGING STATIONS CAN
CONTINUE TO OPERATE THROUGH
THEIR USEFUL LIFE RATHER THAN
HAVING TO BE REPLACED
PREMATURELY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN WOMEN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS THE TEACHING OF A
DEPUTY EXECUTIVE OFFICER AT THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK WITH YOU ABOUT EVEY
INFRASTRUCTURE DEPLOYMENT UNDER
THE V. W. SETTLEMENT.
SO BEFORE I GET INTO THE DETAILS
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THAT
SOMEONE I JUST KIND OF WANT TO
BACK UP I THINK IT'S USEFUL TO
JUST REMEMBER -- FROM
200-092-2017 VW SOLD ABOUT
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND DIESEL
VEHICLES IN CALIFORNIA THAT HAD
DEFEAT DEVICES THAT WERE
DESIGNED TO AVOID THE KNOX
EMISSION CONTROL.
SO AS A RESULT OF THIS AND A
CONSENT DECREE GETTING CAUGHT IN
A CONSENT DECREE.
A VW WAS REQUIRED TO DO FOUR
MAIN THINGS SO THE FIRST THING
THEY HAD TO DO WAS THEY HAD.
TO EITHER FIX THE VEHICLES ARE
GET THEM OFF THE ROAD.
THE SECOND THING IS THEY PAID A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR PENALTY.
THE THIRD THING IS THEY HAD TO
MAKE UP THE EXTRA NOT EMISSIONS
SO THEY'VE PROVIDED FOUR HUNDRED
AND TWENTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
WHICH WE ARE ADMINISTERING
CARBONS ADMINISTERING AND THIS
IS SOMETIMES KNOWN AS APPENDIX
D..
AND THEN FINALLY THE REQUIRED TO
INVEST EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN CALIFORNIA TO SUPPORT
THE INCREASED USE OF THAT IS AND
THAT'S WHAT I'M GOING TO TALK
ABOUT TODAY THAT'S CALLED
APPENDIX FEES SOMETIMES PEOPLE
WILL CALL IT.
SO VW IS IMPLEMENTING APPENDIX
THE SEE THROUGH ITS SUBSIDIARY
ELECTRIFY AMERICA WE SOMETIMES
CALL THAT EA.
AND THIS INVESTMENT IS MADE IN
FOUR CONSECUTIVE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR THIRTY MONTH ZAB
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN CYCLES.
THERE ARE FOUR AREAS THAT YOU
CAN -- INVEST IN UNDER THE
CONSENT DECREE.
SO ONE OF THEM IS THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE. ONE IS BRANDED
NEUTRAL PUBLIC AWARENESS SO
AWARENESS OF ELECTRIC VEHICLES
BUT NOT NECESSARILY ANY
PARTICULAR BRAND.
INCREASING ZAB ACCESS THROUGH
THINGS LIKE RIDE AND DRIVE
EVENTS AND THEN ALSO GREEN CITY
PILOTS WITH AN EMPHASIS ON
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION
PROJECTS LIKE.
THAT CAR SHARING AND TRANSIT --
ESPECIALLY IN LOW INCOME AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
SO THE BOARD APPROVED ELECTRIFY
AMERICA'S CYCLE ONE SEVEN BEST A
PLAN IN JULY OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
AFTER A PUBLIC WORKSHOP AND
THREE BOARD MEETINGS.
AND SO THIS PLAN PROVIDES FOR
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
A STATEWIDE NETWORK OF HIGHWAY
FAST CHARGERS. FORTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR CHARGING IN
THE SIX LARGEST METRO AREAS IN
THE STATE AREAS LIKE WORKPLACE
RETAIL MULTI FAMILY HOUSING.
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR AN
AWARENESS PLAN -- THROUGH WEB
BASED SOCIAL MEDIA REGULAR SORT
OF TV AND RADIO AND THEN ALSO
THE SELECTION OF SACRAMENTO AS
THE GREEN CITIES PILOT.
SO AS PART OF THIS PILOT
ELECTRIFY AMERICA'S PROVIDING
FORTY FIVE FORTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE SACRAMENTO AREA.
FOR TWO NEW CAR SHARING SERVICES
ZERO EMISSION SHUTTLE AND
TRANSIT BUSES AND THE ASSOCIATED
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE AND
MARKETING -- ELECTRIFY AMERICA
HAS BEEN BUSY IMPLEMENTING THEIR
CYCLE ONE PLAN TO DATE THEY HAVE
LICENSE OR AT LEAST A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY SEVEN STATION SITES.
SEVENTY TWO OF THESE ARE IN THE
PERMITTING PROCESS THIRTY FIVE
HAVE BEEN PERMITTED. NINE OF THE
SITE WORK IS COMPLETE BUT
THEY'RE NOT YET OPEN AND FIVE OF
THEM HAVE BEEN COMMISSIONED AND
ARE OPEN.
ON EA IS COORDINATING WITH THE
I. O. U.'S DIRECTLY AND CARP
HELPS COORDINATE BETWEEN CDC AND
ELECTRIFY AMERICA TO HELP
IDENTIFY POTENTIAL OVERLAPS IN
WERE STATIONS ARE BEING CITED --
WITH RESPECT TO THE SACRAMENTO
GREEN CITIES PILOT ELECTRIFY
AMERICA HAS PLACED A HUNDRED OF
A PLAN TO TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
CARSHARE CHEVY BOTH T. V.'S.
I'M AS PART OF THE SECOND CAR
SHARE THEIR PUTTING.
ELECTRIC VEHICLES AT APARTMENT
BUILDINGS THEY'RE DESIGNED FOR
SORT OF ROUND TRIPS AND THEY'VE
GOT ABOUT HALF OF THE SEVENTY
ONE APARTMENT BUILDINGS --
IDENTIFIED AND SIGNED UP FOR
THAT PROGRAM AND THEY'VE ALSO
BEGUN INSTALLING DEDICATED LEVEL
TWO CHARGING.
I'M AS THAT MR ECKERSLEY OF
POINTED OUT THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
PERMITTING HURDLES AS THEY'VE
GONE THROUGH THIS PROCESS
THEY'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY
WITH GOBIZ WHICH IS REALLY
HELPED A LOT.
AND WE THINK THAT THE GUIDE BOOK
WILL ALSO HELP AND SMOOTH THIS
PROCESS AS WE GO FORWARD -- I
WANT TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE CYCLE TO PLAN AND THIS PLAN
WILL BEGIN ON JULY FIRST OF
TWENTY NINETEEN AND IT WAS
APPROVED BY OUR BOARD.
AND DECEMBER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
AFTER A PUBLIC MEETING AND TWO
BOARD MEETINGS.
SO THIS PROVIDES -- TWENTY FIVE
TO THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS MORE
FOR THE HIGH SPEED I CHARGING
NETWORK ON THE HIGHWAY. NINETY
FIVE TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
MILLION FOR COMMUNITY CHARGING
IN THE NINE LARGEST METROPOLITAN
AREAS IN THE STATE. TEN TO
FOURTEEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
RESIDENTIAL AND RURAL LEVEL TWO
CHARGING. SIX TO TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR TRANSIT BUS CHARGING
AN AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE CHARGING --
FOR ZAP TRANSPORTATION NETWORK
COMPANIES AND THEN TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO BOOST STATION
UTILIZATION AND THAT AWARENESS.
WE'VE BEEN MEETING MONTHLY WITH
ELECTRIFY AMERICA AND WE RECEIVE
QUARTERLY WRITTEN REPORTS WE
EVALUATE EACH OF THESE REPORTS
FOR ADHERENTS TO THE 35%
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
INVESTMENT GOAL.
ON THEIR SECOND ANNUAL REPORT IS
DUE TO US AT THE END OF APRIL
AND WE WILL BE USING THAT TO
PREPARE.
OUR FIRST ANNUAL SB NINETY TO
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE THAT
WOULD DELIVER LATER THIS YEAR.
I ALSO WANT TO MENTION --
EARLIER I SAID B. W. WAS
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE FOUR HUNDRED
AND TWENTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
TO FULLY MITIGATE THEIR KNOCKS
EMISSIONS.
UNDER THE SETTLEMENT MOST OF
THAT MONEY IS GOING TO VEHICLE
REPLACEMENT.
BUT THAT PLAN ALSO INCLUDES TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR LIGHT DUTY
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT IS MANAGING
THAT PIECE OF IT FOR THE WHOLE
STATE.
WE'RE WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
BAY AREA DISTRICT AND THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION SO
THAT THAT COMPONENT IS
IMPLEMENTED IN A WAY THAT'S
COORDINATED WITH OTHER STATE
INVESTMENTS.
AND THEN FINALLY WE WERE ASKED
TO ADDRESS THE RECENT FIAT
CHRYSLER SETTLEMENT FOR
ADMISSION STANDARDS VIOLATIONS --
SO THE SCA SETTLEMENT IS
STRUCTURED DIFFERENTLY FROM THE
VOLKSWAGEN SETTLEMENT.
I'M CALIFORNIA'S GOING TO
RECEIVE SEVENTY EIGHT POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS. FORTY FIVE
POINT EIGHT OF THIS IS AND
PENALTIES AT A LITTLE OVER
NINETEEN MILLION IS FOR
ADMISSIONS MEDICATION.
THESE PAYMENTS UNDER STATE LAW
ARE DEPOSITED INTO THE AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL FUNDS AND THEN
THEY'LL BE MANAGED THROUGH THE
NORMAL YOU KNOW BUDGET PROCESS
THAT WE GO THROUGH.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
BE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
I THINK CUT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- LA -- MAY HAVE SOME
COMMENTS.
AMANDA MARTIN DEPARTMENT FINANCE
I'LL BE VERY BRIEF -- THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IN THE BUDGET
BILL PROPOSED AT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET MAINTAINS FUNDING LEVELS
AND JUST READ LAST YEAR AS YOU
HEARD FROM ISSUE ONE INCLUDES
THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION.
OF CAP AND TRADE FUNDS FOR THEIR
RESOURCES FOR ITS CLEAN VEHICLE
REBATE PROJECT.
OF THE BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES A
HUNDRED EIGHT MILLION FOR THEIR
TO COMMISSIONS ALTERNATIVE AND
RENEWABLE FUEL AND VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY PROGRAM WHICH
INCLUDES THE NINETY FIVE MILLION
AVAILABLE FOR GRANT FUNDING --
THERE WAS NO SPECIFIC BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL ON THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE INCLUDED THIS
YEAR AS WE'RE NOT REQUESTING A
CHANGE IN THE LEVEL OF THE
FUNDING APPROPRIATED -- HOWEVER
AS DESCRIBED IN THE AGENDA AND
DISCUSSED HERE TODAY -- THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES --
VARIOUS PROPOSALS FOR THE ENERGY
COMMISSION PUBLIC TO LIST
MISSION AN AIRPORT.
I'M TO IMPLEMENT. ZERO MISSION
VEHICLE RELAY LEGISLATION
INCLUDING AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY
SEVEN SB ONE THOUSAND SB.
TEN FOURTEEN BETWEEN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND THE
RECENTLY RELEASED SPRING FINANCE
LETTER.
A TOTAL OF EIGHT HUNDRED THIRTY
NINE THOUSAND SIX POSITION THE
REQUESTED TO IMPLEMENT THE
RECENT THAT LEGISLATION WHICH AS
YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD WILL HELP
INFORM OUR FUTURE AND PAST.
THANK YOU.
DROUGHT.
YEAH THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
YOUR AGENDA DOESN'T I'D PROBABLY
NOT A LOT OF THE KEY QUESTIONS
AND ISSUES AND AN ADMINISTRATION
IS ALREADY TOUCHED ON A LOT OF
THEM SO I'M GONNA KEEP MY
COMMENTS BRIEF JUST WANTED TO
EMPHASIZE A COUPLE KEY QUESTIONS
THAT WE THINK.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO CONTROL THE
JEWEL AND ON AN ASTON
MINISTRATION ONE IS RELATED TO
THE ISSUE THAT HAS BEEN
DISCUSSED AROUND IS CHANGES IN
TECHNOLOGY BOTH AND NO -- NO
THOMAS VEHICLES AS WELL AS
CHARGING TECHNOLOGIES AND
BASICALLY HOW THE ADMINISTRATION
IS PLANNING ON KIND OF YOU KNOW
HAVING THE FLEXIBILITY TO ADJUST
TO THOSE CHANGES INCOME NOT
KNOWING EXACTLY HOW THOSE
TECHNOLOGIES WILL EVOLVE AND SO.
WHAT THE PLAN IS FOR KIND OF
ADJUSTING OF AS THOSE THINGS
CHANGE OVER TIME THE SECOND
ISSUE RELATED TO HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES WHICH WAS ALSO TOUCHED
ON?
A LOT OF THE FUNDING FOR HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE IS
COMING FROM THE I'LL USE SO I
THINK SOME THERE'S ARE SOME KEY
QUESTIONS AROUND HERE WHERE
WHERE THEY GAPS ON KIND OF YOU
KNOW HEAVY DUTY INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT ISN'T FUNDED.
A AND I OWE YOU TERRITORIES AND
HOW THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PLANNING ON ADDRESSING THOSE
GAPS AS WELL AS COORDINATION
WITH BETWEEN AGENCIES -- CAR
PROVIDES A LOT OF THE INCENTIVES
FOR THE HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES AND
SO HOW THE ADMINISTRATION IS
THINKING ABOUT IN A WHINING KIND
OF THE HEAVY DUTY INFRASTRUCTURE
IN THE VEHICLES GIVEN THAT --
THE FUNDS ARE COMING FROM
DIFFERENT SOURCES SO ON MY
COMMENTS THERE THANK YOU
QUESTIONS AND IF YOU HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT.
TO NOW'S A GOOD TIME TO STEP
FORWARD.
MS GARCIA FOLLOWED BY CHAIR TANK.
AT THANK YOU I DEFINITELY WANT
TO SEE ALL THESE PROGRAMS BE
SUCCESSFUL -- BECAUSE THAT'LL
HELP THEIR QUALITY IN MY
DISTRICT IN AND AROUND THE STATE.
AND WHETHER IT'S THE PAST THE
PASSENGER CARS FOR THE HEAVY
DUTY TRUCKS YOU KNOW THAT MAKE
SURE SELL IMPORT AND I THOUGHT.
QUESTIONS THOUGH AS WE ARE
LEADING THE IDEA USE OR ASKING
THEM TO INVEST.
HOW IS THIS BANKRUPTCY WITH PGA
ANY GONNA AFFECT THEY'LL
SEPARATE SPECIALLY AS WE WORRY
ABOUT OUR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND ARE WE?
AT THE AGENCY LEVEL HAVING
DISCUSSIONS OF HOW.
TO WORK AROUND OR WORK WITH THAT
ISSUE THAT'S OUT THERE PENDING
AND THOSE THOSE EFFORTS POSSIBLY
BEING.
AFFECTED AND 40% OF THE STATE.
SO YEAH AS I NOTED ON MY
PRESENTATION -- ALMOST ALL OF P.
GENIES -- INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING
THAT'S ALREADY BEEN REQUESTED
HAS BEEN APPROVED BY THE
COMMISSION AND THE BANKRUPTCY
JUDGE SO THERE ABOUT FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL.
OBJECTS THAT FOR WHICH THAT
FUNDING IS AN UNCERTAIN BUT IT
IT'S IT'S VERY SPEAKING OF IT
MOST OF THAT FUNDING IS ALREADY
APPROVED.
AND HAS BEEN APPROVED BY THE
BANKRUPTCY JUDGE.
AND I HEARD A SAID FIFTEEN
BILLION BILLION FIFTEEN MILLION
OF THE OF THE NEXT.
ABSOLUTELY I KNOW FIFTEEN
MILLION.
OF THE OF THE ONE BILLION TOTAL
THIS ON THE TABLE SO BASICALLY
P. GENIES -- PORTION OF THE
TOTAL ALL IN ALL I KNOW YOU
FUNDS WERE KIND OF FRONT LOADED
IN THE FIRST APPROVAL SO MOST OF
WHAT'S ON THAT STILL ON THE
TABLE AND THAT SECOND BILLION.
ARE -- SAN DIEGO AND ADDISON
PROJECTS ACTUALLY IN AND THE
OTHER THE SMALL AREAS AS WELL.
AND THEN I JUST HAVE ONE MORE
QUESTION AND A SHORT COMMENT ON
YOUR A APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE OF
IDENTIFIED SEVENTY ONE APARTMENT
BUILDINGS. TO PROVIDE THE CERRO --
THE SEVEN RIGHT SHARE.
HOW DID YOU GUYS GO ABOUT
SELECTING THESE? SEVENTY ONE
APARTMENTS ARE HOW ARE THESE
BETTER ON THE STATE SO -- THIS
IS IT SAID THESE ARE FOR THAT
SACRAMENTO GREEN CITY PILOT
PROGRAM CITIES ARE IN SACRAMENTO --
AND ALL OF A ELECTRIFY AMERICA'S
THE ONE WHO'S OPERATING THAT
PROGRAM SO I WOULD AND I DON'T
KNOW IFYOU HAVE MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW.
SO ACT ELECTRIFY AMERICA WORKING
WITH APARTMENT BUILDINGS TO
IDENTIFY SO THEY ARE THE ONES
THAT ARE OPERATING THAT RIGHT --
AND THEN MY LOVE COME IN WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT HOW DO W GET.
TO DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES HAD
WE MAKE SURE INDIVIDUALS AND
APARTMENTS HAVE ACCESS AND SO I
APPRECIATE THAT WE ARE.
MAKING EFFORTS -- OUT THERE IN
TRYING TO LEARN AND GROW.
IN THAT SPACE I I DO WORRY
THOUGH ABOUT THESE COMMUNITIES.
I I LIVE IN ONE OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE NOT JUST PUTTING IN
AN INFRASTRUCTURE ABOUT THAT
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE ABLE TO
ACCESS THESE CARS.
INTO WHETHER IT'S THROUGH THE
USED CAR MARKET OR THROUGH OTHER
INCENTIVES -- I I KNOW WE HAVE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS OUT THERE AND
I'VE WORKED WITH THEIR DISTRICTS
TRY TO MAKE SURE MY COMMUNITY AS
A WAR THEM AND TRIES TO
PARTICIPATE IN THEM.
AND WHILE THE INCENTIVES ARE
PRETTY LARGE -- NINETY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS UP -- TO AND IT
STILL HAS BEEN CANCELED OUT FOR
A LOT OF PEOPLE IN MY COMMUNITY
IN AND WHAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
AFFORD.
SO JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE US AS
WE'RE DOING THIS WORK AND WE'RE
TRACKING WE'RE TRACKING AND WORK
ADJUSTING ALONG THE WAY.
ABSOLUTELY SO UNDER THAT
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT IN THE
PREVIOUS ISSUE THERE ARE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE FOCUSED ON
KIND OF THE EQUITY COMPONENT IN
TRYING TO PROVIDE MORE ACCESS
AND WE ARE LOOKING FOR WAYS. FOR
EXAMPLE THROUGH THE LOW CARBON
FUEL STANDARD TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDS AS WELL
ON TO THESE KINDS OF PROGRAMS.
IN AND I SAY IT JOKINGLY BUT
IT'S REALLY NOT A JOKE I FEEL
SOMETHING'S GOT TO BE LIKE OPRAH
WINFREY AND SAY LIKE YOU GET A
HEART YOU GET A HOT.
SO WHEN I TALK TO THE CAR
DEALERS IN MY DISTRICT THAT TELL
ME WELL FOLKS IN YOUR COMMUNITY
ARE COMING IN AND IT MIGHT BE
CASH BECAUSE THEY HAVE A LOT OF
INSTABILITY OR THEIR EMIGRANTS
AND EVEN MORE SO NOW WITH THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
SO THEY WANT TO SPEND BETWEEN
THREE TO FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
THAT I WANT TO HAVE.
BEEN SECURITY OF A PAYMENT IF
THERE'S A FAMILY EMERGENCY AND
SO A TEN THOUSAND DOLLAR.
PROGRAM IS A LOT OF MONEY BUT IT
STILL DOESN'T GET THEM TO THE
POINT WHERE THEY PENCILS AND FOR
THEM TO BUY THESE CARS WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH USE CARS ON THE
MARKET OUT THERE AS WELL.
PART OF IT IS THAT COMPANIES ARE
TAKING THE BACK SO WE CAN LEARN
FROM THEM AND AND THAT'S FAIR --
IN IN THAT BERRIER BUT WHEN I'M
TALKING TO MY DAUGHTERS ARE LIKE
THEY CAN'T I'M SORRY I TALK TOO
MUCH UNTIL BLUE IN THE FACE
ABOUT THESE.
THESE PROGRAMS BUT THEY'RE NOT
WILLING TO TO DO IT OR NOT ONLY
TO DO AT LEAST -- BECAUSE THAT
STILL VERY AFFORDABLE SO IT'S
TRYING TO MEET THEM WHERE THEY
ARE AT ON AND SO IT'S I ALMOST
TO THE POINT OF HOW DO I MAKE A
CAR BE BETWEEN THREE TO FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS WHICH MAKES ME
LIKE OPRAH WINFREY SAID ONLY BUT
I DO THINK WE NEED. TO START
THINKING AND AND THOSE
DIRECTIONS AS TO TALK ABOUT
EQUITY.
THANK THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
IN JUST A FAULT WITH MY FROM MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BELL'S COMMENTS I
I THINK -- WE'RE NOW AT A POINT
WHERE THERE IS A USED CAR MARKET
THERE ARE SOME USED CARS THAT
ARE CHEAP -- IN THAT PRICE RANGE
BUT THEY HAVE LIMITED RANGE
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY A PAIR AYE THE
CONCERN SO -- WE DEFINITELY NEED
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET THE
USED CARS BACK INTO COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE ARE DIFFERENT COMMUNITY
THAT'S ALL THEY BY IS USED CARS
THAT'S THEY'RE NOT INTERESTED IN
NEW CARS THEY DON'T THEY DON'T
FIND A VERY -- COST EFFECTIVE.
IN IN THAT IN THAT WAY -- AND SO
I THINK THAT THE LINKING GOT UP
ALSO -- DEAF TELLING WITH HER
COMMENTS -- YOU KNOW WHAT IS THE
MULTI FAMILY STRATEGY OR WHAT IS
THIS WHAT IS THE STRATEGY IN THE
COMMUNITY.
THAT HAS A SIGNIFICANT OF NUMBER
OF MULTI FAMILY -- TENANTS
BECAUSE YOU KNOW IN MY CITY WERE
YOU THINK THERE BE A HUGE AMOUNT
OF ADOPTION WE ARE SORT OF
TAPPED OUT BECAUSE 65% OF OUR
COMMUNITY ARE TENANTS.
IN SO -- THERE THAT'S YOU KNOW
WHAT WHAT THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLES ON OUR STREETS
WE WOULD ACTUALLY DO MORE IF
THERE WAS A MORE.
ROBUST INFRASTRUCTURE AND IN
FACT IT'S IT'S IT'S IT'S
FASCINATING THE FEW FAST
CHARGERS THAT ARE IN.
SAN FRANCISCO -- ALL EVERYBODY'S
COMPETING WITH ALL THE LIFT AND
UBER DRIVERS. TO TO GET TO THEM
SO IT'S YEAH PROBABLY I THINK
EVEN IN ALL OF SAN FRANCISCO
PROBABLY. TEN OR TWENTY FAST
CHARGERS WHICH SEEMS KIND OF
SHOCKING FOR OUR POPULATION FOR
WHO WE HAVE THAT ON YOU KNOW IF
YOU COULD SORT OF ADDRESS THAT
THE THAT THE THE OTHER PIECE I'D
LIKE TO HEAR AS GIVEN EVERYTHING
YOU KNOW VW -- THE I'LL USE YOU
MENTIONED ENERGY SETTLEMENT -- I
BELIEVE -- FARRAH PUT TOGETHER
IN IN THE REPORT SORT OF A LOW
ESTIMATE NEED A HIGHEST MAY NEED
GIVEN EVERYTHING THAT IS IS.
IS HAPPENING ARE WE ARE WE GOING
TO HIT THE LOWER SUBMITTED NEED
ARE HITTING THE HIGHEST ME ARE
WE STILL SHORT WHAT IS.
WHAT'S WHAT IS OUR AND TO
ANTICIPATED.
PRODUCTION GIVEN ALL THE WORK
THAT WE CURRENTLY KNOW ABOUT
RIGHT NOW.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAYBE I'LL TAKE
YOUR YOUR SECOND QUESTION AND
LET -- COLLEAGUE SPEAK TO THE
MULTI FAMILY ISSUE WERE WORKING
ON THAT AS WELL BUT AS FAR AS
THE NUMBERS THAT WERE IN THE
REPORT -- MY I THINK YOU'RE
REFERRING TO PAGE TWENTY FIVE
AND THESE ARE NUMBERS WE
PREPARED AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE
LOW ESTIMATE OF NEED.
WE HAVE ABOUT A HUNDRED THOUSAND
NINETY SEVEN THOUSAND CHARGERS
SHY OF THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND GOAL.
WE THE ENERGY COMMISSION REVISED
THESE NUMBERS DOWNWARD SO NOW
THAT ESTIMATE IS MORE LIKE.
SEVENTY THOUSAND AND THAT WAS
DUE TO TWO FACTORS THE FIRST IS
WE'VE INCLUDED PRIVATE SHARED
CHARGER SO MULTI FAMILY THAT
EXIST AND PARKING LOTS OF
BUSINESSES THAT WANT TO SUPPLY
CHARGES FOR THEIR FOR THEIR THE
EMPLOYEES ARE YOU KNOW WHOLE
FOODS NEAR WHERE I LIVE HAS A
COUPLE CHARGED.
YESTERDAY SO WE ADD THOSE IN
THOSE THOSE OTHER CHARGERS THAT
BRINGS THAT NUMBER DOWN STILL A
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT GAP AND WE'RE
ONLY TALKING ABOUT. TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE SO -- I WANT TO JUST
POINT OUT HOWEVER THOUGH THAT
THESE THESE LOOK AT ALL THE
OTHER FUNDERS YOU IDENTIFIED
THAT ARE THAT ARE PUTTING IN
CHARGERS AROUND THE STATE.
BUT THE NUMBERS I WOULD SAY
THESE THESE -- SHORTFALLS WERE
LOOKING AT PRETTY CONSERVATIVE
BECAUSE THE NUMBERS WE SUPPLY
THE COMMITTEE AND THE ONES I
JUST SHARED WITH YOU.
ARE BASED ON FUNDING THROUGH
TWENTY TWENTY AND AS WE HEARD
FROM THE P. YOU SEE THEY'RE
ENTERTAINING ADDITIONAL FUNDING
REQUEST THAT WILL GO BEYOND THAT
SO WE EXPECT THOSE THAT
SHORTFALL THE SNAPSHOT IN TIME
IS LIKELY TO GO DOWN.
THANK YOU FOR TO SORT OF
CLARIFYING THAT THE SLIDE AYE
NOW I'M KIND OF UNDERSTANDING
WHAT IT IS.
SO SO YOU'RE SAYING THE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY TWO THOUSAND BETWEEN
NOW.
AND TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THE SORT
OF EVERYTHING THAT WE NO OF AS
OF THIS THE SECOND ARE WHENEVER
YOU DO THAT NOW TO SUCH PUBLIC.
PRIVATE EVERY EVERYTHING I
SHOULD BE CLEAR -- NO THAT'S
EVERYTHING WE KNOW ABOUT THE
ENERGY COMMISSION IS FUNDING
WHAT WE KNOW OF THE OTHERS THAT
YOU IDENTIFY MUCH FOR AMERICAN
ENERGY SETTLEMENT AB IF YOU GO
IT CETERA -- IN IT INCLUDES WHAT
WE KNOW AS AN ESTIMATE TODAY OF
THE PRIVATE CHARTERS THAT ARE
INSTALLED.
IT DOESN'T INCLUDE THE GOING
FORWARD ESTIMATE OF WHAT
ADDITIONAL PRIVATE SHARE
CHARGERS WILL GO IN I I SEE SO.
SO I I I I INSTALLED A PRIVATE
CHARGER IN MY GARAGE IS THAT A
LEVEL TUNE IN KNOWN PRIVATE
LOCATION THAT'S NOT EVEN KNOW
JUST -- SO SOME PEOPLE ONLY CARE
PRIVATE SO.
IN BY THAT OBVIOUSLY YOU CAN
SHARE YOUR CHARGER BUT WE'RE
GOING TO WE'RE GOING -- TO WHERE
THERE'S ACCESS TO MULTIPLE
PEOPLE ON A DAILY BASIS AND SO
THERE ARE THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS MORE LIKE YOU THAT
HAVE THEM IN THEIR HOMES THOSE
ARE ALSO NOT INCLUDED IN THE
COUNTS GOT IT OKAY.
SO -- YEAH I THINK WHAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL IS TRYING TO UNDERSTAND.
WHAT?
SOME OF YOUR THOUGHTS ARE ABOUT
HOW.
TO HOW TO HOW TO BRIDGE THAT GAP
IS IT.
IS IT ALL PUBLIC FUNDING IS
THERE A WAY TO DO IT WHERE IT'S
PUBLIC PRIVATE HOW HOW DO WE
KNOW HOW TO HOW DO WE BRIDGE
THAT GAP BECAUSE I THINK THAT.
THE GAP -- PLAYS A HUGE ROLE IN
PEOPLE NOT ADOPTING BECAUSE ONCE
THEY GET THEIR STAR SO STRESSED
HERE NOT NO STRESS ABOUT WOULD
LIKE TO GET GAS RIGHT THEY CAN
GET GAS EVERYWHERE THERE'S A
CONFIDENCE.
BUT IF YOU'RE A COMMUNITY.
YOU MAY NOT HAVE A GARAGE IF YOU
DON'T HAVE YOUR OWN GARAGE READY
OR GIVE A CARPORT OR YOU YOU
LIVE IN A APARTMENT COMPLEX.
YOU CAN INSTALL A CHARGE OR OR
FOR US A LOT OF PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THEY BUILD THE
GARAGES OUT SO THEY THEY CHARGE
THEIR CARS ON THE NOT ON THIS
SORT OF IN THEIR DRIVEWAY.
SO -- GET GIVEN THOSE TYPES OF
SITUATIONS WHAT WILL IT TAKE TO
SORT OF BUILD OUT THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE TO REALLY TALK
THIS IS TRUE THIS IS A GREAT
QUESTION WE THINK THIS IS A GOOD
NEWS BAD NEWS SITUATION THE GOOD
NEWS IS WE HAVE OVER HALF A
MILLION.
CELEBS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I THINK IF YOU WOULD
PREFER THAT TEN OR TWENTY YEARS
AGO PEOPLE WOULD HAVE PROBABLY
CHUCKLE.
THE BAD NEWS IS WE HAVE FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND THE US IN
CALIFORNIA -- AND WE'RE TRYING
TO CATCH UP WITH THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SO WE SEE IT
AS A AS A SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE
TO TO MEET THESE GOALS SO.
AS YOU KNOW AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY
SEVEN DIRECTS US TO LOOK INTO
THIS IN PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES AT THE AIRPORT IN THE
PC.
AND WE STARTED THAT ANALYSIS
ALREADY IN TO WE'RE GONNA BE
REALLY DIVING INTO THOSE
QUESTIONS WELL IN AND AND
HOPEFULLY YOUR GAP ANALYSIS IS
NOT LOOKING AT THE FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND BETWEEN LOOK AT
THE FIVE MILLION BUT IT IS.
RIGHT SO IT IS SO WE TOOK IT WE
WE WE'VE BEEN PLANNING AGAIN
SORT OF THE SNAPSHOT IN TIME OF
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND ONE POINT.
FIVE MILLION -- BUT YES WE WE
APPRECIATE THAT THE BILL AS IT
SHOULD BE THE LAW AS WELL AS
COMMON SENSE SUGGESTS THAT'S
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND IF THINGS
CONTINUE TO MOVE THOSE NUMBERS
WILL GROW IN THE INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS TO SUPPORT LARGER NUMBERS.
IN IN TERMS OF THE SORT OF WHERE
THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS GOING
BETWEEN THE THREE I USE BETWEEN
PW BETWEEN AND RG.
IS IT BECAUSE IT THEIR BORDERS
AND ENERGY COMMISSION WHO'S.
WHO WHO'S SORT OF?
MAN I'M ALMOST LIKE BEING THE
STATE PLAN ARE RIGHT BECAUSE YOU
WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE LIKE YOU
KNOW FIVE FAST CHARGERS IN ONE
PLACE AND NO FAST CHARGES IN
THIS PLACE.
I KNOW ALL UP UNTIL RECENTLY
THERE NO FAST CHARGERS ALONG I
FIVE WHICH IS WHY NO ONE NO NO
AND YOU KNOW MANY PEOPLE DON'T
DRIVE THEIR EVEY OR THERE WASN'T
THAT I THINK IS ONLY A TEST LE
FAST CHARGER.
BUT PEOPLE DON'T DRIVE THREE
BEES BETWEEN SAN FRANCISCO AND
LA BECAUSE YOU CAN'T YOU KNOW
EVEN EVEN IF YOU TRY GAS CARGO
FILTER GAS BETWEEN SERVICES
CANNELLA SO THINK.
WHO SO WHO'S MANAGING THAT
OVERALL MAP I GUESS TO TYSON
MAYBE HIS BEST AWAY IN FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON THIS
CONVERSATION BUT I IN SHORT
WE'VE BEEN WE'VE BEEN?
WORKING ON THAT.
I WOULD LIKE TO I I'D LIKE TO
POINT OUT THAT WERE OFFICIALLY
IN OVERTIME NOW -- AND SO IF YOU
COULD KEEP YOUR RESPONSE BRIEF
AND WE'VE GOT TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WAITING TO SPEAK I DON'T
MEAN THAT.
STEP ON YOUR ON YOUR QUESTION.
I HAVE TO I HAVE A TWELVE
O'CLOCK AS WELL.
I WOULD JUST SAY IT'S A GROUP
GROUP SUPPORT HERE RIGHT IN
TERMS OF THE STATE OF THE ART
COMES OUT TO THE ENERGY
COMMISSION WHEN THEY DO THE
REPORT IT TO SAY THE RP IN
COORDINATION WITH ALL THE OTHER
AGENCIES.
YOU SEE THERE WORKING ON THE
TRANSPORTATION LIKE CHICKEN
CATION FRAMEWORK THERE IN
COORDINATION WITH THE AGENCIES
BUT THERE BE TO SELECT PRIMERICA.
THAT WE IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
AND GO BIDS ARE HELPING MAKE
SURE THAT ALL THOSE PIECES ARE
COMING TOGETHER.
SO THERE'S THERE'S A LOT OF
COOKS IN THE KITCHEN I THINK
WE'RE PRETTY WELL COORDINATED
CAE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT LET'S HEAR
FROM THE PUBLIC AND IF YOU KEEP
YOUR COMMENTS BRIEF AND
DEFINITELY UNDER THIRTY SECONDS
I'D APPRECIATED AND MS BRASS.
HAD A QUESTION SORRY.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT ME THAT WAY?
I I KNOW I KNOW I BETTER
RECOGNIZE YOU.
SORRY ABOUT THAT MS RIGHT.
YOU HEARD ME TALKING ABOUT THE
THE MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY WE
KNOW THAT.
THE CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE IS
REALLY IMPORTANT -- ESPECIALLY
IN THE THE FREE CORRIDORS FOR
THE MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES.
IT'S A BARRIERTO IT IF WE DON'T
TAKE CARE OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GET THE
VEHICLES THERE.
SO FREE WE WANT THE VEHICLE
DEPLOYMENT WE'VE GOT TO HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WHAT'S THE OVER ARCHING
INVESTMENT STRATEGY FOR THOSE
CHARGING FOR THE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY -- VEHICLES.
YOU WANT.
TO AT THE THAT'S A DIFFICULT
QUESTION TO ANSWER SO RIGHT NOW
I THINK THE MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY MARKET IS REALLY EMERGING
WE HAVE A BUNCH OF DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS LIKE THAT ZERO NEAR.
ZERO FREIGHT IN ENERGY
FACILITIES PROGRAM A. R. B. AS A
GOOD EXAMPLE OF A BUNCH OF
DIFFERENT PROJECTS GOING.
THE IN ABOUT THAT HYDROGEN AND
CHARGING AND THEN YOU HAVE THE
UTILITIES INVESTING HEAVILY ON
THE CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE. FOR
IT YOU KNOW FOR BATTERY ELECTRIC
VEHICLE DRIVE TRAIN SAID THIS
ONE I THINK WORDS THAT MEAN
HEAVY DUTIES IS.
EMERGING RIGHT NOW SOARED AB.
IN COORDINATION WORKING TOGETHER
TO HELP SEE THOSE RIGHT NOW VOTE
CATEGORIZE IT MOSTLY AT THE
PILOT PHASE.
AND THEN SCALE IS VERY CLOSE
BEHIND.
SO THE PIECE IS AUTHORIZED TO AT
TWENTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS TO
INSTALL DC FAST CHARGING
STATIONS ALONG TRANSIT QUARTERS.
AND FIVE HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO INSTALL
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE ACT FAKE
ELECTRIFICATION OVERALL.
THAT'S PC YEAH FOR THE I USE.
THE QUESTION THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING ASKED ABOUT WHO'S.
WHO'S THE PLANNER FOR THIS.
IT ALMOST BEGS THE QUESTION
SHOULDN'T THERE BE -- A PLANNER
FOR THIS INFRASTRUCTURE AND IF
SO.
WHAT WOULD BE THE RECOMMENDATION
AS TO WHICH DEPARTMENT SHOULD BE
THE DEPARTMENT?
THAT OVERSEAS AT ALL.
WELL I THINK IN A LOT OF WAYS
THEY GO BAD AS HAS BEEN
APPOINTED.
TO BE THE COORDINATOR OF ALL
THESE THINGS SO I THINK THAT --
AS FAR AS MASTER PLAN THAT'S IT
THAT'S MAYBE TOO FAR A STEP TOO
FAR IT'S MORE OF A MASTER
COORDINATOR IS MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE ALL MAKING DECISIONS IN
TANDEM.
GOING FORWARD TO REGULAR
MEETINGS TO HELP FACILITY THAT
AFFECTS.
BOTH AT THE TOP AGENCY LEVEL AND
THEN AT THE AT THE STAFF LEVEL
AS WELL.
LAST COMMENT.
THIS IS FROM A VERY WISE YOUNG
MAN -- WHO SAID TO ME WE ARE
JUST TO POINT INFRASTRUCTURE
WE'RE CREATING NEW LOCAL
ECONOMIES -- MATTHEW HAMLET A
YOUNG MAN WHO VERY WISE BEYOND
HIS AGE.
THAT'S ABSOLUTELY IMPORTANT AND
SO WE'RE BILL BUILDING THE
SUPERSTRUCTURE.
WE NEEDED IN OUR COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE WE ARE IN THE FRENCH
QUARTER.
WE WANT THOSE DIESEL TRUCKS TO
SWITCH OVER THEY'RE NOT GONNA DO
IT UNLESS THEY KNOW THEY CAN
MAKE THEIR DELIVERIES.
SO I AM LOOKING ORWARD TO
FINDING OUT WHO THE MASTER
PLANNER IS.
COORDINATING I THINK IS.
JUST NOT THE SAME THING I THINK
HAVING A MASTER PLANNER WHO IS
THE ONE THAT RECEIVES THE
INFORMATION WHO CAN LOOK AT THE
ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
FIGURE OUT WHERE THE LIGHT LIGHT
DUTY INFRASTRUCTURE IS GOING IN
AND THE MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
INFRASTRUCTURE EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AND I'M LOOKING
FORWARD. TO CONTINUING THAT
DISCUSSION SO THAT NEXT YEAR
WE'RE NOT WONDERING WHO THE
PLANNER IS.
WILL KNOW WHO THE COORDINATORS I
WANT TO KNOW WHO THE PLANNERS
NOW.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT NO MORE QUESTIONS
PUBLIC COMMENT THANK YOU.
HI HANNAH GOLDSMITH DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ELECTRIC TRANSPORTATION
COALITION AND I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR HAVING THIS
DISCUSSION ON INFRASTRUCTURE
TODAY IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT --
REGARDING THE STATE'S ROLE IN
ADOPTING POLICIES FOR CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE WE WOULD LIKE TO
POINT OUT THE NEED FOR BALANCE
AND UNDERSCORE THAT THE FOCUS
SHOULD BE ON THE RAPID EXPANSION
OF CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE.
CURRENTLY THE DIVISION OF
MEASUREMENT STANDARDS WHICH THAT
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
ARE CONSIDERING REGULATIONS
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE THE RETROFIT.
OR MORE LIKELY THE REPLACEMENT
OF EXISTING CHARGING STATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA AND WHICH WOULD ADD
COSTS TO FUTURE CHARGING
STATIONS -- KELLY TO SEE IS
CURRENTLY WORKING WITH BOTH
AGENCIES ON THESE PROPOSALS AND
WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THE REGULATIONS
AS CURRENTLY PROPOSED.
AS HAS BEEN MENTIONED THE STATE
UTILITIES AND OTHERS HAVE SPENT
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS TO PUT IN
OUR CURRENT NETWORK OF CHARGING
STATIONS AND REQUIRING THE
REPLACEMENT A RETROFIT.
OF THE STATIONS RISKS OURS OF
AIR QUALITY CLIMATE AND PUBLIC
HEALTH GOALS AND I JUST WANT TO
UNDERSCORE WHAT KERRY FROM THE
CPUC SAID THAT GRANDFATHERING
REALLY SHOULD BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY
FOR THESE REGULATIONS.
ARE ASK OF YOU IN THIS REGARD IS
TO PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
OVERSIGHT OF THESE REGULATORY
PROCESS SEES. TO ENSURE THE
REGULATIONS WILL NOT HINDER OR
REVERSE OUR PROGRESS TO ACHIEVE
THE NEEDED LEVELS OF CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE STATE
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS MICHAEL
HIMSELF THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
STATION JUST WANNA START MY
COMMENTS BY THINKING FOLKS HERE
FOLKS FROM THE C. Q. C. A. R. B.
AND C. C..
R. FOR ALL THEIR GREAT WORK ON
TRANSPORTATION LIKE VACATION.
I KNOW I'M FOR UNFORTUNATELY
WHAT I WANT TO SAY THAT DESPITE
ALL THE GREAT PROGRESS IN THE
INVESTMENTS ARE BEING MADE --
WERE STILL FALLING SHORT OF WHAT
WE NEED TO ACTUALLY HIT SCALE I
AND THERE'S A QUESTION WITHIN
THE STAFF ANALYSIS -- OF WHETHER
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD CONTINUE
OR RATHER -- AUGMENT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL INVEST
IN LIGHT DUTY -- VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE BY ALSO INVESTING
IN MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
INFRASTRUCTURE I WOULD SAY
THAT'S AN UNEQUIVOCAL YES --
FROM THE TRANSIT INDUSTRY SO WE
GIVE YOU JUST SOME PERSPECTIVE
ON THERE WAS MUCH DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE CPC'S CONTINUED
INVESTMENTS.
IN MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE
TRANSIT INDUSTRY THAT AMOUNTS TO
A MINIMUM INVESTMENT OF ABOUT
FIFTY TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS.
THAT'S STATEWIDE AND THAT IS
CURRENTLY ONE TIME.
WE'VE GOT ABOUT TEN THOUSAND
VEHICLES THAT NEED TO BE CHARGED --
AND THAT AMOUNT OF FUNDING WILL
JUST SIMPLY BE INADEQUATE FOR US
TO GET THERE AND SO I DO THINK
THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE A A
CONTINUED FOCUS.
FROM THE LEGISLATURE MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY. TO MAKE THIS
TRANSITION AND I DO THINK THAT
IT CAN BE -- PINPOINT IN A FEW
KEY AREAS -- LARGELY WITH
TRANSIT AGENCIES AND BRINGING
THEM TO SCALE WE'VE GOT A LOT OF
AGENCIES ARE OPERATING ABOUT A
DOZEN TRANSIT BUSES VERY FEW
THAT ARE OPERATING ANYTHING MORE
THAN THAT. FOR US ACTUALLY PROVE
THAT THIS TRANSITION IS IS
FEASIBLE AND IT'S A VIABLE WE
DIDN'T MAKE SOME INVESTMENTS IN
LARGE SCALE.
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THAT HAS A A
BENEFIT NOT ONLY ALLOWING THAT
TRANSIT AGENCY TO MAKE THAT
TRANSITION TO FULLY ELECTRIFIED
THE LESSONS LEARNED THAT WILL
COME FROM THAT CAN BE PORTED
OVER INTO OTHER HEAVY DUTY
APPLICATIONS SO AS A MEANS OF
KIND OF FOLLOWING A ARBY'S LEAD.
OF INVESTING IN TRANSIT AS A
BEACH HEAD TECHNOLOGY WE NEED
ALSO INVEST IN THE HEAVY DUTY
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR TRANSIT AS A
BEACH HEAD TECHNOLOGY THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HELLO RICHARD CHORE SKI WITH THE
EEVEE CHARGING ASSOCIATION -- WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE STATE'S TV
DEPLOYMENT GOALS WHICH REQUIRE
ROBUST NETWORK OF CHARGING
STATIONS.
AND THE STATE'S COMMITMENT TODAY
WITH FUNDING IS HELP MAKE THAT A
REALITY AND LEVERAGE A LOT OF
PRIVATE INVESTMENT.
WE WANT TO STRONGLY ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH THE COMMENTS OF
THE CALLIE T. C. WITH REGARD TO
THE PENDING DISCUSSION AND
POSSIBLE DEPLOYMENTOF STANDARDS.
THAT WOULDLIMIT THE AMOUNT OF
TOTAL CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT COULD BE AFFORDED IN THE
STATE.
TODAY STAFF REPORT RECOGNIZES
THE NEED TO BALANCE CHARGING
STATION TECHNOLOGY STANDARDS
WITHOUT OVERLY IMPACTING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE DEPLOYMENT.
HOWEVER THE AIRPORT IS CURRENTLY
CONSIDERING A REGULATION THAT
COULD THREATEN A DECADE OF
CHARGING STATION INVESTMENTS AND
RESTRICT THE ABILITY THE
INDUSTRY'S ABILITY TO DEPLOY
MORE INFRASTRUCTURE.
WERE ENGAGED IN THE REGULATORY
PROCESS AND WILL CONTINUE ENGAGE
WITH A A. R. B. STAFF TO ENSURE
A BALANCE OF TECHNOLOGY -- AND
APPROPRIATE STANDARDS AS A
REPORT IDENTIFIES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKUP PRAY WITH A
PRIME A KELLY ON BEHALF OF
CHARGE POINT.
THEIR LEADING PROVIDER OF THE V.
INFRASTRUCTURE BASED IN CAMPBELL
AND I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR RAISING THIS ISSUE.
OF EVEY INFRASTRUCTURE AND
PUBLIC ACCESS WHO WERE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF INSURING THAT
PUBLIC ACCESS IS THERE FOR ALL
COMMUNITIES.
IN INCOME LEVELS I ALSO WANT TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE BY THE
CPUC CALLIE T. C. AND THE AB
CHARGING ASSOCIATION.
THAT WE LOOK AT INSURING THAT --
THE EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURES
GRANDFATHERED IN AND ON ANY
STANDARDS BUT AS WE LOOK FORWARD
TO ESTABLISHING PUBLIC ACCESS
STANDARDS THERE WERE ALSO
MINDFUL OF THE RAPIDLY CHANGING.
TECHNOLOGY THAT ALLOWS FOR
PUBLIC ACCESS AND THE
METHODOLOGIES FOR PAYMENT AND
THAT WE NOT IN.
FOR INTERFERE WITH THAT AND NOT
LOOK TO OR RELY ON NINETEEN
FIFTIES TECHNOLOGY BUT LOOK FOR
TO HELP PAYMENT IS GOING TO GO
FORWARD WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND LOOK AND YOUR CONTINUED
OVERSIGHT.
SURE MEMBERS DANTRELL WITH TOUGH
LOVE A ALSO WON A A REPEAT
REITERATE -- SOME OF THE
CONCERNS OF THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS ONLINE -- OURSELVES
WITH THE THEIR CONCERNS -- BEEN
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE WORK
THE HARD WORK THAT ALL THESE
AGENCIES ARE DOING -- ON THE AB
INFRASTRUCTURE SIDE IT TRULY IS --
HERCULEAN A CHALLENGE -- ALSO
PARTICULAR WANNA GIVE A SHOUT
OUT TO GO BATES AND THEIR
EFFORTS ON THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE PERMITTING GUIDE BOOK WHICH
REALLY IS INTENDED.
TO ALIGN -- WHAT HAPPENS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL DOWN IN THE WEEDS
WITH THE STATE LEVEL GOALS AND
AND THAT IS A HUGE HUGE
CHALLENGE -- TO ENSURE A
HUNDREDS OF OF JURISDICTIONS --
LOCAL GOVERNMENT JURISDICTIONS.
NOT ONLY HAVE THE TOOLS AND
RESOURCES BUT ALSO YOU KNOW ARE
ARE AWARE THAT THE STATE LEVEL
GOALS ARE IMPORTANT -- TO MEET --
AND LIKE MANY -- PERMITTING --
EFFORTS STREAMLINING EFFORTS
THAT YOU HAVE PASSED -- IT'S
IT'S THE HIGHER LEVEL -- STAPLES
THAT EVERYONE HE'S TAKING
CONSIDERATION SO THAT THE WORK
THE GOV IS DOING IS TRULY
INVALUABLE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
THE THE HARDWORKING TIME THE
PUTTING THAT THAT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THIS IS THE INFORMATION NOT ONLY
ITEM SO WE'LL BRING THAT ONE TO
A CLOSE THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION.
WILL MOVE ON NOW TO ISSUE THREE
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE RAPIDLY
THROUGH THE REST OF THE AGENDA
BECAUSE PEOPLE HAVE.
PLACES TO GO AND PEOPLE TO ME --
AND WE'RE GONNA.
WE'RE GONNA LOSE MEMBERS RAPIDLY
FREE.
TO MOVE THINGS ALONG SO IF WE
COULD -- IS IT POSSIBLE TO
COMBINE ISSUES THREE AND FOUR AT
ONE LOCATION TATIAN THAT BE
GREAT AND THEN WE'LL TAKE.
QUESTIONS AND PUBLIC COMMENT AND
TO SEE IF WE CAN'T GET A MOTION
ON THE TABLE.
OKAY WHAT IT SAID THAT I AM ET
CHIANG FROM THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD AND SAID THESE
THESE ARE ISSUES THREE AND FOUR
TOGETHER.
SO IS ABOUT TO CHANGE PROPOSAL --
FOR SB ONE IMPLEMENTATION AND
ALSO FOR THE TRUCK ONE PROGRAM.
SO ON THE TRUCK AS A MINISTER
WITH THE TRUCK LOAN PROGRAM
ACTUALLY -- START WITH WE HAVE A
TRUCK AND BUS REGULATION AND
WITH THIS REGULATION DOES IS IT
CLEANS UP THE EXISTING ON ROAD
TRUCK AND BUS FLEET IT PROVIDES
IMMEDIATE AIR QUALITY BENEFITS.
ESPECIALLY TO COMMUNITIES AT OR
NEAR BUSY ROADWAYS AND FREIGHT
HUBS.
SB ONE CONTAINS A PROVISION THAT
STARTING IN TWENTY TWENTY DMV
HAS TO VERIFY THE TRUCKS MEET
THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE TRUCK
AND BUS REGULATION.
BEFORE REGISTRATION IS ISSUED SO
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS GOING TO
INCREASE PEOPLE'S -- CONTACTING
OF AIR BEAT TO UNDERSTAND
WHETHER THEY ARE IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THIS REGULATION WHAT THE
IMPACT IS GOING TO BE.
AND ALSO IT'S GOING TO INCREASE
THE DRAW ON THIS TRUCK LOAN
PROGRAM ON THE TRUCK ONE PROGRAM
IS ADMINISTERED IN COORDINATION
WITH THE CALIFORNIA POLLUTION
CONTROL FINANCING AUTHORITY.
IT BASICALLY USES PUBLIC FUNDING --
AND LEVERAGES PRIVATE FUNDING SO
THAT FLEET OWNERS THEY CAN'T GET
A LOAN USING CONVENTIONAL LOAN
CRITERIA ARE ABLE TO QUALIFY
BECAUSE THE LOAN IS BACKED BY
THE STATE.
I'M WE'RE ASKING FOR AN
AUGMENTATION OF NINETEEN POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN FISCAL
YEAR.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY THAT
WOULD BRING THE TOTAL ASSISTANCE
TO FORTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
N THAT FISCAL YEAR AND WILL
COVER LOANS FOR ABOUT SIXTEEN
THOUSAND TRUCKS.
THIS IS A REALLY KEY COMPONENT
OF HELPING SMALL BUSINESSES
COMPLY WITH THE TRUCK AND BUS
REGULATION -- ESPECIALLY BEFORE
THESE SB ONE REQUIRE ITS HEAD.
I'M SB ONE HAS -- I'VE TALKED
ABOUT SORT OF ONE OF THE PRIMARY
PIECES OF IT THE OTHER TWO
PIECES THAT AFFECTS THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD.
WERE REQUIRED TO DO YOU AN
EMISSIONS ANALYSIS OF ON THE OF
THE MISSION COMPONENTS UNDER SB
ONE AND THERE WERE ALSO REQUIRED
TO COORDINATE WITH CALTRANS NCTC.
ON GRANT GUIDELINES -- SO UNDER
THE ISSUE FOR WERE ASKING FOR
THIRTEEN THREE YEAR LIMITED TERM
POSITIONS FOR COMPLIANCE
ASSISTANCE AND ENFORCEMENT. ONE
THREE YEAR LIMITED TERM POSITION
FOR THE EMISSIONS ANALYSIS AND
THEN ONE PERMANENT POSITION FOR
DEVELOPING PLANNING GRANT
GUIDELINES AND CONSULTATION WITH
THE CDC AND CALTRANS.
I'M GONNA LEAVE IT THERE AND IF
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS I'D BE
HAPPY TO GO INTO MORE DETAIL
THANK YOU QUESTIONS SO ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS FROM ALEJO.
FINANCE -- IS THERE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON EITHER OF THESE ITEMS.
AND IT WOULD THAT BE ISSUES
THREE AND FOUR WITH WONDERFUL.
WERE GONNA TAKE THESE UP
SEPARATELY AFRICA NO NOT MY
FAULT FOR NOT REMEMBERING -- SO
NUMBER.
THREE WAS THERE A SECOND.
WITH.
WILLIAM HI.
FONG [inaudible]
GARCIA MULLIN.
PATTERSON RAY S. [inaudible]
REAVIS HIGH.
GREAT SERVICE M. MOST ON ISSUE
[inaudible]
FOR SECOND.
BLOOM HI FONG [inaudible]
GARCIA MULLIN [inaudible]
PATTERSON RADIUS [inaudible]
REVERSED.
GREAT THAT COMPLETES ISSUES
THREE AND FOUR WILL MOVE ON TO
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
AND ISSUES FIVE SIX AND SEVEN WE
HAVE -- A ISSUE FIVE IS A
RECOMMENDATION TO HOLD OPEN --
WELCOME LOOKING FORWARD TO YOUR
BRIEF [inaudible]
DISCUSSION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
WILL TRY TO BE BRIEF.
HELLO CHAIRMAN AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS -- MY NAME IS BERNARD AS
A VETO I AM THE ADMINISTRATIVE
SERVICES DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
WE HAVE SEVERAL SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS HERE TO PRESENT OUR
REQUEST AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE.
LET ME BEGIN WITH ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE STRENGTHENING THE
ADMINISTRATIVE CORE.
THIS PROPOSAL REQUEST EIGHT
PERMANENT POSITIONS PLUS LIMITED
TERM FUNDING FOR THREE
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS TO
STRENGTHEN THE ADMINISTRATIVE
CORE.
THAT SUPPORT THE CPUC.
AS HIGHLIGHTED IN STAFF COMMENTS
RESPONSIBILITIES AT THE CPUC
HAVE EXPANDED OVER THE YEARS AS
A RESULT OF THE NEW MANDATES.
PROGRAMS AND GOALS.
THE ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF HAVE
NOT GROWN IN HARMONY WITH THIS
EXPANSION.
THEREFORE WE ARE REQUESTING THIS
AUGMENTATION TO PROVIDE THE SEED
P. YOU SEE WITH ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THE COMMITTEES CONSULTANTS
AND HAVE PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION TO SUPPORT THIS
REQUEST WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE THESE
CONVERSATIONS.
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS ON
THIS PROPOSAL.
ANY OTHER -- COMMENTS.
ARE THERE QUESTIONS [inaudible]
THIS RECIPE.
AS NOTED IN THE STAFF COMMENTS --
TO JUSTIFICATION.
THERE'S ADDITIONAL JUSTIFICATION
DATE AT THE BOTTOM LINE IS WISE
BUT WHY ARE THE BUDGET POSITIONS
NEEDED.
AND I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT.
POURTANT TO BE PROVIDED I KNOW
IT'S GOING TO BE HELD OPEN BUT I
THINK THAT THAT INFORMATION
SHOULD BE PROVIDED.
WHAT WE WOULD COUNTERED AT THE
CPUC HAS BEEN -- BOTH INJURIES
ILLNESS AND A LACK OF AN
APPROPRIATE STAFFING FOR
MANDATED -- ACTIVITIES SUCH AS A
MONTHLY REPORTING -- TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE -- THE
CONSTRAINTS OF OUR CURRENT
STAFFING DON'T ALLOW US TO
EFFECTIVELY RESPOND TO FINANCE
IN LA -- AS WE WOULD LIKE TO WE
WOULD PREFER TO DO A BETTER JOB
IN THE FUTURE.
YOU SAY INJURIES AND ILLNESS.
SO ARE THEY OUT.
THEY'RE INJURED OR THEIR ILL AND
THEY'RE OUT OF WORK -- WE'VE HAD
DOES SOME OF LIMITED ABILITY --
TO HAVE STAFF IN THE OFFICE DO
THESE SITUATIONS AND WE HAVE NO
VACANCIES SO WE CANNOT FILL
BEHIND THEM.
AT MEDINA NOT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND WE WOULD APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY WORK WITH STAFF
MORE TO PROVIDE MORE
JUSTIFICATION FOR THESE
POSITIONS.
THANK YOU I THINK IT'S NECESSARY
THANK YOU.
OUR ENTERED THIS WILL BE A HOLD
OPENS ALL HAVE TIME -- FOR FOR
SOME OF THAT DISCUSSION IS THERE
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM.
AND WE WILL -- WE'LL THAT OPENED
HAS SAID AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER [inaudible]
SIX ON GOOD AFTERNOON ON A CHAIR
AND MEMBERS CHRIS PARKS DIRECTOR
OF THE UC'S OFFICE OF THE SAFETY
ADVOCATE OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
ESSAY.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK BEFORE YOU TODAY A BRIEF
BACKGROUND ON ESSAY -- AT THE
END OF TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE UNANIMOUSLY ADOPTED
SB SIXTY TWO CREATING P. UC CODE
THREE OH NINE THAT EIGHT
ESTABLISHING A DIRECT YOU KNOW
SAY TO AMONG OTHER THINGS.
RECOMMEND IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES SAFETY
MANAGEMENT SAFETY CULTURE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE RECOMMEND
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE CITY UC'S
OWN SAFETY MANAGEMENT AND SAFETY
CULTURE IN ITS OVERSIGHT OF
UTILITIES.
AS AN ADVISORY ROLE TO THE
COMMISSION AN ADVOCATE AS A
PARTY IN PROCEEDINGS TO ASSIST
THE COMMISSION.
IN ITS EFFORTS TO HOLD PUBLIC
I'M SORRY JUST.
PUBLIC UTILITIES ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEIR SAFE OPERATION IN -- TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ESSAY
RECOMMENDED ADVOCATED AND
PROMOTED SAFETY MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM IMPROVEMENTS OVER BROAD
RANGE INSPECTION OF UTILITY
PROGRAMS INCLUDING ELECTRIC
WILDFIRE GAS PIPELINE AND GAS
STORAGE -- ALWAYS SAY CURRENTLY
IS COMPRISED OF FOUR SENIOR
ENGINEERS AND THREE SENIOR
ANALYST WITH APPROXIMATELY ONE
THIRD STAFF LOCATED IN EACH OF
THE P. UC'S.
SACRAMENTO LA AND SAN FRANCISCO
OFFICES IN THE LAST YEAR WE HAVE
BEEN ACTIVE IN OVER A DOZEN
PROCEEDINGS AT THE COMMISSION.
AND PER P. UC THREE OH NINE DOT
EIGHT ALWAYS SAY SUBMITS ITS AND
REPORT DIRECTLY TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN JANUARY OF EACH.
YEAR DESCRIBING ITS -- WORK IN
DETAIL.
YOU SEE THREE OH NINE DOT EIGHT
INCLUDES A SUNSET CLAUSE OF
JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY THE END OF THIS
YEAR UNLESS THE SUNSET IS
DELETED OR EXTENDED THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL REQUESTS AT THE SENSE
THAT BE REMOVED TO PROVIDE
THIRTY FOR CURRENT STAFF AND
PROSPECTIVE STAFF.
AS OSA PLANS AND CONTINUES TO
MOVE FORWARD IN ITS WORK TO FILL
THE LEGISLATURE'S VISION WHEN IT
ESTABLISHED ALWAYS SAY.
THAT IS -- ESSAYS PORTION OF
THIS AGENDA SO -- AS AS YOU KNOW
THERE'S A RECOMMENDATION TO
REJECT THIS ITEM BECAUSE THERE'S
A POLICY BILL MOVING FORWARD ON
THIS VERY TOPIC -- AND DID YOU
WANT TO ASK ADD ANY COMMENTS
WITH RESPECT TO THAT.
SPECIFIC ISSUE.
OR THE ADMINISTRATION MIGHT.
I'LL TAKE THAT BRIEFLY -- MATH
MISTLETOE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
WELL FINANCE AGREES THAT POLICY
BILL WOULD ACCOMPLISH THE SAME
GOAL OF REMOVING THE SUNSET DATE --
WE BELIEVE THE TRAILER BILL
PROCESS IS MORE APPROPRIATE AS
THERE ARE POSITIONS PROPOSED UP
FOR THE OFFICE OF SAFETY
ADVOCATE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET [inaudible]
RIGHT.
OKAY AB APPRECIATE THOSE
COMMENTS WE HAVE TO HAVE A
REQUEST FROM THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL -- TO LOOK AT THIS IS A
POLICY BILL BECAUSE THERE ARE.
OTHER ISSUES THAT -- HOW HE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE -- HAD
DISCUSSED AND I THINK THE PROPER
FORM FOR THAT IS IN THE POLICY
CONTEXT.
A MISTER BROWN TO TO ANYONE AND
I MEAN I I THINK I JUST LIKED
OUT OF WE THINK IT'S REASONABLE
TO CONSIDER THIS ISSUE THROUGH
THE POLICY PROCESS THE AUTHORITY
FOR THE OFFICE WAS ORIGINALLY
ESTABLISHED THROUGH THE POSSIBLE
PROCESS WE THINK THAT'S
REASONABLE MENU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS IS A PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS.
WE HAVE A A REQUEST TO REJECT
WHICH TAKES A VOTE -- I THINK
IT'S FAIRLY UNIQUE NATURAL IF
YOU'VE DONE THIS BEFORE AND THE
TIME THAT I'VE BEEN CHAIR BUT DO
WE HAVE A MOTION TO REJECT THE
PROPOSAL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WOULD.
MOVE TO REJECT WITHOUT PREJUDICE
THE PROPOSAL AND DIRECT THE
ADMINISTRATION TO GO THROUGH THE
POLICY PROCESS AS REQUESTED BY.
THE AUTHOR.
PERFECT THANK YOU.
BILL MOTION SECOND.
HELLO I FONG.
GARCIA MULLIN.
PATTERSON RAY S. I READ THIS.
THANK YOU OUR FINAL ITEM IS --
ISSUE NUMBER -- SEVEN PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION AND ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND THIS IS A HOLD OPEN --
RECOMMENDATIONS -- IF YOU COULD
KEEP YOUR PRESENTATION AS BRIEF
AS POSSIBLE WE WOULD APPRECIATE
I WILL TRY MY BEST.
A GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN BLOOM
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS LINDA CEREZO AND I'M THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR AT THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE AND WITH ME
HERE TODAY IS CHLOE LUKENS SHE'S
UP PROGRAM MANAGER OVER ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE MATTERS.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT OUR
BUDGET REQUEST WE ARE REQUESTING
THREE POSITIONS TO WORK N
ELECTRIC INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUES.
ARE INFRASTRUCTURE WORK OF
BREAKS DOWN PRIMARILY INTO TWO
AREAS DISTRIBUTION PLANNING.
AND TRANSMISSION PLANNING AND
PERMITTING -- WITH RESPECT TO
NEW AN ON GOING WORK AND ARE
REQUESTING ONE ENGINEER POSITION.
STARTING IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
DISTRIBUTION PLANNING BECAME AN
ANNUAL AN ON GOING PROCESS THAT
ENTAILS REVIEW AND ANALYSIS OF
COMPLEX TECHNICAL DATA. FOR
EXAMPLE EVERY YEAR EACH UTILITY
WILL PROVIDE AN ASSESSMENT OTHER
USE THEIR SYSTEMS CAPACITY.
FORECASTS OF SUPPLY AND DEMAND
ON THE SYSTEMS AND IDENTIFY
AREAS THAT REQUIRE UPGRADES FOR
CHANGES.
UTILITIES ALSO WHAT IDENTIFIED
THE NEED FOR SYSTEM UPGRADES AND
NEW CONSTRUCTION THAT COULD BE
DEFERRED WITH DISTRIBUTED ENERGY
RESOURCES JUST SUCH AS SOLAR AND
STORAGE.
WE REVIEW ALL THIS INFORMATION
FOR ACCURACY AND TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THE UTILITIES PLANTS
AFFECTIVELY ENSURE RELIABILITY.
AND ARE COST EFFECTIVE THIS
POSITION WILL ENABLE US TO
ADDRESS THIS NEW WORKLOAD.
NOW I'D LIKE TO SWITCH OVER TO
THE TRANSMISSION SIDE OF
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE'RE REQUESTING ONE ENGINEER
POSITION AND ONE ATTORNEY
POSITION TO FOCUS ON INCREASING
AN ONGOING TRANSMISSION PLANNING
ACTIVITIES AND PERMITTING
APPLICATIONS. TO ADDRESS
CONGESTION AND RELIABILITY
ISSUES.
BY THE END OF THIS YEAR WE
EXPECT FOURTEEN NEW APPLICATIONS
FOR TRANSMISSION UPGRADES OR NEW
CONSTRUCTION TO BE FILED AT THE
PC.
THIS IS ON TOP OF APPLICATIONS
ABOUT LAST YEAR THAT ARE STILL
BEING LITIGATED THAT THE CPUC.
IN ADDITION THE UTILITIES WILL
FILE ADVICE LITERATURE SMALLER
TRIP SMALLER TRANSMISSION
PROJECTS WHICH WE MUST ALSO
ANALYZE.
AS YOU KNOW TRANSMISSION
PROJECTS ARE EXPENSIVE.
AND THE UTILITIES TYPICALLY
REQUEST HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN COST RECOVERY FROM
RATEPAYERS.
WE ARE OFTEN THE ONLY PARTY
ASIDE FROM THE UTILITY
PARTICIPATING IN THESE
PROCEEDINGS WE CAN TALK COMP
COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS TO ENSURE
THAT TRANSMISSION PROJECTS ARE
NEEDED.
THAT COSTS ARE REASONABLE AND
WHERE POSSIBLE IDENTIFY COST
EFFECTIVE ALTERNATIVES.
THESE TWO POSITIONS WILL ALLOW
US TO ADDRESS THIS INCREASED
WORKLOAD.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND A
WHAT WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU THE QUESTIONS POSED IN THE
US STAFF REPORT IS -- I THINK --
BECAUSE ACTUALLY WHY WERE THOSE
ANTICIPATED IN THE ORIGINAL --
WELL WHEN WHEN -- YOU ORIGINALLY
REQUESTED POSITIONS TWO YEARS
AGO YES -- CAN YOU -- RESPONDED
THAT AGAIN.
BACK TO TWO YEARS AGO WE OF THE
COMMISSION AND STAKEHOLDERS WERE
JUST STARTING TO BECOME FAMILIAR
WITH WHAT IS INVOLVED IN
DISTRIBUTION PLANNING -- IN
PARTICULAR IT'S A NEW AREA AND
AND THE DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM WAS
NEVER.
BUILT TO TAKE ON THOUSANDS OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLES STORAGE SOLAR
SO IT REALLY.
AT THAT TIME IT WAS NOT
ANTICIPATED THAT THE TYPE OF OF
THE BEGINNING OF THE
DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM WHEN IT WAS
BUILT IN FACT IT JUST NEVER WAS
DESIGNED TO TO TO TAKE ON THAT
KIND OF OF COMMUNICATIONS THAT
ARE INVOLVED.
WITH THESE SYSTEMS LOAD ETCETERA
SO IT REALLY ENTAILS A LOT OF
ENGINEERING ANALYSIS AND IT'S
PRETTY COMPLEX TO MAKE SURE THAT
SERVICES RELIABLE AND SAFE.
AND COST EFFECTIVE AS WELL SO
IT'S JUST THIS IS THIS IS A VERY
NEW TO ALL STAKEHOLDERS
UTILITIES WHAT THE UTILITIES
COMPLAINING OTHER SYSTEMS FOR A
LONG TIME BUT IN TERMS OF
STAKEHOLDERS -- SUCH AS THOSE
WHO WON IN A CONNECT TO THE
SYSTEM NOW STORAGE PROVIDERS.
AGAIN SOLAR -- ELECTRIC VEHICLES
IT JUST IT REQUIRES A WHOLE NEW
LEVEL OF PLANNING AND IT'S IT
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT.
THANK YOU FOR THAT EXPLANATION
THAT YOU WANT TO ADD SOMETHING.
THAT JUST HAVE AN IDEA OF THE
IMPACT SO WE HAVE ABOUT -- EIGHT
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND SO
THE ROOFTOP OF A TAKES -- INTER
CONNECTED RIGHT NOW TO THE GRID
AND THAT'S ABOUT SEVEN THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS OF DEMAND -- WE ALSO
IF IT'S ESTIMATED WHEN WE HAVE
THREE POINT NINE THREE POINT
NINE MILLION ELECTRIC VEHICLES
INTER CONNECTED INTO THE TO THE
DISTRIBUTION GRID THAT'S GOING
TO BE ABOUT 5% OF CALIFORNIA'S
TOTAL -- ANNUAL LOAD SO AS
YOU'RE GETTING A FEEL THE
SYSTEMS BECOMING MORE DYNAMIC
AND SO WE REALLY NEED TO
FORECAST PLAN FOR FOR THIS.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE IT'S
RELIABLE -- WE NEED -- TO ALSO
AS WHEN IT WAS SAYING THE
COMMUNICATION -- YOU KNOW IT
WE'RE NOW TALKING ABOUT HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF POINTS -- OF
GENERATION NOW AND TOOK ACTING
TO THE DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM TO
CREATE DIFFERENT BACK I GOT IT
THANK THANK YOU -- FOR THE
EXPLANATION.
THAT'S HELPFUL ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS PUBLIC COMMENT --
FINANCE AND LA -- YOU'RE GOOD.
THEN -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE PRESENTATION WE'RE GONNA
HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN THAT BRINGS
US TO THE CONCLUSION THAT
MEETING WE HAVE HAD ON VOTES
FROM AT LEAST ONE MEMBER -- AND
WILL DO THIS NOW.
YOU CAN JUST CALL THE MINT.
SO THIS IS ON THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR ISSUES. 246-910-1317
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND TWENTY THE
MOTION WAS TO PROVE THESE ITEMS
FONG.
AND THEN WE'LL TAKE THIS UP
SEPARATELY.
ISSUE NUMBER ONE THE MOTION WAS
TO APPROVE [inaudible]
FONG.
ISSUE NUMBER THREE THE MOTION
WAS TO APPROVE FONG.
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE MOTION TO
APPROVE FONG.
ISSUE SEVEN MOTION TO APPROVE
FONG.
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT MOTION TO
APPROVE FONG.
ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN THE MOTION
WAS TO APPROVE FONG [inaudible]
OKAY.
ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE THE MOTION
WAS TO PROVE FONG.
ISSUE NUMBER FOURTEEN MOTION TO
APPROVE FONG.
ISSUE FIFTEEN MOTION TO APPROVE
FONG.
AN ISSUE SIXTEEN MOTION TO
APPROVE FONG [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT BRINGS THE
MEETING TO A CONCLUSION AND WE
ARE ADJOURNED.
THANKS EVERYBODY [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
YEAH